GOOD MORNING
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE HEARING.
DUE TO THE CONTINUED STAY AT
HOME ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRING THE MASS BE WORN
IN PHYSICAL DISTANCE A. B.
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM RIGHT THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
THE PUBLIC FOR THE PUBLIC TODAY
CAN FORTY TWO OH TWO WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF. AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA SO WE CAN MAKE MAINTAINED
SIX FEET OF SPACING. THEY'RE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM.
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND AND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. OR DIAL IN
WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO BE USING
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO AND I'M
GOING TO REPEAT THAT. THE
NUMBER TO CALL IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO WHEN THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING.
TESTIFYING ON BEGINS THEIR
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVE STREAM BROADCAST IN
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE
ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE
A MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL YOUR REMAIN ON A LIFELINE
AND WILL NEED TO MEET YOURSELF
INTO YOUR CALLED ON TO SPEAK.
IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATE A PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE OUT. NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. THREE NINE FIVE
EIGHT AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP YOU. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. WELL WE ALSO
BEING MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE
OFFICE. WE HAVE FOURTEEN ITEMS
ON THE AGENDA TODAY. EIGHT OF
THOSE ITEMS ARE PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT. OUR CONSECUTIVE SYSTEM
NUMBER SIX TO NUMBER THIRTEEN
WHICH ARE AS FOLLOWS. SB NINE
TWENTY EIGHT. SB NINE TWENTY
NINE. SB NINE THIRTY AND SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY THREE BY THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE. SB NINE NINE EIGHT
AND S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX
BY SENATOR MORLOCK. S. B.
TWELVE TWELVE AND S. B.
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN BY SENATOR
RUBIO. WE ALSO HAVE ONE AUTHOR
WHO IS UNABLE TO PRESENT HIS
BILL HERE WITH US TODAY. I ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB ONE FORTY SIX BY
SENATOR BILL WILL BE PRESENTED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
THANK YOU SIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WE WILL BE HEARING BILLS IN THE
ORDER SHOWN ON OUR AGENDA. WE
WILL TAKE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OR WITH
CONCERNS. THESE WITNESSES WILL
HAVE THREE MINUTES EACH TO
PROVIDE THE TESTIMONY ALL
SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THE POSITION
OF THE BILL ONLY. LET'S SEE IF
I COULD HAVE A QUORUM SECRETARY.
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
AT LACKEY. BLOOM BLOOM HERE
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
HERE RAMOS RAMOS HERE
THREE OF US THE THREE OF US
HERE ROBERT RIVAS RIVAS HERE
VOEPEL. BOTH HERE THANK YOU FOR.
NUMBER ONE. TRANSACTION. WELL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. I'M ASSUMING THE
MICROPHONE IS ON YOU CAN HEAR
ME. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB
ELEVEN TWENTY. THIS BILL ALLOWS
PROPERTY OWNERS TO HAVE
DUPLEXES AND SUBDIVIDE THEIR
PROPERTY IN A SINGLE FAMILY
HOME NEIGHBORHOOD STATEWIDE AS
LONG AS THESE NEW UNITS MEET
EXISTING COMMUNITY STANDARDS
AND PROTECTIONS. SB ELEVEN
TWENTY BUILT ON ARE INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL APPROACH TO
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS. WHICH
IS LED TO A QUADRUPLING OF
APPLICATIONS IN MOST METRO
AREAS AND THE PERMITTING OF
THOUSANDS OF NATURALLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS. THE
UC BERKELEY TURNER CENTER FOR
HOUSING INNOVATION RECENTLY
FOUND THAT IF JUST 5% OF THE
PARCELS ELIGIBLE UNDER THE BILL
CREATED NEW TO UNIT STRUCTURES.
IT WOULD RESULT IN SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND NEW HOMES ALMOST A
QUARTER OF THE STATE'S HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION GOAL OVER THE NEXT
EIGHT YEARS. FURTHERMORE THE
SMALL SCALE NATURE OF THESE
HOUSING UNITS MAKES
CONSTRUCTION MORE ACHIEVABLE
WHILE BUILDING EQUITY FOR
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS WHO WISH
TO BECOME PARTNERS IN SOLVING
THE HOUSING CRISIS CRISIS. THE
BILL CLEARLY RESPECTS THE
PRIORITIES OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND LOCAL LAND USE DECISIONS BY
REQUIRING THAT HOMEOWNERS MEET
SPECIFIC A SPECIFIC LIST. OF
REQUIREMENTS TO PROTECT LOCAL
ZONING AND DESIGN STANDARDS
HISTORIC DISTRICTS
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY AND
EXISTING TENANTS VULNERABLE TO
DISPLACEMENT. SB ELEVEN TWENTY
AS PART OF OUR SENATE'S HOUSING
PRODUCTION PACKAGE WHICH MAKES
MORE HOUSING PRODUCTION
POSSIBLE EVEN WHILE WE CONTINUE
WORKING THROUGH THE NEW
REALITIES IN UNCERTAIN TIMES
CALLS BY THE PANDEMIC. AND OUR
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. AUTHOR
MINUTES BEFORE YOU TODAY
INCLUDE LANGUAGE TO BETTER
ALIGN THE TWO SECTIONS WITH ONE
ANOTHER ADD CLARIFICATIONS TO
EASE IMPLEMENTATION AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES ADD REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS SO WE CAN TRACK
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE BILL
I'M ALSO HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES TECHNICAL
SUGGESTIONS MENTIONED IN THE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF. I
BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSAL AS
ENVISIONED BY MY COLLEAGUES AND
I STRIKES A FAIR BALANCE
BETWEEN THOSE WHO FEEL THIS
BILL GOES TOO FAR. AND THOSE
WHO FEEL THAT IT DOESN'T GO FAR
ENOUGH. I UNDERSTAND THAT SOME
COMMUNITIES REMAIN CONCERNED.
ABOUT PHYSICAL CHANGES THIS
MIGHT BRING TO THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD OR THEIR DISTRICT.
I WANT THEM TO KNOW THAT WE
HAVE TAKEN THEIR CONCERNS TO
HEART AND HAVE WORKED WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT HEIGHT SETBACKS DESIGN
REVIEW. AND THE ABILITY TO
REQUIRE NECESSARY ON SITE
IMPROVEMENTS ARE PROTECTED.
NEVER BEFORE HAS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BEEN SUCH A CRITICAL
ISSUE IT WAS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC IT REMAINS SO.
OVERCROWDING UNAFFORDABLE RENTS
HOMELESSNESS THESE ARE ALL
SYMPTOMS OF OUR HOUSING CRISIS
LONG BEFORE COVE IN NINETEEN.
WITH THESE ISSUES EXACERBATED
BY THE PANDEMIC THE CREATION OF
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IS NOW
A MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH. I
THINK THE ROLE OF GOVERNMENT IS
TO BE PRESENT AND STEP IN WHEN
THERE'S A CRISIS AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE'S VOICES ARE
HEARD. TO WORK WITH EVERYONE ON
A COMPROMISE. AND ULTIMATELY
MOVE THE NEEDLE FORWARD THROUGH
LEGISLATION LIKE SB ELEVEN
TWENTY- I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
THERE IS QUITE A LIST OF
MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT ELEVEN
TWENTY. AND I'M HAPPY TO GO
THROUGH THAT LIST BUT I THINK
I'D RATHER HEAR. FROM YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES- THIS HAS
BEEN A COMPLICATED PROCESS
MONTHS OF DISCUSSION. MEETINGS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND- I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION AND
YOUR COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WHY DON'T
WE TAKE THE AND OF THE WITNESS
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE
LARA. DELVIN VALENCIA. AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION. MODERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE. OPEN THE
PHONE FOR LAUREN EPIC. YES GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
FORMED A VOLUNTEER REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO JOIN
SENATE PRO TEM ABSENT TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AT ELEVEN TWENTY I
WE ALSOREALLY WANT TO THANK
HER FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS
YEAR SENATE HOUSING PRODUCTION
PACKAGE THAT'S ELEVEN TWENTY
REQUIRED BECAUSE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT CONTAINING TWO
RESIDENTIAL UNITS TO BE
CONSIDERED MINISTERIAL YOU BUT
THEN I THINK THANGAL FAMILY
RESIDENTIAL DOWN. AND ALSO
REQUIRES MINISTERIAL APPROVAL
OF THE PARCEL MAP OR TENTATIVE
AND FINAL MAP FOR URBAN LOT
SPLIT THE PARCELS AND
RESIDENTIAL DOWN. TO THIRTEEN
CONDITIONS ARE MET. HOW
PRODUCTION TODAY HAVE FOR. ON
CHEN LARGE. MULTI FAMILY
DEVELOPMENTS AND SMALLER EIGHTY
YEARS. BOTH OF COURSE ARE
IMPORTANT PRODUCT TYPES BUT
THEY DO NOT ADDRESS THE NEED
FOR SMALLER SCALE DEVELOPMENT
THAT CAN COME OUT MIDDLE INCOME
HOMEOWNERSHIP OR ALTERNATIVE
RENTAL HOUSING TYPE. AND S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY. RIGHT THAT
MAKING THREE MONEY BENEFIT FOR
SMALL SCALE DEVELOPMENT BY
ADDING MUCH NEEDED HOUSING
CHOICE IS AN EXISTING SINGLE
FAMILY FOUND THAT WOULD STILL
BE SUBJECT TO LOCAL
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE DENSITY
INCREASES ARE COMPATIBLE WITH
THEIR LOCAL CONTACT. FAVORED
LEVINE HOUSING TYPES AND
PREDOMINANTLY SINGLE FAMILY
FILMS HAVE ALREADY PROVED
SUCCESSFUL IN MANY
JURISDICTIONS. AND THERE ARE
NUMBER OF EXAMPLE THE
NEIGHBORHOODS FOR EXAMPLE IN
SACRAMENTO WHERE DUPLEXES AND
OTHER MULTI FAMILY PROJECT
YOU'VE ADDED BOTH RENTAL AND
FOR SALE UNITS THAT ARE
AFFORDABLE. AND THEY PROVIDE A
NUMBER OF OPTIONS FOR WHERE
PEOPLE TO LIVE. SO THE ELEVEN
TWENTY PROVIDE THE PROPERTIES
THAT WILL STREAMLINE THIS TYPE
OF NEW HOUSING SUPPLY AND
IMPOSE IMPORTANT CONDITIONS
THAT MUST BE MET FOR
DEVELOPMENT APPROVAL. THESE
UNITS MUST BE LOCATED IN INFILL
AREAS COMPLY WITH LOCAL
STANDARDS THAT DON'T PRECLUDE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF TWO UNITS.
AND AVOID PROTECTED AND
SENSITIVE HABITATS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARD. THE BILL
ALSO INCLUDES SAFEGUARDS
DIFFERENT PREVENT THE LOSS OF
EXISTING HOUSING OR
DISPLACEMENT OF POTENTIAL
VULNERABLE TENANTS. IMPORTANTLY
THE BILL SPECIFIES THAT CITY OR
COUNTY MAY APPLY ITS LOCAL
OBJECTIVE DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS
AND LOTS OF DINNER BUT
PREVENTIVE CONSTRUCTION ABOUT
THE TWO UNITS. ON EITHER OF THE
RESULT RESULT IN MOCK WHAT
PERSONAL. THIS ARE CRITICAL
THAT'S THE CRITERIA SIMILAR TO
OTHER RECENT POSITIVE
SUCCESSFULLY ENCOURAGE
DEVELOPMENT TO BUILD A DENSER
PROJECTS WHAT THE ALLOWING
VOCAL OBJECTIVE STANDARDS TO
APPLY AND EITHER REALLY
IMPORTANT POLICIES THAT YOU
CAN'T CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
FINALLY EIGHTY CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUPPORTS LANGUAGE
SETTINGS IN THE OPTION OF THE
ORDINANCE TO IMPLEMENT THE- OF
THE LEFT SB ELEVEN TWENTY
TWENTY CLASS. AND THIS IS THEN
APPLIED TO EIGHTY ORDINANCES AS
WE HAVE SEEN IT IS VERY
SUCCESSFUL AND IT HELPS-
JURISDICTIONS IMPLEMENT THE
REQUIREMENTS QUICKLY AND FORGET
ABOUT ITBETTER TO SET WITH
LOCAL GENERAL PLANS AND STATE
COLLEGE IS. DOING BECAUSE BEING
A PICK CAL IN SUPPORT BALANCE
EFFORTS TO STREAMLINE AND
ENCOURAGE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
PARTICULARLY AS BEEN SAID IN A
TIME WHEN CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO FACE AN UNPRECEDENTED.
HOUSING CRISIS COMPOUNDED BY
THE RECENT AND I. IN OF CODE
THAT PANDEMIC. WE BELIEVE THIS
RIGHT RIGHT. AND A NUMBER TOOL
THAT WERE. IN INCREASED
PRODUCTION HOME. AND WE'RE VERY
PLEASED TO HERE SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE IN OTHER IN THE ROOM THAT
ARE GOING TO. PROMOTE THIS BILL
SORRY. SEEING NONE OPERATOR IF
YOU'D LIKE TO OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WE
WILL TAKE THEIR NAME RIGHT THE
ORGANIZATION. AND THEIR SUPPORT.
REYES AND GERMAN IF YOU DO WISH
TO SHOW SUPPORT IT IS ONE ZERO
OUR FIRST WILL COME FROM THE
LINE SIXTEEN LINE SIXTEEN LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING THIS IS TECHNI FAN ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE WIND.
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHAT. NINE FIFTY
WE CAN HEAR YOU. MOVING ON WILL
GO TO THE. ONE FORTY NINE NINE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MAILING STEPHENS SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF A GROUP OF NEIGHBORS
AND SUNNYVALE WE APPROACH.
OPERATOR WOULD LET'S REMIND
EVERYONE WE ARE ON SUPPORT
CURRENTLY. THANK YOU. ONCE
AGAIN ONCE AGAIN WE ARE ON
SUPPORT ONE MOMENT OUR NEXT
LINE IT COMES ON THE LINE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT NINE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS LOUIS
MONTANA YOU HAVE TO CALIFORNIA
BE CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NECTARS LINE ONE TWENTY NINE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS A FEW MINOR
COULD NOT OPEN THE DAIRY
COUNCIL GOING INTO PORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT IS LINE ONE THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS LISTED BOB NAYLOR
REPRESENTING AT FIELDS TED IN
COMPANY A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
CALIFORNIA BEEN A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING KIM STONE THROWN
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM THE
PRINCIPAL WITNESS FOR THE
OPPOSITION MY NAME IS VANESSA
EXACTLY RIGHT LEADING UP TO THE
FRONT IN A MOMENT IF YOU COULD
PLEASE HOLD ON WE'LL BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO HEAR YOUR
TESTIMONY. MOVING ON TO LINE
ONE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS MAC BUFFY THEME
OVER CALIFORNIA BY THERE'S HERE
BORDELLO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS SAMPLING
BURKE FROM. ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
THAT DIDN'T HELP SACRAMENTO AND
I CALIFORNIANS SUPPORTER THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GONNA
GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
TERRY MARCHAND ARE CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF SANTA MONICA AGAIN BE
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AVENUES DENNIS BOYCE FONG
CALLING FROM VAN NUYS ON BEHALF
OF PASSAGE BEGIN BEING AND THE
STRONG SUPPORT STILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS TRICHINELLA I LIVE IN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY FIVE
SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY OF WINNETKA WITH AFFECT
BMP AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT AT ELEVEN TWENTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE. SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
AGAIN MY NAME IS OFFERED. TO
YOU FROM EAST BAY EVERYONE
CALLING IN. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT IS LINE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY
THE TIME EATEN STROLL WITH THE
BAY AREA HOUSING ADVOCATES ECO
LISTEN AND SUPPORT THANKS THANK
YOU. NEXT IS LINE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THERE- MY NAME IS KIM
SAM TELL I'M WITH- KEEP
PASADENA MOVING. AND I AM
TOTALLY AGAINST THE. BILL UP IS
ME IF. DON'T EXCUSE ME YOU'D
LIKE TO CALL IN DURING OPETH
THIS IS. SUPPORT CURRENTLY.
OPERATOR MOVE. OUR NEXT CALLER
IS BLIND THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JASON RYAN WITH ONLY CALIFORNIA
CITIES WE HAVE A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION ON THIS MATTER
I WOULD GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT
THE AUTHORS ALREADY TAKEN WE
HAVE A FEW OUTSTANDING ISSUES
THAT WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS IN
ORDER TO GET OUR FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. I CAN'T. NEXT IS
LINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EIGHT
CALCULATE FROM THERE BUT WE
CAN'T AND I'M CALLING IT
SUPPORT- SB ELEVEN TWENTY.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO
TO LINE ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS- CONTENDING WITH
INTER COUNTY MD CALLING
REQUESTING YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE FORTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI TEACHER GARY I AM
CALLING ON BEHALF OF LONG BEACH
YOU RE IN SUPPORT OF THE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE
ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
MARLON AFTER WORK ON BEHALF OF
SCHNEIDER ELECTRIC NORTH
AMERICA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
WHAT THE SONNENFELD ON BEHALF
OF SANTA CRUZ SB IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT IS
LINE ONE TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS VANESSA CHáVEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT IS A LINE ONE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT YES IT IS I APOLOGIZE AND
I GOT CU OFF EARLIER- GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DOESN'T MATTER NOT LIKE HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE THREE PIECES
INCLUDE THE SAN FRANCISCO
FOUNDATION AND TMG PARTNERS. AS
WELL THE SAN FRANCISCO AND BAY
AREA PLANNING AND RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION AND HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA ALL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT IS LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM NOT EVEN
COUNTY FAMILY DISTRICT FIFTY ON
BEHALF OF THEM ON FOR I
STRONGLY THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ALEX TOWARDS THE STRATEGY THREE
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF UP FOR
GROWTH ACTION CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT IS LINE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FIFTY
EIGHT POSSIBLE YOU HAVE YOUR
MUTE BUTTON ON. MOVING ON NEXT
WILL GO TO THE LINE ONE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SORRY BUT MY NAME IS
BUT ACTUALLY I'M A WHOLE DAY
FUND IN A WAY FOR THAT OPPOSING
VIEW THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AS A
REMINDER TO ONE ZERO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT NEXT IS
LINE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS FEEL AND THE APPS
FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT LINE IS LINE ONE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS DEFINITELY A CROW FROM
DEPEND CALIFORNIA CALL YOU
SUPPORT A BUTTON HELPING
OFFENSE OF THIS BILL GREAT
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE TO OF
LATE SUPPORT PEOPLE BETTER GET
IN THERE LINE NUMBERS ONE
MOMENT. NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE
LINE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JASON BRYANT OF THE
APPLE CRANDELL HOMES WE ARE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
AMY PARTY WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF HISPANIC REAL
ESTATE PROFESSIONALS AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OPERATOR THESE THE
FINAL CALLS FOR SUPPORT. BACK
TO A ONE LAST ONE AND IT'S LINE
ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS TOM MCCARTY CALLING
FROM CALIFORNIAN B. AND I AM IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OPERATOR WE ARE NOW
GOING ONE MOMENT. WE DID HAVE
ONE MORE YOU UP HERE LINE ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN RIGHT. HI MY NAME
IS LAURIE ALLEN CALLING FROM
OAKLAND I'M CALLING FOR AN END
WITH EAST BAY FOR EVERYONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT. HEARING
NONE WE WILL NOT GOING TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE FORTY
TWO OH TWO FOR OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME ON OVER TO THE-
MICROPHONE. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION WE
ACTUALLY SUPPORT THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL IS A GOOD BILL- BUT
WE DON'T THINK IT GOES FAR
ENOUGH IN TERMS OF RENTER
PROTECTIONS- THERE IS SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE RELATIVE TO RENT
CONTROL BUT- REMINDER THE COSTA
HAWKINS DOES NOT INCLUDE SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES. AS ELIGIBLE FOR
RENT CONTROL SO. THAT PROVISION
DOES NOT TO OPERATE IN THE
CONTEXT OF THIS BILL. WE'RE
ALSO CONCERNED THAT WHILE THERE
IS SOME CONSIDERATION OF NOT
DISPLACING PEOPLE WE ARE NOT
CONCERNED ABOUT DISPLACING
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DISPLACED. WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOMETHING IN
THE BILL THAT PROVIDES SOME
ASSURANCE TO A RENTER. THAT
THEY- ARE GOING TO LAND ON
THEIR FEET- WHEN THEY ARE MOVED
OFF OF PROPERTY THAT'S GOING TO
BE DEVELOPED UNDER THIS BILL-
WE ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE ON
THE AUTHOR TO CONSIDER
AMENDMENTS LIKE THAT THAT WOULD
MOVE US TO A SUPPORT POSITION
THANK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER MARTIN. I'M SOME. OTHER
ANYONE ELSE THE DUDE LIKE TO
TESTIFY HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
TWO. SEEING NONE OPERATOR WE'LL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES THESE ARE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO-
OPPOSED PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO REMOVE
YOURSELF FROM THE QUEUE YOU CA
TOGGLE IT OFF BY PRESSING ONE
ZERO AGAIN OUR FIRST OPPOSITION
IS LINE EIGHTY SIX. PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
OPERATOR JERRY NO
RESPONSIBLE BOOK GO AHEAD. WHAT
WILL GO TO THE NEXT LINE IS
LINE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS BRIANNA CALL PLAYS ON THE
BALL UNTIL THE STATE HOMEOWNER
AT ELEVEN TWENTY DOES NOT
BENEFIT HOMEOWNERS. BELIEVE THE
PORTERS OF THE BILL OUR
DEVELOPERS AND CONTRACTORS
EVERYONE AGAINST IT OUR
HOMEOWNERS. IT'S JUST READ THE
CAPTION ON OUR PROPERTY VALUES
VALUED BY PRIVATE DEVELOPERS
OPPOSE SB ELEVEN TWENTY. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE.
ONE FORTY SEVEN ONE MOMENT OPEN
YOUR LINE. OKAY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN NOW PLEASE GO AHEAD YES
ADDRESS CALL WITH ALAMEDA
SYSTEM CAPITALIST AND- LET'S
SEE IT DOES NOTHING TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THIS IS ALL ABOUT LUXURY HOME
DEVELOPMENT. AND TAKING AWAY
THE AUTHORITY OF OUR ACT LOCAL
PLANNING BOARDS SO I OPPOSE SB
ELEVEN TWENTY. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO THE LINE SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI I'M A PUBLIC
INTEREST HELPING TENANTS
RETURNING HERE IN LOS ANGELES
WHEN HE NEEDS TO BRING A BANKER
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE SMALL
LOT SUBDIVISIONS HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATING TO. LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME COMMUNITIES THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM I SEE IS A TENANTS
RIGHTS ATTORNEY THAT WORKS TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
DISPLACED. REAL ESTATE
SPECULATION I THINK THIS BILL
IS CONTINUED REAL ESTATE
SPECULATION ABOUT FOR A FEW
QUALITY SUBDIVISION BUILT AND
ARE LOWER MIDDLE INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS. I AM VERY VERY
THE WHOLE POINT IS THAT I'M NOT
BEING BILL COMING OUT OF
SACRAMENTO THAT TRY TO REIN IN
REAL ESTATE SPECULATION AND I'M
I'M I'M STOCKTON MAYOR COMPUTER
KIND OF BILLS ARE COMING OUT
OF- THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY I'M
REALLY DISAPPOINTED. AYE AYE.
AYE OPPOSED. THE FELLOW ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NOT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
RAY LOGGER WITH MIXED THE NINE
AND I OPPOSE FIFTY ONE ONE TWO
WELL THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE FORTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I NEED A MAILING
STAFF AND- I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND A GROUP OF
NEIGHBORS A SUNNYVALE WE OPPOSE.
THIS BILL THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT LINE LINE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ME YES IT IS.
OKAY HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
RACHEL ROSE LUCKY ON THE
PRESIDENT AROUND PART BILLS
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL A
CERTIFIED NEIGHBOR CALIFORNIA
THE CHARTER OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES- THE RAMPART VILLAGE
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL HAS
SUBMITTED A RESOLUTION THROUGH
THE LETTER PORTAL WE STAND AS
FERVENT OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN
TWENTY AND ASK YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO
TO LINE AT NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING. MICHAEL KONIG FROM THE
HISTORIC PRESERVATION ZONE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF SUNSET SQUARE
IN LOS ANGELES. WHERE WE
HOMEOWNERS HAD SEEN THE
DEVASTATION WROUGHT BY SMALL
LOT SUBDIVISIONS. WE THOROUGHLY
OPPOSED THE BILL. THANK YOU.
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING JACK AND THE NUMBER OF
CITIZENS PRESERVING VENICE AND
IT BILL MUST BE AMENDED TO
EXEMPT COASTAL BROWN AND
PROTECT OUR SPECIAL COASTAL
COMMUNITY I OPPOSE THE BILL AS
WRITTEN. THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO
TO ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THRAUPIDAE OTHER THAN
THE AREA WOOD COUNTY THE
NEIGHBOR COUNCIL PARK MESA WE
ARE ON. AS BEING IN UPDATE TO
SB A LETTER TWENTY THING
HURRIEDLY COMMERCIAL. IS BEING
GIVEN THE TO RESIDENTIAL MARK
RATE. ELEVEN TO ONLY ALLOW
MASSIVE SPEC TO COME THE IN. IS
A CORD NO WATER HOUSING MIKE.
THE LOW AND LOW RATE THIS WILL
EXACT. MASS SPECULATION SO ONCE
AGAIN OF. SB TWIN THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE IS. HELLO.
MOVING ON WILL TO THE ONE ONE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS A- MY NAME IS. ROBERT
HERE'S A CALL ON MY OWN BEHALF
THAT I PROUD OF A AWAY OF
THIRTY FOUR HANG HOMES WEBER LA.
I OBJECT TO THAT PANNED ATHLETE
IN IS THE TO ON FAMILY.
PARTICULAR DURING THE PANDEMIC
WE FAMILY ARE BEING JUST TRY TO
SURVIVE. ORGANIZED CAN BE YET
DID THE- IS NO. ST THE REAL
ESTATE INDUSTRY IN THE MARKET
ARE SALIVATING OVER THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT FUELS SPECULATION
AND USE THAT HOUSING AS AN
INVESTMENT VEHICLE FOR GLOBAL
CAPITAL. THERE'S NO SHORTAGE OF
LUXURY HOUSING BUT IF YOU WANT
TO SEE MORE LUXURY HOUSING LESS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND MORE
DISPLACEMENT AND EVICTIONS THEN
VOTE FOR THIS BILL WALL STREET
ONLY GUARDS WILL THANK YOU
ESPECIALLY SINCE YOU WILL BE
GIVING THEM THIS GIFT UNDER
COVER OF CODE IT. BUT IF LIKE
ME YOU COMPETE OVER. AND
COMMUNITY OVER TO. PLEASE WORK
ON LEGISLATION WHICH DE
COMMODIFIED HOUSING AND VOTE NO
ON THE CYNICAL CORPORATE
WELFARE BILL WHICH HAS THE
COMMUNITARIAN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ACCERN NEXT WE GO TO ONE SIXTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES LISA MORRIS AND I'M
INVOLVED WITH MANY COMMUNITY AN
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP. ALL OF
MOVED TO THE SUBURBS FOR THE
AMERICAN DREAM OF OWNING A HOME
IN A YARD FOR THE KIDS AND PAT
IS WRONG TO TAKE LOCAL CONTROL
AWAY FROM CITY TO SET THEIR OWN
ZONING GUIDELINES CREATING
THEIR OWN COMMUNITY AND THE
VISION I HAVE. YOU CANNOT
IGNORE ALL YOUR CONSTITUENTS
CITIES HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION A
COMMUNITY GROUPS- OF COME OUT
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. WE DO NOT
WANT TO BE DICTATED TO BY
SACRAMENTO. EVEN THE PRESIDENT
UNITED STATES ROAD BACK IN LIKE
REGULAR REGULATION IN THE H. F.
F. H. S. TO PRESERVE FINGALL
FAMILY NEIGHBORHOOD. THEREFORE
I OPPOSE. THANK YOU MODERATOR
WE HAVE NOW TAKEN EQUAL TIME IN
OSPF OPPOSITION CALLERS NOW
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
CALLERS PLEASE REMEMBER TO TAKE
YOUR PHONE OFF OF MUTE WHEN THE
MODERATOR OPENS THE LINE AGAIN
JUST YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION THANK YOU. GREAT AND
WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
MICHAEL GOLDMAN I AM A CITY
COUNCILMAN FOR THE CITY OF
SUNNYVALE HEART OF SILICON
VALLEY I AM ALSO A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF THE
LOCAL ELECTED. HI CHRIS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATTHEW
BAKER WITH THE PLANE
CONSERVATION THE- ASSEMBLY
PORTLY INTENT OF THIS BILL
SUPPORT. BREAKING UP THE FAMILY
LEARNING HOWEVER WE KEEP THEIR
SENSES URBANIZED AREA IS FAR
FAR TOO BROAD OF A KNACK FOR
OUT OF THE PROVISIONS
INTEGRATION BE OPTIONS TRADING
IN YOUR LOCATION EFFICIENT CARE
THANK YOU EVER CALLERS I WANT
TO REMIND YOU THAT PLEASE JUST
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND.
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CAROL FORD AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PILOTS ASSOCIATION AND WE
OPPOSE SB ONE ONE TWO ZERO
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JUDY
BRUNETTI I'M WITH THE RIVIERA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION IN
TORRANCE AND CALIFORNIA CITIES
FOR LOCAL CONTROL. AND WE
OPPOSE SB ELEVEN THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE OH
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS DAVID
COOK NOW I AM A HOMEOWNER
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF BUT NOT
BEEN SENT HOME COULD FORTY FIVE
YEARS I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS.
AND GRAB THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE UP FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JOHNNY NASH HONEST STAKEHOLDER
HERE IN VIEW HEIGHTS NINE ZERO
ZERO FOUR THREE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE ELEVEN TWENTY THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SHANE KENNEDY LIVABLE
RIVERSIDE AND MORENO VALLEY.
PLEASE CLOSE THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BRENNAN DAWSON WITH YORK
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A COUPLE NOT
BEEN IN A POSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT WE ARE GOING TO
LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS CAROL AUSTIN WILL PROTECTING
OUR FOOTHILL COMMUNITIES- WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
DEVELOPING URBAN WILDLIFE AREA
ENQUIRE. THANK THANK YOU.
NEXTRA UNDERLINED SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JULIE
TO HELP THEM. CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER REPRESENTING KELLY
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
STATEWIDE LOCAL ELECTED LEADERS
RECOGNIZE THEM CERTAINTY OF OUR
POST PANDEMIC CHICHERIN OPPOSE
THE SPECIAL INTERESTS OPPOSE SB.
ELEVEN TWENTY. THANK NEXT LINE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS MICHAEL
STEINER ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTWOOD HIGHLANDS NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE
RESTORATION GO FAMILY HOUSING
EIGHT MILLION HOMEOWNERS IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT ANY INCREASE
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE HIS BILL. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
AT YALE MALL ONE AND I'M ABOUT
THE ALLY ALLIANCE THE LOCALLY
PLANNED GROWTH AND I LOVE THAT
WALMART ARE. JOHN OPPOSED
ELEVEN TWENTY FAILED TO MEET
OUR NEEDS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THANK YOU THANK YOU.
PLEASE REMEMBER YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION. AND YOUR ORGANIZATION.
NEXT LINE IS SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JACQUI
ACKLAND I'M A TORRENT CITY
RESIDENT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL I THINK THERE'S
NOTHING TO. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
LINE IS LINE ONE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS NO WELL
THAT THAT THAT NUMBER YEAH BUT
UNIQUE AND I GB SEVEN STRONGLY
OPPOSES STYLE THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT LINE IS LINE. ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS BARBARA
HAPPENING ON A MEMBER OF THE
CATHOLICS OF THE ASIAN AND SAN
FRANCISCO WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
ELEVEN TWENTY. THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT LINE IS LINE ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS DONNA CHISHOLM FROM FEENEY
VALLEY CALIFORNIA NINE BUT
CITIZENS UNITED FOR RESPONSIBLE
BUILDING AND- OUR NEIGHBORHOOD-
STRONGLY OPPOSES. ELEVEN TWENTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
LINE IS LINE ONE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YES TODD
MACHEN AND PRIVATE CITIZEN-
MARIN COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT IS LINE ONE
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEARING NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON THE LINE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MELISSA MCCAFFREY
REPRESENTING THE AIRCRAFT
OWNERS AND PILOTS ASSOCIATION-
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE- DENTAL I
MEAN TONY THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE EIGHTY ONE. EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
SHONDA MOSTLY PRESIDENT OF THE
VIEW HIGH BLOCK PLUGGABLE OVER
NINE HUNDRED RESIDENTS AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SENATE BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MOVING ON WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE OF FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE ONE FORTY EIGHT. MOVING ON
WE'RE GOING TO LINE EIGHTEEN
LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES YES. MY NAME IS
ANDREW EVANS I'M A STAKEHOLDER
VIEW HEIGHTS DISTRICT GATE.
AREA POLLS IF HE ELEVEN TWENTY.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE ONE NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MAKE A WARRANT. OUT BAY
LIGHTNING CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF
OF HUNDREDS AND THOUSANDS OF
COMMUNITY ADVOCATES. STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTY EXCUSE
ME SB ELEVEN TWENTY WHICH IF
YOU HAVE OTHER BENEFICIAL
INTEREST LAND GRANT YOU MORE IN
THE FAMILY HUNDRED NEXT CALLER
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE. ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONLY MINOR
IS SEAN I THANK THEM THAT ARE
MESA HEIGHT OF. WE IF. SB
ELEVEN TWENTY. THANK YOU.
THANKS IS LINE ONE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS JENNIFER HAGEE OF
SAN FRANCISCO RESIDENT OF
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT NINETEEN I
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE NINETY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
THE INTERLINKING OF A TWENTY
FIVE YEAR RESIDENT HOMEOWNER IN
THE BEVERLY GROVE SECTION OF
LOS ANGELES NOT CALLING ON THE
BEHALF OF AGENT DEVELOPER
SPECULATORS. ABUNDANT BUT I'VE
HOUSING IS NOT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. TWENTY NOTHING TO HAVE
HOUSE. THANK YOU MY NEXT CALL
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE
GOING TO LINE ONE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI WE ADDRESS
CHALLENGES WITH UNITED TO THANK
THE MISSION IN FACT THIS GOES
MISSION DISTRICT THAT HAS BEEN
DEVASTATED BY SPECULATION ON
HOMELESSNESS. THIS BUILDING
THIS BILL IS ANOTHER HAND OUT
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT GOING TO
LINE TWO HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN YES MY
NAME IS TERRY TAKE NAY TEAMED
UP ON THE BOARD OF THE WEST
WITH HILLS PROPERTY OWNERS
ASSOCIATION IN LOS ANGELES WE
FILED FORMAL OPPOSITION TO THE
PORTAL AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
LINE IS A MANAGER FOR. A MAJOR
TAX PICKING FOR RIVIERA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION THE
SOUTH BAY AND CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS FOR LOCAL CONTROL. TO
PUT SOUNDS LOVELY BUT THIS
ALLOWS FOR MARKET RATE HOMES
WHERE ONE IS NOT. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS STEVEN SCHARF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
ELECTED THE MAYOR OF CUPERTINO
AND FORTY YEAR SIERRA CLUB
MEMBER I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI ANNIE
GEGEN IN HOLLYWOOD FROM THE
FRANKLIN CORD THE COALITIONWE
HAD VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED TO THIS
IT'S NOTHING BUT THEY WILL BE
VERY MASCULINE. WE'RE GOING TO
LINE TO- OH TWO NINE TWO OR TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
HOLLY OSBORNE I LIVE IN NORTH
REDONDO BEACH THE DESK MEDIA
FLOW LOPSIDED. AND WE REQUESTED
THAT YOU OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO LINE ONE NINETY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SUSAN
CURSED CHAIR OF THE NEXT THE
NINE CAMPAIGN REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
OPPOSED ELEVEN TWENTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS MIKE THEN CALL UP OF
LOS ANGELES. THE MOBILE
CALIFORNIA UP CLOSE. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD MY
NINETEEN YEAR OPEN. I THANK YOU
MY NAME IS RAY ONE OF THE
CURRENT VICE CHAIR AND FORMER
CHAIR OF THE CITY CUPERTINO
PLANNING COMMISSION I'M AN
ADVOCATE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THE PLEASE OPPOSE SB ELEVEN
TWENTY. ONE LOCAL CONTROL. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE TWO ZERO
EIGHT TWO OH EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES YES
HELLO PLEASE WE'RE GOING TO
JONES. I AM REPRESENTING JERRY
BUTLER BURKE PARK AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. NEXT IS LINES TO ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NOT HEARING A RESPONSE
WILL MOVE ON LINE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JERRY DOUBLE FROM THE LAS
VIRGENES MALIBU COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTING THE
FIVE CITIES AND WE ARE OPPOSED
TO ELEVEN TWENTY. THANK YOU.
NEXT IN LINE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THEY HAVE IT AND THE
NUMBER OF BILL HAD BEEN
BLACKWELL AND I STRONGLY
STRONGLY. I'M NOT SUPPORT. ONE
ONE HUNDRED THANK YOU. NEXT IS
ALIGNMENT TO TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS DOUG HAMBLIN I'M A
HOMEOWNER AND THIRTY YEAR
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES NUMBER
LOCAL FORTY SEVEN AS WELL
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO TO
LINE ONE ZERO FOUR ONE OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS NANCY OKADA I
REPRESENT FIFTEEN VOLATILITY
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE ELEVEN
TWENTY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT ONE IN LINE TO FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
GLEN MANIAN FROM LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA- STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE ONE NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES. A GREAT MY NAME IS
YVONNE JOHNSON I'M A MONUMENT
IN A VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY
FOUND AND CO CHAIR OF
PROTECTING OUR FOOTHILL
COMMUNITY WE OPPOSE THE REQUEST
YOU OPPOSE THICK VERY PLEASANT
MORNING. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THAT COMES NINE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I AM THE PRINCIPAL
OPPOSITION WITNESS. SOMETHING
MAY HAVE HAPPENED TO YOUR ORDER
BUT NEVERTHELESS A GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS LYNETTE TO MCELROY.
AND I REPRESENT LITTLE
CALIFORNIA AND K. WHICH IS CAL
ALLIANCE LOCAL. ALSO I AM
CAPTAIN OF MY BLACK LEATHER
MEMBER CARD WHICH IS LOCATED IN
THE CRENSHAW DISTRICT OF SOUTH
LOS ANGELES LET ME TELL YOU
ABOUT MY STORY WHITE MATTER
THANK YOU. PLEASE GIVE ME THE
BALL WITNESS EXCUSE ME I AM THE
CREDIBLE WITNESS AND I HAVE
THREE MINUTES AND I THANK YOU
SO MUCH- MY HUSBAND IS A VERY
AND I. URGE YOU HAVE NOW TAKEN
EQUAL TIME IN OPPOSITION COLORS
NOW PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY
WE DID TAKE SIX MINUTES OF
OPPOSITIONS A COMMENT EARLIER
ON THANK YOU. WHEN WILL TO LINE
TWO SEVEN. PLEASED AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS A
MALE LARA I AM A HOMEOWNER IN
LAGUNA GAL CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HEY THIS IS IDEA
MADISON IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES
WITH LIBERAL CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT IS LINE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JEANETTE ASHER
AND I'M A HOMEOWNER IN VIEW
HEIGHTS AND I OPPOSED SB ELEVEN
TWENTY. THANK YOU. NEXT IS
ALIGNED TO TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME I AM
CHRISTINE RASMUSSEN I'MA
RESIDENT OF LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA I AM A SINGLE FAMILY
HOMEOWNER AS WELL AS A MULTI
UNIT A RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS
AND I OPPOSE THIS ALONG WITH
MYSELF AND MY NEIGHBORS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON
THE BOTTOM LINE. NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
DAVID CAME ON BEHALF OF THE
BETTER WAY FOR CALIFORNIANS- IT
OPPOSITION AND I'D BE HAPPY.
WELL. WHAT. THANK YOU. BERMAN
UNDERLINED ONE OH SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
RECALL ANTI GENTRIFICATION
ADVOCATE IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
MISSION DISTRICT AND PRESIDENT
OF GLOBAL CALIFORNIA. I STAND
WITH THE SOUTH LA AND OTHER
SENSITIVE COMMUNITIES THAT WILL
BE DEVASTATED BY THE
SPECULATORS LAND GRAB DREAM I
HAVE THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THE
NEXT CALLER IS LINE ONE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO HELLO WE CAN
HEAR IT. HI MY NAME IS BRENDA
ASHLEY AND I LIVE IN AND-
KRISHAN MANNER AREA OF LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY WE HAVE
NINE HUNDRED OR NINE HUNDRED
HOMEBUILDING STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
ELEVEN TWENTY THANK YOU. NEXT
IN LINE TO THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT
IN THE THREE- I REMEMBER PLEDGE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION- THE
BILL FAILED IT JUST IT WILL
RUIN SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOODS THANK YOU BY A
PUNK YOU. MMHM NEXT DEADLINE TO
THIRTY SIX. GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I TRIED GIVING ROSA
MAP OF THE BREADWINNER BY
MENTAL. HOUSING COALITION WE
ARE NOT OPPOSED BUT WE DO
CONCERN ABOUT THE LACK THAT
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT IS
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HABERT I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. ONE ONE TWO I'LL THANK
YOU. NEXT DEADLINE. TO THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS MONICA DRIVE LEVINE AND
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MYSELF MY
IMMIGRANT NEIGHBORS WHO WERE
ABLE TO PURCHASE A HOME AND MY
PARENTS AS WELL WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE MONEY GRAB THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT IN LINE ONE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND HEARING NO RESPONSE WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR WE JUST CHECK
ONE MORE TIME AND THEN WE WILL
MOVE ON. WE DO HAVE QUITE A FEW
THAT JUST JUMPED IN ONE MOMENT
WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT ONE. NEXT
IN LINE TO FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS JANET
FOSTER AND I'M CALLING FROM
LONG BEACH EMB CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE ARE CURRENTLY
STILL IN OPPOSITION SO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO CALL IN WITH YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION.
ONCE AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION IT'S
ONE ZERO THE NEXT IN LINE. ONE
ONE MOMENT. ONE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HEARING NO RESPONSE WILL
MOVE TO THE NEXT LINE TO FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
MORNING MY NAME IS TERRA BEST
KOKAN BIR FOR I'M A HOME OWNER
IN BURBANK CALIFORNIA. AND I AM
STRONGLY. IN OPPOSITION TO BE.
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE AND I DON'T.
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE ONE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BOB RID ITSELF
MEMBER OF CITIZENS FOR TEXTING
TEN PEDRO IN THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL TOWN IN LOS ANGELES.
ONE OF THE FEW CITIZENS TO THE
WHEN THE WHERE THEY FELL AND
OUR ORGANIZATION REQUEST THAT
YOU EITHER I THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE MOMENT AND
THAT WILL COME FROM LINE ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE MOMENT. IT'S
COMING FROM LINE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. YES
MY NAME IS RAY LONG WAY OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AIRPORT A CALIFORNIA
COUPLE COOPERATE OF CORPORATION
REPRESENTING PUBLIC AND
PRIVATELY OWNED AIRPORTS IN THE
STATE AND THE ASSOCIATION
OPPOSES SB ONE ONE TWO ZERO
THANK YOU. NEGATIVE IMPACTS
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND THAT IS
LINE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THAT
ME YES IT IS YEAH. OCT MY NAME
IS PAMELA GIVE BERMAN ON A
MEMBER OF THE PANORAMA CITY
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL THIS BILL
ALLOWS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BYE NEXT CALLER PLEASE WELL I'M
IN. OUR NEXT CALLER'S LINE TO
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO. NINE TO
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES YES. HI THIS IS
BEACH INNER CITY COUNCIL VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO OPPOSE SB ELEVEN
TWENTY GIVEN THEIR NO
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS THIS
CALL LADIES. WE'RE GOING TO
LINE UP ONE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THAT
MAKES YES IT IS YES. HI BOB
THANK YOU- I DIDN'T MARK GOTTEN
FROM COMMUNITIES UNITED EIGHTY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF THE
PROTECTION OF THE CLUB AND IN
AGREEMENT WITH MAYOR GARCETTI'S
OPPOSITION TO YOUR BILL THANK
YOU ALSO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE TO
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM WENDY
MOGUL HOMEOWNERS THE TO LOOK A
LAKE LOS ANGELES AREA AND
FORMER MEMBER OF THE GREATER TO
LOOKALIKE NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL
I STAND WITH MY FELLOW
HOMEOWNERS IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL NINE ZERO TWO AND
ALSO SENATE BILL. ONE ONE TWO
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
ROUND ALIGNMENT. FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THERE MY NAME'S KIM
WOULD KEEP PASADENA MOVING AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT IN LINE TO TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARLENE AT
ARMADOS CITY COUNCIL NUMBER BUT
IT'S ABOUT THE BEACH CALLING IN
OPPOSITION AT ELEVEN TWENTY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE TO THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I NAME IS STACY TRAVIS
REPRESENT A GROUP OF HOMEOWNERS
AND RENTERS IN WESTCHESTER
CALIFORNIA CALLED- AT IT
RESPONSIBLE GROWTH WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO BILL ELEVEN
TWENTY DUE TO THE LACK OF
RESOURCES. THE WATER. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE THE FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FIFTY
TWO. MY NAME IS ROMEO MELLOW
RENDON INSTALLED FOR ANGELES
AND I'VE CALLED A LOVE IN
TWENTY THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE TO FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BRENDEL GET EACH YEAR
GRANADA HILLS I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK WHAT WHAT THE
CISCO DOES NOT WORK EVERYWHERE
THANK YOU MATCH. THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. OUR FINAL IN Q.
RIGHT NOW IS LINE TO FIFTY THEY
HAVE DISCONNECTED FROM IT WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR ALL THOSE THAT
PARTICIPATED THIS MORNING I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK- IF ANY OF
OUR- COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE SENATOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR NO NO. MATTER
SPEAKER PRO TEM I AM. I WANTED
TO ASK A QUESTION ON THE MORE
ON THE FOUR PLEXUS THAT ARE OUT
THERE IN THE DUPLEXES IN THOSE
AREAS AS IT WAS THERE STILL
DIALOGUE HAPPENING WITHIN THE
BUILDING TRADES- AS WE MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD. I AM AWARE
THAT- WE HAVE GOTTEN A RECENT
COMMENTS FROM. SOME OF THE
BUILDING- COMMUNITY AND- WE
JUST BECAME AWARE OF THAT SO.
AS IT RELATES TO THE QUESTION
WE WILL OBVIOUSLY CHECK IN WITH
THEM WE HAVE HAD MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS. OBVIOUSLY
COMMENTS STILL COMING IN BUT-
I'M PREPARED TO LOOK AT
WHATEVER RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
CAME AND I THINK JUST THIS
MORNING. IN TERMS OF THE FOUR
PLEXUS- YOU KNOW THERE HAS
BEEN- QUITE A BIT OF CONFUSION
ABOUT. WHAT'S ALLOWED SO LET ME
JUST BE VERY CLEAR RIGHT NOW
EXISTING LAW SAYS. I YOU CAN
HAVE TWO UNITS ONE PRIMARY
RESIDENCE AND ONE EIGHTY YOU
BASED ON OUR A. D. LAW.
LEGISLATION SB ELEVEN TWENTY-
WITH NO EXISTING EIGHTY YOU ON
THE PROPERTY CURRENTLY FOUR
UNITS TWO DUPLEXES A LOT SPLIT
TO INTO. ELEVEN TWENTY EXISTING
A DO YOU ON THE PROPERTY
ALREADY FOR TWO DUPLEXES THE
EIGHTY YOU BECOMES A PRIMARY
RESIDENCE ONCE THE LOT IS
SPLIT. THE LOT SPLIT AND A DO
YOU FOR TWO PRIMARY RESIDENCES
AND TWO EIGHTY USE. DUPLEX IN A
D. U. THREE ONE DUPLEX ONE
EIGHTY YOU SO FOR OUR IN ALL OF
THOSE CASES WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF THE DUPLEX EXISTING AND A D.
U. THREE. SO THE CONCERNS THAT
PEOPLE AND I UNDERSTAND HOW
PEOPLE GET CONFUSED WITH THE
COMPLEXITY OF LEGISLATION AND
OUR ATTEMPTS TO PUT PARAMETERS
AND TIGHTEN UP SOME OF THE- THE
CRITERIA. BUT YOU KNOW I'VE
HEARD THINGS FROM TWELVE UNITS
STATE NOW FOUR AND THREE WITH
THE DUPLEX AND IDEA TO BE CLEAR
AND IN TERMS OF THE QUESTION
YOU ASKED WE WILL LOOK AT THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND RICK AND
SUGGESTIONS AS WE LEAVE HERE
BETWEEN NOW AND APPROPRIATIONS
WE WILL HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
AND WE WILL GET BACK TO YOU
DIRECTLY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND THE FURTHER
DISCUSSION. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LUCKY YEAH MINE'S NOT A
QUESTION LINES JUST AND AN
EXPLANATION OF MY VOTE. I WILL
PROBABLY HAVE TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL FOR. DIFFERENT REASONS THE
EXPRESSED OVER THE PHONE FACT
IS I'M QUITE. AMUSED AND
THANKFUL FOR THE COMPROMISE IN
THE AND THE SUPPORTERS THE
PLURALITY AND THE UNUSUAL A
COLLECTIVE GATHERING OF
OPINIONS THAT YOU'VE BEEN ABLE
TO PUT TOGETHER HOUSING BILLS
ARE VERY VERY DIFFICULT. BUT
ALL OF US AGREE THAT OUR
HOUSING SITUATION IS IN A
CRISIS. AND SO WHERE DO WE SEEM
TO BE A STALEMATE EVERY TIME WE
TRY TO DO SOMETHING REASONABLE.
AND IT'S NOT UNCOMMON THAT
CAN'T BOTH THE WAY I WANT TO
VOTE BECAUSE MY DISTRICT IS
VERY COMPLICATED. AND THERE ARE
MANY TIMES. A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIMES RIGHT VOTE
DIFFERENTLY. THEN I MY PERSONAL
OPINION. MY DISTRICT HAS
OVERWHELMINGLY. GIVEN ME A
ROBUST RESPONSE IN OPPOSITION
PREDICTABLY SO YOU GOTTA
REMEMBER DESK IS OPEN ON THE
BEGINNING OF THE DESERT RIGHT
AND SINGLE FAMILY HOMES ARE
VERY SICK. IN THE MINDS OF MY
RESIDENTS MOST MY RESIDENTS. IN
MY DISTRICT IS SO ANYTIME
THERE'S A DENSITY INCREASE. OF
RELAXATION. IT'S SUPPOSED
REALLY STRONGLY AS WHEN I WAS
ON CITY COUNCIL THAT'S WHAT
DREW ALL THE PEOPLE IN OUR
COUNCIL MEETINGS IN PROTEST AS
WHEN WE HAD ANY KIND OF-
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE DENSITY IN
IT THAN A- RESIDENTIAL DISTRICT
AND SO IT'S VERY PREDICTABLE
BUT I. THERE WAS A VOTE THIS
THAT TRIGGERED A LOT OF
RESPONSE AND SO NONETHELESS I
WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT I THINK
YOU YOUR IF I WAS VOTING NAY I
WOULD GLADLY SUPPORT BUT I
WOULD BE BETRAYING THE
OVERWHELMING RESPONSE TO MY
DISTRICT AND SO I FEEL
COMPELLED TO. ANSWER THAT CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LUCKY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US.
THANK YOU- MADAM PRO TEM FOR
WORKING ON THIS BILL AND
HOUSING PRODUCTION I KNOW THAT
THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN VERY
IMPORTANT TO YOU AND TO-
SEVERAL SENATORS- YOU KNOW
WE'RE IN A HOUSING. YOU KNOW
AND WHICH IS FEEDING INTO OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON- I DIDN'T TALK- TWO
GROUPS OF MY CONSTITUENTS THAT
HAD CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL-
AND WHEN IT WHICH THEY ALSO
HAVE HAD CONCERNS ON EIGHTY
USE- IN THE PAST BUT- MAINLY
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
EXPRESSED THIS TIME WERE AROUND
WILDFIRES OWNS- EVEN THOUGH I.
YOU KNOW MY DISTRICT IS AN
URBAN AREA IT'S PART OF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES- PARTS OF
IT ARE ALONG THE FOOTHILLS-
LIKE ESPECIALLY THE SUNLAND
TUJUNGA AREA WHICH IS A
COMMUNITY OF LOS ANGELES. AND
BUT I DID VERIFY THAT THAT AREA
WAS DESIGNATED RIGHT AS A FIRE
HAZARD ZONE WHICH I BELIEVE
THAT. YOUR BILL. THIS WOULDN'T
APPLY THIS. I JUST WANT TO COME
THAT THAT'S THE- THAT YOU- YOU
ARE RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER VERY
FIRE- PRONE AREAS ARE EXEMPT IN
THIS BILL- THERE HAS BEEN A
REQUEST THAT WE ALSO EXEMPT LOW
YOU KNOW OTHER LESSER DEGREE OF
HIGH FIRE. ZONES LOCAL CONTROL
AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
THE ABILITY TO ENSURE- HOW
DEVELOPMENT OCCURS IN- THOSE
LESSER ZONES BUT LEAD BENEATH
VERY HIGH FIRE ZONES MY WHOLE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO IS LISTED-
MUCH LIKE LARGE PARTS OF LOS
ANGELES- THAT IS THE PART THAT
IS ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL AND
WORKING WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO ENSURE OTHER THEY CAN MAKE
THE DECISION THEY'RE ABOUT HOW
BEST TO BUILD IN THOSE AREAS SO
VERY HOT FIRE AREAS EXEMPT-
BELOW THAT CATEGORY IT'S LEFT
TO LOCAL DISCRETION TO
DETERMINE HOW TO BUILD IN THOSE
AREAS. OKAY THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY SEEING NONE- I
HAVE A MOTION. FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS DO
I HAVE A SECOND. SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. AND I'M SURE
YOU'VE GIVEN ME A GREAT DEAL OF
TIME SO LET ME BE VERY QUICK
AND JUST THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR BEING
WILLING TO SPEND SO MUCH TIME
TO LISTEN TO THE CONCERNS AND
THE SUPPORT EXPRESSED BY THE
WITNESSES TODAY I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF THOSE WITNESSES MANY OF
THE CONCERNS EXPRESSED WE HEARD
DURING THE LAST SIX MONTHS OF
DISCUSSION AND TRYING TO PUT
TOGETHER A PACKAGE OF
PRODUCTION BILLS. AROUND I
WOULD JUST SAY YOU MORE THAN
ANYONE UNDERSTANDS AS OUTLINED
BY THE VICE CHAIRMAN THE
COMPLEXITY OF TRYING TO DO-
LEGISLATION AROUND HOUSING
WHETHER WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY AND SUBSIDIES
PRODUCTION AND SUPPLY
REGULATION AND SEEK WORK ALL OF
THOSE THINGS ARE ISSUES ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS YOUR
BODY AND THE ASSEMBLY IN THE
SENATE OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. HAS PRODUCED SOME
INCREDIBLE PACKAGES OF HOUSING
BILLS WE CONTINUE THE ASSEMBLY
DOES THE SENATE DOES TO TRY TO
FIND THE SPOT IN WHICH WE
ADDRESS ALL OF THOSE ISSUES
THIS BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS ALL
OF THOSE ISSUES. IF MONEY AND
SUBSIDIES WERE THE THING THAT
WOULD GET US A PRODUCTION AND
MORE HOUSING UNITS FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS. I THINK THAT'S
ACTUALLY EASIER IT WASN'T
PREVIOUSLY BUT IT'S ACTUALLY
BEEN EASIER TO FIND SUBSIDIES
IN MONEY IF WE DON'T ADDRESS
THE PRODUCTION ISSUE THE SUPPLY
AND DEMAND ISSUE IN WAYS THAT
ARE- APPROPRIATE WORKING WITH
OUR LOCAL PARTNERS- CITIES AND
COMMUNITIES- I HEARD A LOT OF
THE CONCERNS THAT PEOPLE
EXPRESSED I WOULD URGE US TO
CONTINUE TO TRY TO EDUCATE OUR
CONSTITUENTS MANY OF THE
FIERCELY EXPRESSED WE TAKING
CARE OF IN TERMS OF. ALLOWING
THE LOCAL JRISDICTIONS TO PUT
THE PARAMETERS AND THE
SUSPENDERS AROUND IT WE OF YOU
KNOW APPRECIATE SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOODS I LIVE IN A
SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOOD IN
WHICH WE STARTED TO SEE A D
USE AND OTHER THINGS IT ISN'T
JUST ABOUT SPECULATION THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE NEED
TO ADDRESS S. AND I. WILL JUST
SAY. THIS BILL WANTS TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S AFFORDABILITY ONE
EIGHTY USE CAME ONLINE WHAT WE
LEARNED FROM THE DATA COMPILED.
BY IS THAT EIGHTY USE RENT AT
BELOW MARKET RATES. 62% OF THE
MEDIAN INCOME THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT. THE BILL SPECIFICALLY
LIMITS INDIVIDUALS FROM
RECEIVING MINISTERO LOT SPLITS
ON ADJACENT PARCELS AS A WAY OF
PREVENTING INVESTOR
SPECULATION. SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT- THIS IS
TOO CRUDE TO CORRECT A PROBLEM
OF. OF SUPPLY THE BILL FURTHR
BANS PROPERTIES WERE TENET HAS
RESIDED IN THE PAST THREE YEARS
FROM MOVING FORWARD WITH ANY
DEMOLITION. OF THE EXISTING
RESIDENTS. TO PREVENT
PROFITEERING INDIVIDUALS FROM
EVICTING EXISTING TENANTS SO. I
COULD GO ON BUT YOU'VE GIVEN ME
SO MUCH TIME I JUST THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS
UNDERSTAND WE ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS ALL OF THOSE ISSUES.
WITH THAT- THIS IS PART OF A
PACKAGE OF BILLS I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE GETTING READY TO HEAR
ANOTHER OF MY COLLEAGUES BILLS-
SB THIRTY EIGHTY FIVE. I WANT.
WE MAIN INTEREST IN WORKING
WITH YOU. I AND THIS ASSEMBLY
TO CONTINUE TO DO A PACKAGE OF
BILLS THAT TRIES TO ADDRESS THE
BROADEST DEGREE OF CONCERNS.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
INTENTION AND THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION AND A SECOND AND I SO
MUCH WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MUCH SEN ATKINS
AND I'M FOR SO I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING ON THE COMMITTEE ON THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. AS YOU KNOW WE WERE
TRYING TO SEEK A BALANCE
BETWEEN STREAMLINING
DEVELOPMENT ENSURING FOR THE IN.
PRESERVING SOME LOCAL CONTROL-
I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS THE ITS
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO
PASS OF AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I.
LACKEY ROUGHLY NO LACKING NO
BLOOM. BOERNER HORVATH RAMOS
RAMOS I THREE OF US THREE OF US
I ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
VOEPEL. K. IT'S FORTY WE NEED
SKEWS TO ONE WE ONE ADDITIONAL
VOTE AND WE WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN UNTIL OF THE WE GET ALL OF
OUR MEMBERS BACK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION DAY THANK YOU TO
ALL THOSE AROUND THE CALL OF WE
APPRECIATE YOUR- GUIDANCE AND
IDEAS AS WE MOVE FORWARD THANKS.
OKAY WE WILL NOW GO ON TO A
POINT TO GO TO ITEM NUMBER.
THREE AND WE'RE GOING TO
WELCOME UP. THIS IS S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE CENTER TO
COVER YOUR OWN AND SENATE-ROOM
YOUNG. AND WELCOME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY PERCENT SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE ON THE
NEIGHBORHOOD HOMES ACT- BEFORE
I GO I'D LIKE TO- OUT I BELIEVE
MADAM PRO TEM WANTED TO SAY A
FEW WORDS ON THIS BILL SO IF
YOU COULD TAKE A COUPLE MINUTES
OF MY TIME. THE READER HONORED.
SHARON THANK YOU AND US SENATOR
THANK YOU- YOU KNOW I AGAIN
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION TO THIS CONVERSATION.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE- IS A PART
OF A PACKAGE OF SENATE HOUSING
BILLS. AND I KNOW THAT- IN THE
PAST AND EVEN THIS YEAR THE
ASSEMBLY HAS PUT TOGETHER UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP OF YOUR HOUSING
CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO-
BILLS. THAT WE HOPE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND BE ABLE TO CONTINUE.
TO DISCUSS AND WORK TOGETHER.
HI THIRTY H. FIVE IS PART AND
PARCEL OF THAT PACKAGE AND- I
JUST WANT TO COMMIT TO YOU IN
ADDITION TO THE SENATOR WHO
WILL. CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
THAT WE WILL POT WORKING GOOD
FAITH EVERY STEP OF THE WAY TO
TRY TO DETERMINE HOW. BEST TO
TAKE INTO. THE ISSUE THAT YOU
IS MEMBER. OF OUR BY. BODY IN
THE ASSEMBLY BRING UP- WE TAKE
IT SERIOUSLY AND WE HAVE A VERY
SHORT TRUNCATED TIME TO DO THIS
CRITICAL WORK. AND I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT YOU IS MEMBERS
KNOW THAT AS THE LEADER OF THE
SENATE I AM COMMITTED TO
WORKING ON ALL OF THESE BILLS
RELATED TO HOUSING WHETHER IT'S
THE ASSEMBLY BILLS OR THE
SENATE BILLS TO SEE IF WE CAN
BE SUCCESSFUL. THAT IS TRUE ONE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE AS WELL
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR TOP
THANK YOU. K. WELCOMES CENTER
COVER GYRO THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET ME FIRST OFF BY SAYING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO YOU AND
THE STAFF FOR A THOROUGH
ANALYSIS AND ROBUST
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS BILL. I
APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT'S THAT'S GOT INTO IT UNDER
VERY DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES.
LET ME START OFF BY SAYING THE-
COMMITTEE RECOMMENDS SEVERAL
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL. AND
TODAY I WILL ACCEPT ALMOST ALL
OF THESE AMENDMENTS AND I'D
LIKE TO ARTICULATE WHICH ONES I
WILL AND IF YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT. THE ONE AND A HALF IT'S
LEFT I'M WILLING TO DO TAT AS
WELL. ONE IS TO REMOVE THE
PROVISIONS RELATING TO SB
THIRTY FIVE. TWO IS LIMITING
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL THE
PARCELS THAT ARE NOT ADJACENT
TO INDUSTRIAL USES THAT WAS
NEVER THE INTENTION. THREE
LIMITING THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
TO PARCELS LOCATED IN URBANIZED
AREA CLUSTERS FOR THE
REALLOCATION OF EXEMPTS SITES
ON PARCELS THATARE NOT
IDENTIFIED AS AREAS SUCH AS
PRIME FARMLAND COASTAL ZONES
WETLAND HIGH FIRE SEVERITY
ZONES THEY'RE IDENTIFIED BY
CODE SECTION SO I DIDN'T SAY
THE CODE SECTION BECAUSE NOBODY
WOULD KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
NEXT IS TO REQUIRED THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT HAVE AN
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS THE
NEXT IS ADDING A SUNSET TO THE
BILL THERE IS A DISPUTE ON WHAT
DATE WOULD INCLUDE. ALL OF THE-
INSURER ALL OF THE CLOCKS HAVE
COMPLETED THEIR SIXTH CYCLE THE
RENO CYCLE AND SO- WE BELIEVE
IT'S THIRTY TWO YOU BELIEVE
IT'S TWENTY SIX IF IT'S TWENTY
SIX I'M OKAY WITH THAT- AND
THEN STRIKING THAT CFD
PROVISIONS- THOSE ARE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDS THAT. THAT I AM
WILLING TO ACCEPT. SO AS AS
YOU'RE ALL AWARE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO FACE AN EXTREME.
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS IN
ORDER TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILY THE STATE
MUST INCREASE HOUSING
PRODUCTION TO TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND UNITS PER YEAR. YET
THE LACK OF AVAILABLE LAND FOR
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT
CONTINUES TO BE A CHALLENGE
MANY OF OUR CITIES ARE BUILT
OUT AND DON'T HAVE READILY
AVAILABLE VACANT LAND AND OTHER
CITIES. ARE RELUCTANT TO
DEVELOP HOUSING ON THE
OUTSKIRTS OF THEIR
JURISDICTIONS WHICH IS AS IT
SHOULD BE. SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE TAKES A COMP CONCEPT
ARTICULATED IN SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE. BY SENATOR STEINBERG TO
DEVELOP DEVELOP SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES AND TO REUSE AND
ADAPT UNDERPERFORMING
PROPERTIES TO CREATE WALKABLE
COMMUNITIES AND AVOID SPRAWL.
THIS ADAPTED REDUCE BILL WILL
SPUR OF BURKE HOUSING
PRODUCTION BY AUTHORIZING
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS. ON
EXISTING LOTS CURRENTLY ZONED
FOR COMMERCIAL OFFICE AND
RETAIL USE SUCH AS STRIP MALLS
ARE LARGE RETAIL SPACES. THE
BILL WILL ALSO SOLVE AND
EVOLVING CRISIS THAT HAS BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE SHELTER IN
PLACE ORDERS DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WHICH IS
SHIFTED BUSINESS TO ACCEPT NEW
WORK FROM HOME STRATEGIES AND
EXPANDED ONLINE TRANSACTIONS
FOR COMMERCIAL RETAIL. NUMEROUS
MAISCHAK MAJOR COMMERCIAL
TENANTS HAVE INDICATED THAT
THEY MAY BE FILING FOR
BANKRUPTCY OR CLOSING STORES
SUCH AS SEARS J. C. PENNEY'S
KMART TOYS R. US. ALL OF US
HAVE THESE COMMUNITIES IN OUR
DISTRICTS. AND THAT'S DUE TO
THE DECLINE. CONSUMER PRESS
OVER TIME WHICH IS LEFT MANY
COMMUNITIES WITH STRIP MALLS
AND MALLS WITH MAJOR TENANT
VACANCIES WHICH CONTRIBUTED TO
THE DECLINE OF THE RETAIL
CENTER INCREASING BLIGHT
VANDALISM DECLINING SALES TAX
REVENUE. IN MY DISTRICT THESE
RETAILERS ARE OUR MAJOR TENANTS
AND I EXPECT TO SEE MANY MORE.
OF THESE RETAILERS LEAVE AS THE
ECONOMY STRUGGLES IN ADDITION
MANY CORPORATE ENTERPRISES ARE
FOR GOING THEIR BRICK AND
MORTAR OPERATIONS IN FAVOR OF A
NEW WORK FROM HOME REALITY.
THESE UNDER UTILIZED OR VACANT
COMMERCIAL SPACES ARE ALONG
MAJOR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
ROUTES AND CONTAIN SIGNIFICANT
ACREAGE AVAILABLE TO BE
DEVELOPED FOR MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT TO CREATE A
WALKABLE LIVE WORK PLAY
VILLAGE. THE WALKABLE VILLAGE
CONSTABLE ALSO HELP TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY
CREATING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF VEHICLE
TRIPS BY ALLOCATING SERVICES
WITHIN WALKING DISTANCE OF
PEOPLE'S HEALTH. MOST SIMPLY SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WILL ALLOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO APPROVE
RESIDENTIAL OR MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT ON COMMERCIALLY
ZONED RETAIL R OFFICE SPACE
REQUIRE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
MEET OR EXCEED THE DENSITY
DEEMED APPROPRIATE TO
ACCOMMODATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SUCH AS APARTMENTS TOWNHOMES
AND CONDOMINIUMS AND PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL DECISION.
MAKING BY SUBJECTING TO DEVELOP
TO LOOK PLANNING PARKING AND
DESIGN OR- WITH NO COST TO THIS.
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WILL
INCENTIVIZE RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS WITHOUT IMPACTING
SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS BY
GIVING LAND OWNER AND
DEVELOPERS WAIT A WAY TO MEET
THE GROWING DEMAND FOR HOUSING.
THE BILL ALSO SPUR ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY A CRITICAL COMPONENT
TO ECONOMIC RECOVERY DURING A
RECESSION IN REGION'S MOST IN
NEED TO RE VIOLATE
REVITALIZATION AND AS A STEP
TOWARDS ECONOMIC TRANSFORMATION.
SB EIGHT THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
IS SUPPORTED BY A LARGE NUMBER
OF ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA FORWARD CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY THE
CALIFORNIA YIMBY HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY AND WESTFIELD. WITH ME
TODAY TO PROVIDE TSTIMONY IN
SUPPORT AND FACILITATE
DISCUSSION ARE THE CO SPONSORS.
ON MICHAEL WEINBERG OF TELL FOR
ENSURE MURATSUCHI FEAST POLICY
OF THE B. COME. MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE- LINES FOR
WITNESSES AND WITNESSES AGAIN
R. MICH WINE BURKE AND- MISS OF
CISNEROS. THE LINES ARE OPEN.
HI THANK YOU CHAIR AGUILAR
CURRY- YOUR LEADERSHIP OF THE
COMMITTEE AND- ON SO MANY OTHER
IMPORTANT ISSUES SUCH AS
BROADBAND FOR ALL I THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHAEL WEINBERG AT THE OF
CALIFORNIA BOARD IN WE ARE CO
SPONSOR OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
SENATOR CAFIERO AND HER STAFF
FOR ALL THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL
AND- WE UNDERSTAND TO GO SHE
ATION CONTINUE WITH VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS CALIFORNIA FOR
BEAT THE MOVEMENT TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND
GOVERNMENT WORK FOR EVERYONE
AND ALL THE STATE'S REGIONS ONE
PRIMARY WAY WE DO THIS IS
BRINGING PEOPLE TOGETHER FROM
ALL PARTIES IN REGIONS AND
INTERESTSACROSS THE STATE THAT
ARE CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC SUMMIT.
THE INTENDED FRAMEWORK ABOUT
THE THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE WITH
THE PRIORITY ACTIONS. STEMMING
FROM THE SUMMIT LAST YEAR. THE
BILL WILL HELP ME THE- ST NEW
TO PRODUCE A NOW. SUPPLY OF
HOUSE OF ALL. AS WELL IF YOU
WOULD. THE CLOSE TO BREAK
MORTAR. AS HIGHLIGHTED BY
CENTER. UNFORTUNATELY BOTH THE
CRISIS THE- AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AS WELL AS RETAIL BANKRUPTCIES
AND BUSINESS CLOSURES. ARE ONLY
GETTING WORSE DUE TO THE IMPACT
OF THE PANDEMIC. FIVE THOUSAND
HOUSING IS AN ALLOWABLE USE ON
PROPERTY. ZONED FOR COMMERCIAL
AND RETAIL THE BILL WILL
INCREASE XCELERATED NEW HOUSING
PRODUCTION. IN STRATEGIC SPACES
THAT ARE OFTEN PRIME LAND CLOSE
TO PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. SO
THIS. HI BOOKBUILD OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS AS WELL AS
OUR GOAL IS TO PRODUCING SOCIAL
EQUITY THREE PRODUCING HOUSING.
THE STATE THAT ARE ALREADY PART
OF OUR URBAN LANDSCAPE TO
CONTAIN SIGNIFICANT ACREAGE.
THE COULD BE DEVELOPED FOR
HOUSING OR MIXED USE. GEN I
JUST WANT TO THAT WAS EXTREMELY
BY THE COMMENT ABOUT YOUR
LACKEY. THAT. THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATORS YOU TO BE HONEST
ARE MADE TIME TO TRY TO DO ANY
RECENT ON HOW. DID A REASON OF.
BILL DEVELOPED BY A BROAD RANGE
OF STAKEHOLDERS THERE'S BEEN A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK
WITHIN ON THAT. TO INCORPORATE
ALL THE CONCERNS OF A BROAD
RANGE OF INTERESTS. HI I URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON THIS BILL
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WHERE I GOT HURRY AND ASKING
THAT THANK YOU SENATOR CAMBIADO
AND YOUR STAFF A HARD WORK ON
HIS MY NAME IF YOU IF YOU CAN'T
OF WITH THE CAL AN WE ARE A
PROUD PARTNER WITH CALIFORNIA
BOARD TEXAS CARE ACT THIRTEEN
FIVE OUR PUBLIC POLICY
ORGANIZATION WENT OVER BY OVER
HERE COULD BE THE LARGEST
EMPLOYERS ACROSS NINE COUNTY
BAY AREA. LIKE THE BAY AREA
ABOUT CALIFORNIA- P. THIRTY
OTHER WORKFORCE GRAPPLE WITH
ATHLETES HOUSING COSTS EVEN AS
MINES JONATHAN OR MARKET THEY
ARE COMING DOWNSTREAM. OUR
COMMUNITY. ESPECIALLY AMONG MY
ARE FOR HOUSING ONLY COME BY BE
NINETY. WE NOT BE PREPARED TO
BE OUR HOUSING BECAUSE AND
HAVING ARE. BY LEVERAGING THE
OPERA WILL BE AND THEN DURING
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO TRANSIT
INTEREST. WELL DOWNEY PARKING
DESIGN AND OTHER ARTISTS.
INCLUDING EQUITY AND OR AT
COUNTY LOCAL INCLUSIONARY
ZONING I UNDERSTAND WERE ACTUAL
EGO CHANGES IN THIS REGARD
THANK YOU BEGINNING COURAGE BUT
BILITY. OPT HER THAT YOU'RE
CENTER REPORT. QUOTE WELL
DEFINED COULD CARRY PROGRAMS
THAT REQUIREMENTS AT A LEVEL
THAT CAN BE ACCOMMODATED
COMFORTABLY GIVEN REVENUES.
COSTS AND INCENTIVES AVAILABLE
LOCALLY. BEYOND THE CURRENT
LEVEL THE RETIREMENT CAN BE A
BURDEN AND DEVELOPERS MAY
CHOOSE NOT TO DEL. DEL WE
RECOGNIZE THAT EACH COMMUNITY
IS DIFFERENT AND THEIR
APARTMENT THAT HADN'T BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED BY THAT. OF FOR
EXAMPLE. IN GOING TWENTY. THE
MOTHER MARKETING COUNTRY THE ON
SITE INCLUSIONARY REQUIREMENT
WITH THE SHRINK FROM TO TWENTY
FIVE. AND WITH MY OUTWARD
MICHAEL ALL THE INTERNET THAT
MUCH LOWER THAN IN PAST YEARS.
AND FORTY SIX SIX THOUSAND
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE PERMITS
WERE. LAST YEAR THAT NUMBER
DROPPED 230-009-0020 FOUR POINT.
42% DECREASE. THE BEAR COUNCIL.
COULD KNOWS ABOUT HEALTH
SOLUTION THAT BY. SOCIAL AND
IMMIGRATION. HOWEVER THAT THE
ATTENTIVE POLICY THROUGH LOCAL
CONDITION AND- WE LOOK FORWARD
YOU. ON THE CAMPAIGN DISCUSSION
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND VERY
COUNCIL STRONGLY OR DID YOUR
EYES OUT ON AT. THE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES I THINK WE HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME LEFT WITH.
WE CAN HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS.
THE TECHNICIAN WRITTEN.
MONUMENTUM CHURN MEMBERS RANDOM
ARE NOT BEHALF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION I DO WANT
TO ASK A QUESTION FOR
CLARIFYING PURPOSES I HEARD THE
AUTHOR EXCEPT THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROVISIONS THAT INCLUDE
THE 20% IS MENTIONED IN THE
ANALYSIS. NO NUMBER. OKAY SO WE
HAVE A SUPPORT OF AMENDED
POSITION- BECAUSE WE DO BELIEVE
THAT AT LEAST 20% BUT
DEFINITELY A HIGHER NUMBER
WOULD BE. MORE APPROPRIATE- WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT ENOUGH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS PUT INTO
THESE PROPERTIES. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT HF DOES WE DO
TAKE OVER COMMERCIALS OWNED
LAND AND PUT IN HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE LOW
INCOME. I THINK WE NEED TO MAKE
A MUCH BETTER. MUCH BETTER SHOW
THAT. I WOULD ALSO URGE THAT
IF- IF THIS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
LANGUAGE STAYS. THE AUDIBLE
LANGUAGE FOR ALL HOUSING
LANGUAGE FOCUSED ON EXTREMELY
LOW AND VERY LOW INCOME PEOPLE.
70% OF THE NEED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ACCORDING TO OUR
STATE DEPARTMENT HOUSING. IS
OUT THOSE TWO LEVELS THE LOWEST
LEVELS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE ADDRESSED FIRST
BEFORE ANYBODY ELSE WE CREATE
YOUR- YOUR- CONSIDERATION
THANK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IMPORTANT
FORTY TWO OH TWO THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE- OPERATOR MODERATOR
BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR THOSE THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT. I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND
EVERYBODY ONCE AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. ON
THE BILL. MODERATOR. JUST TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
ALTHOUGH I HAD NOT BEEN ALIGNED
WITH THE LINE FIFTY ONE FIRST
PLEASE GO AHEAD LIKE FIFTY ONE.
MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS OUT STORES
WITH STRATEGIES THREE SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF UP FOR GROWTH ACTION
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GIVE ME
FAN ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN. MY MONEY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. PLEASE TELL
ME YOUR PHONE. MOVING ALONG
WITH A LINE TO SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO SEVENTY
TWO IS YOUR PHONE YOU'RE A-
SORRY ABOUT THAT IS DIRECTLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE REGISTRY OUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
TO LINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM THIRTY EIGHT YOU
ARE OPEN. YEAH MY NAME IS JAKE
MULHOLLAND I LIVE IN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FORTY FIVE SENATE
DISTRICT TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY OF
WHEN I FOUND WHAT A FIFTY M. B.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT AND- THIRTEEN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MOVING ALONG TO
LINE TO TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FINE ART TWO FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD MY TWO FOUR
FOUR SORRY SORRY ABOUT THAT
GOOD MORNING- THIS IS JORDAN
GRIMES I'M CALLING FROM SAN
MATEO CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF
PENINSULA FOR EVERYONE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AT WORK
ORDER TO TWENTY TWO BY TWO TWO
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI DAVID
WALTON NINE GMT STRONG SUPPORT
S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE. ONE
TWO SEVENTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN TO
SOMEONE. I TO BE MORE SHAUNA
CALLING FROM LA ON BEHALF OF
SANTA MONICA EMB URGES FROM
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT IS GOING TO SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DENNIS PLACE
ON I AM CALLING FROM VAN NUYS
ON BEHALF OF SB AMBIEN WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. WHY TOOL FOR YOU ARE
OPEN. HELLO HELLO. I AM
FREAKING OPPOSITION I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU FEW COULD WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE OPPOSITION. DO I
NEED TO RE QUEUE MA'AM AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
TWENTY THREE. ONE ONE EIGHT.
HELLO THIS IS BOB NAYLOR CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN. OKAY I
REPRESENT THE OLD SEVEN COMPANY
IN ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS
STRONGLY SUPPORT OF AND
CALIFORNIA B. AND THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS LUIS MORA
DATE WITH CALIFORNIAN BE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. I THINK YOU.
ALKALINE TWO SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND OKAY WELL THE
GENTLEMAN BURKE AND I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF- THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE SACRAMENTO IN SACRAMENTO.
NEXT IN LINE. TO EIGHTY TWO
EIGHT ZERO. I TWO EIGHTY RURAL
I HI THIS IS ALEXANDRIA CALLING
FOR EACH L. A. M. B. CHAPTER
WE'RE CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE
TO SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HOW MANY THEY HAVE BEEN
SUPPLIED HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF THAT
THE REPEAT COALITION WHICH
INCLUDES THE SAN FRANCISCO
FOUNDATION SB AT HOME AND TMG
PARTNERS AS WELL CALLING AT THE
PORT ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANNING AND
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION AND
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
ALL URGING RIGHT OUT. THANK YOU.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS HENRY
HOOKER I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SANTA CRUZ YOU MAKE. IN STRONG
SUPPORT INVESTING. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I LIKE TO NINETY ONE YOU
ARE OPEN. FIND TO NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI HIS IS
DONNA CARTER CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. OKAY YES THIS IS
PAM A PROTOCOL AND FROM
CALIFORNIA YOU'LL BE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CARE ROCK ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF GLENDALE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND THAT'S REALLY ONE OF
THE ONE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ALFRED CHIU
FROM EACH DAY FOR EVERYONE
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE TWO
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS SAID ARIELLE FROM
OAKLAND I'M CALLING WITH EAST
BAY FOR EVERYONE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR GOING TO LINE AT
ONE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
ONE NINETY FIVE. DOMINANT
GOTTEN ROBINSON REPRESENTING
OUR AND I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE TO NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO NINE TWO.
GOOD MORNING KILL BILL FERRARI
ON BEHALF OF FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
GOING THE LINE TO EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS DAVID KING
I AM IN UNION CITY CALIFORNIA
CALLING WITH EAST BAY FOR
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT IS LINE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HEY THIS CAL POLY WITH
NEIGHBOR WE CAN OCCUR AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT IN LINE TO SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. DANTE GEORGIA HERE
COMPLAINING OF SENSATION WE
HAVE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
PETITION BUT WE WILL BE
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENT TO AND
THAT WILL BE AFFECTED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT IS LYING
TO FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATOR COUPLE
GYRO MY NAME IS THAT'S TAYLOR
I'M THE PRESIDENT PRO TEM OF
THE WEST TO BE COLLECTED
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION IN LOS
ANGELES AND THE PUBLISHER OF A
NEWSLETTER THIS IS CREATIVE AND
EXCELLENT USE OF RESOURCES IN
THIS LEGISLATION. I PLEASE ASK
THAT YOU ENSURE A STRONG
AFFORDING HEALTH WILL HOUSING
ELEMENT- THAT THAT REMAINS
PRESENT WITHOUT GET OUT. THANK
YOU. NEXT IS IN LINE TO SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS KATHY BEANS
AND PALO ALTO WITH AN INFLUX
FOR EVERYONE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE ONE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS DONALD EIGHT CROW
WITH ABUNDANT HELPING LOS
ANGELES CALLING TO DEPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT IS GOING
TO FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
MORNING BOB HERTZBERG PAN FROM
SAN FRANCISCO I THOUGHT IT
WOULD BE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT IS
LYING TO SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE GROUP WITH CREEK TRAGIC
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND WEST DR COURT. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO LINE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THAT THIS EVENING
STROLL WITH THE BAY AREA
HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE THANKS THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. WELL
HI BECAUSE THEY ARE MAD AT THEM
WITH EMPOWERMENT CONGRESS LEFT
AREA AND THOUGHT THE LATE
REPORT THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
GOING ONLINE TO NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
OFF THEIR- WILL BE I LIVE IN
SAN FRANCISCO I AM A MEMBER OF.
THE MD HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE THREE
OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THREE HUNDRED
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
SORRY ALLOW ME WHAT ARE HELLO
MY NAME IS KHAN ACADEMY AND-
HOW MANY YOUNG BE AND I PHAM
WORK. THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE
TO NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MARLON ACT
BURKE ON BEHALF OF SCHNEIDER
ELECTRIC NORTH AMERICA IN
SUPPORT. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DOWNTOWN ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE THREE OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS A PROBLEM
SOMEONE CALLED ON BEHALF OF
SANTA CRUZ EMB AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND OUR FINAL- IF
FOR SUPPORT IN Q. IS LINE ONE
OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE- SIXTY
ONE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS RECALL WITH THE MOBILE
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR
WE WILL NOW GO TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- WE HAVE A SPEAKER
MISTER LUCAS VIA LOBOS FROM
HOUSING CALIFORNIA I BELIEVE ON
THE TELEPHONE CAN YOU PLEASE Q.
HIM UP. GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS HI
MY NAME IS LOOK AT A LOOK FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE A LINE
YOU CAN FIND OF. CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA IS COMMITTED TO
CREATING A CALIFORNIA WHERE.
EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF INCOME
HAD TO FACE BASEBALL AFFORDABLE
PLACE TO LIVE. A TIME WHEN
CALIFORNIA'S SHORTFALL OF ONE
POINT THREE MILLION HOMES
AFFORDABLE TO LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. VERY REAL PROSPECT
ATTENDED BOTHER THE PEOPLE
BEING ADDED TO THE STATE
FIFTEEN I'M A POPULATION OF A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND. IT
SHOULD B DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO SUPPORT INCREASED
PRODUCTION OF SUCH AFFORDABLE
HOMES. SB THIRTY FIVE PROPOSED
TO OPEN UP SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF LAND TO RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION WITHOUT GOING TO
CHANGE THE CONDITIONAL USE
PERMIT. IT DOES NOT ENSURE THAT
LOCAL THAT LOW INCOME FAMILIES
MOST IN NEED WILL BENEFIT. HOW
THE CALIFORNIA GENERALLY
SUPPORT THE POLICY OF ALLOWING
A NEW HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
MARSHALLESE OWN LAND HOWEVER.
EXPECTED LEAVE REZONING
COMMERCIAL PARCELS TO
RESIDENTIAL USE WILL INCREASE
THE LINE VALUE SUBSTANTIALLY.
PROVIDE A WINDFALL TO CURRENT
PROPERTY OWNERS. GOOD
GOVERNMENT TREAT VALUE SHOULD
BE CAPTURED FOR PUBLIC BENEFIT
IN THE FORM OF A MINIMUM 20%
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
LOW INCOME FAMILIES. FAILING TO
ACQUIRE THE INCLUSION OF
AFFORDABLE HOMES. THANK YOU TO
OPPORTUNITY TO CALIFORNIA THE
METS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CHALLENGE. WE THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO AT THE
MOMENT I WANT TO REVIEW WHAT
THE OPPOSITE TO AND A QUARTER
OF UP TO RE EVALUATE THE-
WHETHER OR NOT THIS FUTURE
MINUTES BEFORE WE CAN LOOK FOR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES HERE FORTY TWO
OH TO THE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL SEEING
NONE MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND ONCE AGAIN I
WILL REMIND EVERYBODY NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. AND
AS A REMINDER TO QUEUE UP YOU
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. OUR FIRST
IN Q. IS LINE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS MARK STUDIES
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP AND WE STAND WITH-
HOUSING CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE THREE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS HERSH CHAIR OF THE NEXT
THE NINE CAMPAIGN REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT
TRULY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SPEAKING OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE ONE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHAT NUMBER
OF MOLECULAR NOW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
OPPOSITION- AND WHAT CAN I GET
THE BILL AND CRANK THAT
RECOGNIZE THAT THE AUTHOR- WILL
BE ACCEPTING MANY OF THE
COMMANDMENTS AND WE'LL REVIEW
WHAT'S GOING BUT YOU CAN PRINT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT NEXT
TO NEXTBOOK THE LINE TO SIXTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU AMERICAN
ALLIANCE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NEXT OUR
NEXT IS LINE TO SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PROPERTY THIS ARTICLE
CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ELEVEN TWENTY AND ALLOWED RURAL
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING ON OUR
COMMERCIAL CORRIDOR IN SOUTH LA
WHICH IS KIND SHOPPERS. NEXT WE
NEXT. ARE NOT TO COME FROM THE
LINE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CRITICALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATED
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE COUNTY AS
WELL AS THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE URBAN COUNTY THE
CALIFORNIA. WE HAD A CONCERNS
POSITION BUT THE CONCERNS WE'VE
LISTED WOULD BE ADDRESSED BY
THE CANADIAN AND THAT I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR. FOR WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU.
NEXT NEXT NEXT OVER THE LINE
THREE OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
HUNDRED NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BOB. WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT
HEADLINE ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HERE YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. GOOD
MORNING AKER THE PLAN
CONTRIBUTION THE WE CURRENTLY
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION BUT WE ARE VERY EAGER
TO REVIEW INEVITABLE YOU AGREED
TO AND THANK THE KENYAN DR-
CONSIDERING. AND NEXT OVER THE
LINE THREE ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
DISTRICT WITH LUGGAGE UNIT IN
SUPPORT. ONCE AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. YOU HAVE ONE PERSON
THAT IS GIVING THERE WE DO HAVE
ONE PERSON JUST BE A MOMENT
THEY'RE GETTING THEIR LINE
NUMBER GREAT THANK YOU. WE DID
HAVE ANOTHER PERSON QUEUE UP
WHILE WE'RE WAITING MOST GO TO
THE ONE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN. HI THIS IS SHAWN FROM
TAMMY TO CALCULATE THE HEIGHT
WE OPPOSE. AND NEXT OVER THE
LINE OF THREE THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY HELLO ARE AT THE HEART OF
THE WETERN CAROLINA POVERTY IN
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION I'M
JOINING OUR COLLEAGUE HEALTH IN
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR WILL MOVE
ON TO. A QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR SENATOR CABALLERO.
OKAY SEEING NONE. THIS IS THE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. LOOK AT THE
MOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LUCKY.
THE SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS. THANK YOU GENTLEMEN-
WE'D LIKE TO ADD THAT THE-
CENTER COVER YOUR- WHO CLOSING
STATEMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY WHO PARTICIPATED-
REMOTELY IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO HEAR WHAT PEOPLE HAVE TO SAY
AND I AND I APPRECIATE IT LET
ME JUST SAY THAT. I'M A SERVICE
POLICY. I GOT ELECTED TO BE
ABLE TO DO THINGS THAT REALLY
ARE IMPORTANT IN MY DISTRICT
AND MY DISTRICT IS A RURAL
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT THAT'S
VERY DIFFERENT FROM THE CITIES
AND FRANKLY TO BE ABLE TO DO
SOMETHING THAT WORKS IN REAL
CALIFORNIAN WORKS IN THE CITIES
AND THE SUBURBS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME BECAUSE IF
WE'RE GOING TO PASS LEGISLATION
TO WORK EVERY. AND WE HAVE
SPENT. THAT THIS THIS WORK WAS
DONE. WITH THAT- BENEFIT OF A
OF A GROUP OF US AND- I WOULD
VENTURE TO BE REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES ALL OVER THE STATE
THAT HAVE REALLY DIFFERENT
HOUSING SITUATIONS AND IT'S A
COMPROMISE OF ALL OF THE
CONCERNS THAT PEOPLE BROUGHT
FROM THEIR DIFFERENT DISTRICTS
AND YOU SEE WHO THEY ARE
BECAUSE THEY ARE LISTED AS- CO
AUTHORS ON THE BILL- THOSE ARE
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE PART
OF OUR OF OUR WORKING GROUP AND
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE IN MY
DISTRICT THAT I'VE BEEN
HEARING. ONCE PASSED THE COVERT
NIGHT. IS HOUSING THE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR ANY
HOUSING AT ALL HAS REALLY
CREATED THE SITUATION WHERE YOU
SEE COBIT IS RAGING. IN THE
FARMWORKERS COMMUNITY BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE LIVING IN REALLY
SERIOUSLY OVERCROWDED
SITUATIONS SO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS REAL IMPORTANT TO ME
AND ONE OF THE ISSUES. IT WILL
AND WHY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE
ARE WHAT'S THE EXACT NUMBER IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE A NEW DENSITY
BONUS. LAW THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GO INTO EFFECT- TO. YOU SAY
THAT ARE WORKING AND CITY BONUS
LEGISLATION THAT DE BONE. GOING
SET SOME AFFORDABLE CRITERIA
THAT ALL COMMUNITIES HAVE TO
FOLLOW AND SO THAT'S THE REASON
THAT I THINK WE HAVE TO HAVE A-
MORE ROBUST DISCUSSION ABOUT-
DENSITY BONUS AND I. ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT- AFFORDABLE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT THE NUMBER TWO
ISSUE OUT BEYOND THAT. IS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THERE'S A
DESPERATE NEED IN MY
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE DOUBLE
DIGIT UNEMPLOYMENT DURING THE
GOOD TIMES OF THE YEAR. TO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO CALL EIGHT. ON
UP. A JOB GOOD PAYING. AND
THAT'S THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS
IS ALL ABOUT IS TRYING TO MEET
OUR OF OUR HOUSING. ISSUEAT
AND OUR JOBS JOBS ISSUE AND DO
IT IN A WAY. THAT DOESN'T
CREATE VACANCIES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE TO BE
BOARDED UP. THAT ATTRACT
BLIGHT. AND THE KIND OF
VANDALISM THAT HAS FIVE
FIREFIGHTERS WORRIED BECAUSE
THEN YOU END UP WITH THE FIRE
SO MY POINT ABOUT ALL OF THAT.
THAT IS THAT. WE'VE FULLY
BOOKED AT. MOMENT TENSING. BY
THE WE'VE WE'VE- A- 95% FROM
AND- AND- YEAH EUROPE TODAY
CONTAIN HIS THIS SENSE TO MAKE
THAT WE GET THE BILL THAT
PEOPLE ARE REALLY. I'M SORRY
WITH AND ANY CLOSER WOULD SAY
THAT I WAS VERY HONORED TO HAVE
BIPARTISAN- COOPERATION ON THIS
BILL AND- AND THE FACT THAT IT
WORKS AND SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES IS TESTAMENT. TO
THE HARD WORK- OF THE OF THE
GROUP THAT'S ON IT. IT'S OVER
SHELTER PLACE COULDN'T SEE EACH
OTHER BUT WE MET ON THE PHONE
EVERY WEEK FOR A SERIES OF
HOURS SO I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FOR YOU- YOUR VOTE OF
CONFIDENCE TODAY TODAY TO
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS CASE AND TO KEEP
IT MOVING I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR- VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR. YOU KNOW THIS IS
TOUGH ON ME AND I TOLD YOU THAT
BEFORE I APPRECIATE THE INTENT
OF THIS BILL AND I THINK YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED A REAL OPPORTUNITY
TO USE VACANT COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS TO HELP US SOLVE OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. CRISIS IF
THE ENTIRETY OF WHAT WOULD THE
BILL DID I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. UNFORTUNATELY
THE BILL BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
IS MUCH BROADER IN SCOPE. WE
HAVE WORKED HARD OVER SEVERAL
YEARS TO ENSURE THAT THROUGH
THE RENEWAL PROCESS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS JUST LARA LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ZONE FOR
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE HOUSING. AND
THEY DO SO IN A WAY THAT IS
ALIGNED WITH THE STATE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL PROP PRINCIPLES.
LOCALS ARE CURRENTLY
IMPLEMENTING THE REVISED ARENA
NUMBERS AND REZONING FOR MORE
PARCELS FOR HOUSING. I'M
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL SHIFTS
THE GOALPOSTS ON THEM AND
ENCOURAGES SPRAWL BY ALLOWING
HOUSING ON UNDEVELOPED
COMMERCIALLY ZONED LAND WITH NO
INFILL CONTROLS. I SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF. THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ADVOCATES WE HEARD TODAY. THE
NEED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SIGNIFICANTLY OUTPACES THE NEED
FOR MARKET RATE HOUSING. AND
THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROVISION IN THIS BILL WAS
CONCERNING. FINALLY AS WE HAVE
DISCUSSED I AM ALSO DEEPLY
CONCERNED BY THE PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL THAT EXPANDS THE SCOPE
OF SB THIRTY FIVE STREAMLINING
BEYOND RESIDENTIAL ZONES. I
CAN'T SUPPORT AN ENORMOUS
EXPANSION OF THE STREAMLINING
PROCESS THAT FAILS TO RESTORE
THE RIGHT OF CALIFORNIA TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PROTECT TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES FROM DAMAGE
OR DESTRUCTION. I WILL DO
EVERYTHING IN MY POWER TO KEEP
SB THIRTY FIVE FROM BEING
EXTENDED OR EXPANDED UNTIL THIS
INJUSTICE IS REVERSED AND
FRANKLY. IF I COULD I'D REPEAL
IT IT UNTIL THAT TIME. THIS IS
NOT ABOUT YOUR BILL OR MINE YOU
ARE A DEAR FRIEND OF MINE IN AN
HONORABLE PERSON BUT THIS IS A
MORAL ISSUE TO ME. WE HAVE. OUR
RECEIVED A COUNTER PROPOSAL TO
THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDED IN THE ANALYSIS.
WELL WE ARE OPEN TO CONTINUE
NEGOTIATIONS I WANT TO MOVE
YOUR BILL FORD. WE CANNOT BET
THIS COUNTER OFFER ON SUCH
SHORT NOTICE. THIS LEAVES US NO
ABILITY TO CONSULT WITH THE
OTHER PARTIES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
THAT HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THESE NEGOTIATIONS FOR THE PAST
SIX WEEKS. I WILL MAKE A
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH YOU AFTER THE BUILDINGS
THIS COMMITTEE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WE HAVE REQUESTED.
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
WILL WORK. TOWARDS A COMPROMISE
BEFORE THE BILL IS VOTED ON
THIS FINAL FORM. YOU JUST
STATED THAT YOU WERE NOT GOING
TO TAKE ALL THE AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE HAS OFFERED A MINUTE
THAT I BELIEVE ADDRESSED ALL OF
THEIR ISSUES AND I'D BE HAPPY
TO SUPPLY THE BILL WITH ALL OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS UNFORTUNATELY
WITHOUT ALL THE AMENDMENTS I
HAVE TO STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT
THE COMMITTEE NOT SUPPORT THE
BILL AND I WILL BE VOTING NO.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. OUR MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
NO AGUIAR-CURRY NO LACKEY.
LACKEY III BLOOM.
BOERNER HORVATH RAMOS ALMOST NO
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL VOEPEL I.
PHOTOS THREE TWO AND WE RULE
YES IT DOES GIVE THEM. THANK
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE BUT- OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR.
OKAY WE ARE MOVING ON TO OUR
NEXT ITEM. FOR ITEM NUMBER FOUR
S. B. TEN FORTY NINE SENATOR
GLAZIER WELCOME. THANK YOU A
ADAM SHARON MEMBERS. ON OCTOBER
THIRTY FIRST IN MY HOMETOWN OF
ORINDA. A TRAGEDY STRUCK. A. I.
INDIVIDUAL HAD RENTED A SHORT
TERM RENTAL THIS IS A HOUSE
OBSESSIVELY TO HAVE A FAMILY
REUNION. INSTEAD IT WAS TURNED
INTO A- PARTY. AND THAT NIGHT
FIVE INDIVIDUALS WERE SHOT AND
KILLED. IT WASN'T THE FIRST
TIME THIS IT HAPPENED AT A
SHORT TERM RENTAL. IN THE LAST
HALF OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
FORTY TWO PEOPLE. HAVE BEEN
SHOT. ENTER OUTSIDE OF RENTAL
PROPERTY THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTRY
AND SEVENTEEN HAVE DIED. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. ARE UNDER VERY
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES TO DEAL
WITH THESE RARE ABUSES OF SHORT
TERM RENTAL PROPERTIES. THE
LEGISLATION THAT YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU IS INTENDED TO GIVE
A TOOL TO THEM. NOT A
REQUIREMENT BUT A TOOL THEY CAN
USE WHEN THEY HAVE SHORT TERM
RENTAL PROPERTIES THAT HAVE
ABUSED THE LAW TIME AND TIME
AGAIN. AND WHAT YOU FIND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE LAW TODAY IS
THAT. A VIOLATION BECOMES JUST
SIMPLY THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS A COUPLE HUNDRED
DOLLAR FINE. THAT'S IT. SO THE
LEGISLATION TAKES THE EXISTING
FINE LEVELS THAT ARE IN PLACE
RAISES THEM UP. TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS NOT THE FIRST
VIOLATION NOT THE SECOND BUT ON
RIVER IT OFFENDERS GIVING THAT
TOOL THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
TRY TO DEAL WITH THIS PROBLEM.
THE LOOK I UNDERSTAND THAT
SHORT TERM RENTALS. ARE ARE A
WAY TO IMPROVE TOURISM TO HELP.
PROPERTY OWNERS EARN SOME EXTRA
MONEY. BUT THERE ARE SOME BAD
ACTORS IT'S NOT THE- USUAL
OCCUR THE RARE OCCURRENCE. AND
SO MY WORK WITH MY LOCAL
OFFICIALS IN MY LOCAL CITIES
WE'RE TRYING TO GIVE THEM JUST
AN ADDITIONAL TOOL THAT'S THE
BILL THAT'S BEFORE YOU TODAY I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL IF. THE GUIDANCE
IN MAKING THIS BILL STRONGER
AND BETTER. I HAVE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY THE VICE MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF ORINDA AB WORTH. AND
RICHARD LAZARO REPRESENTING THE
EXPEDIA GROUP. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THE
BILL TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR-
WE WILL- NOW PUT IN THE QUEUE
THE VICE MAYOR JAMIE WORTH OF
CITY OF ORINDA. AHEAD UP. GOOD
MORNING MATTER MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS AMY WIRTZ VICE MAYOR
VERANDA AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY. THE COURT OF
SENATE BILL TEN FORTY NINE.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE RELIEF
WITH AN IMPORTANT TOOL IN
MANAGING SHORT TERM RENTALS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY WE ARE GRATEFUL
TO SENATOR GLAZERS FOR
SPONSORING THIS LEGISLATION.
WHEN SHORT TERM RENTAL HELPING
PLATFORMS CAME INTO EXISTENCE
MANY CITIES IN CALIFORNIA CHOSE
TO BAN THEM COMPLETELY. IN A
WINDOW WE CHOSE A MORE MODERATE
APPROACH TO PERMIT THEM. AND
ADOPTED AN ORDINANCE THAT
CLEARLY OUTLINES THE RULES.
THAT INCLUDED NO RENTALS FOR
LARGE PARTIES. AND THE
REQUIREMENT THAT SHORT TERM
RENTAL OWNERS REGISTER THEIR
PROPERTY. SINCE THE ADOPTION OF
OUR ORDINANCE. AFTER IT'S
WORKED WITH PROPERTY OWNERS AND
NEIGHBORS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
AND COMPLAINTS. THIS REQUIRES
EXTENSIVE STAFF RESOURCES BUT
IT ALSO REQUIRES THE
ADMINISTRATIVE TOO OLD TO DO
EFFECTIVE ENFORCEMENT. LAST
YEAR WE FOR STRENGTH IN OUR
ORDINANCE TO RESTRICT RENTALS
TO HOSTED RENTAL. WITH TWO
NIGHT MINIMUM HOWEVER THE
GREATEST CHALLENGE WE FACE IS
THE ABILITY TO ENFORCE THE
RULES IN THE FACE OF SERIOUS.
COMPLIANCE OF SHORT TERM RENTAL
PROPERTIES WITH LOCAL ZONING
ORDINANCES IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF BOTH. THE
PROPERTY OWNER AND THE SHORT
TERM RENTAL PLATFORM. HAVING
ADEQUATE ENFORCEMENT TOOLS IT
IS THE ONLY WAY WE WILL BE ABLE
TO EFFECTIVELY MANAGE AND
ENFORCE THESE REASONABLE
ORDINANCES. ARENDAL LIKE MANY
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA IS A
GENERAL LAW CITY AND THE STATE
LEGISLATURE SEPT THE STATUTORY
LIMITS FOR FINE. THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE A MUCH NEEDED TO
OFFER CITY THINK FOURNETTE TWO
ONE FOURTH. THEIR SHORT TERM
RENTAL ORDINANCES. IN A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WE APPRECIATE THIS
OF THE LOWER GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE CAN PROVIDE US WITH
THE TOOLS TO MANAGE EFFECTIVELY
OUR CITIES AND COUNTIES AND IT
HAS BEEN AN HONOR TO WORK WITH
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
OVER THE YEARS. WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK THREE. SENATE BILL TEN
FORTY NINE AND I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE
YOU TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE NEXT
IS RICHARD LAZARO. FROM EXPEDIA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND GOOD
MORNING- ON BEHALF OF EXPEDIA
GROUP OF FAMILY TRAVEL BRANDS
INCLUDING VACATION ONE TO GIVE
ME VACATION RENTAL LEADER VERBO
AND CALLING TODAY TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL TEN
FORTY NINE. EXPEDIA IS PROUD TO
WORK WITH LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA COURT
BALANCED RESPONSIBLE SHORT TERM
RENTAL REGULATIONS THAT MEET
MEET EACH COMMUNITY'S NEEDS.
THIS BILL GIVE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IMPORTANT TOOLS TO
ENFORCE THOSE REGULATIONS.
WE'RE DEEPLY GRATEFUL TO
SENATOR GLAZERS THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO THIS WORK AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE COMMITTEE
TO ADVANCE TEN FORTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
TWO I SEE NONE. I WILL GO TO-
WITNESSES ON LINE MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE UP IN THE PHONE FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY
THANK YOU. OKAY THERE IS A
GERMAN FOR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN PRESS ONE ZERO OUR
FIRST WILL COME FROM WIND THREE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS FILL THE ANTILLES SHOT
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND FROM WORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR GOING TO
LINE THREE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AGERS YOU
DON'T GOT THE CALIFORNIA-
SOMEBODY DISPOSITION STRONG
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND OUR LASTING
QUEUE AT THIS TIME IS LINE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ALFRED
CUTE I LIVE IN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES AND-
I SEE NO WITNESSES HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH TWO ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
TELEPHONE MODERATOR. AND AS A
REMINDER PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
LIKE TO OUR QUEUE UP FOR A
OPPOSITION ONCE AGAIN IT'S ONE
ZERO. NO JUST BE ONE MOMENT WE
DOHAVE ONE IN Q. AND WILL OPEN
THE WINE THREE TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE I OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME VALERIE
HOOD. THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER IN OPPOSITION. HEARING
NONE OR MOVE ON TO- QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE MISTER GLAZIER
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER MORE
PROGRESS SO NOT SO MUCH A
QUESTION BUT I WANT TO THANK
THE SENATOR FOR BRING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL FORD. WE HAVE A
LOT OF SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS AND I THINK YOU
ACCURATELY SAID SO MANY OF THE
POSTS ARE VERY GOOD HOSTS. AND
THEN YOU HAVE SOME VERY BAD
ACTORS IN THOSE BAD ACTORS JUST
WRAPPED NEIGHBORHOODS THEY
ENDANGER LIVES AND SO THANK YOU
FOR BRING THIS FOUR AND I'D
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FORGET HIS. IT'S BEEN SO LONG
SINCE YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THAT'S EASY TO REMEMBER.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR TO
FOR HER- BRINGING THIS BILL AND
THAT- NOTING THAT MY HOME TOWN
IS- LISTED AS IN SUPPORT- I
THINK- LIKE MS BOERNER HORVATH
THE- A LOT OF MY CITIES
ACTUALLY- I HAVE A OF A FAIRLY
LARGE SUPPLY OF A- SHOULDN'T
RENTAL AND WE BELIEVE STOURTON
SAYS TO DEAL I JUST WANTED TO.
KIND. RIGHT NOW MY NOTES TO THE
CURRENT VIOLATION AND CAN BE AN
STARTS AT A HUNDRED DOLLARS AND
GOES UP TO THIRTEEN HUNDRED AND
UNDER THE BILL THAT WOULD GO A
START AT FIFTEEN HUNDRED AND GO
UP TO FIVE THOUSAND AND- PER
VIOLATION. THAT'S CORRECT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED FOR THE FIRST
VIOLATION THREE THOUSAND FOR
THE SECOND FIVE THOUSAND FOR
THE- THIRD. AND IT ALSO US
ALLOWS FOR A HARDSHIP WAIVER
PROCESS CASE- THERE'S BEEN
MISUNDERSTANDINGS OR SOME OTHER
ISSUES TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT.
DOES IT TOM ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- BUT TYPICALLY WHEN
CODE ENFORCED AS AN ISSUE UC OR
FREQUENTLY- IF IT'S NOT A CITY
VIOLATE AND- WARNINGS ARE
ISSUED AND THEN IT'S AFTER THE
WARNING THAT- OF FINES KICK AND
IS THAT A POP. BILITY UNDER
UNDER THIS BILL I'M SURE THAT.
I WONDER. SO YOUR QUESTION IS
THERE A WARNING PROCESS FIRST.
RIGHT GOOD ENFORCEMENT OFFICER-
GIVE A WRITTEN WARNING OR A
SOME FORM OF WARNING WARNING
AND NOT- COULD FIND- SO THIS
BILL ONLY APPLIES TO-
VIOLATIONS THAT AFFECT HEALTH
AND SAFETY SO IT'S NOT A CROSS
THE BORDER TO OTHER. VIOLATIONS
IN A COMMUNITY THIS IS FOCUSED
ON A NARROWER SPACE I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S A COMPLETE
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION IS NO BUT
IT'S A GOOD DISTINCTION I THINK
IT'S A- DISTINCTION. THANK YOU
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TO THE. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM A CELL PHONE
IN HER MOUTH. THE SECOND FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOW. THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZERS- FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORD BUT TO ADDRESS
THE TRAGEDIES THAT HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING IN SHORT TERM RENTAL
PROPERTIES IN YOUR DISTRICT AND
ELSEWHERE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SHOULD BE ABLE TO PENALIZE BAD
OPERATORS ARE RENTERS
ESPECIALLY REPEAT OFFENDERS
WITH THE FACT OF ENFORCEMENT
TOOLS. I ALSO WANT TO THINK TO
YOURSELF- TO YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THE INCREASE FINES FOR
VIOLATIONS OF SHORT TERM RENTAL
ORDINANCES ARE TARGETED TO
SERIOUS VIOLATIONS AND THE
VIOLATORS HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO APPLY FOR A WAIVER IS A FINE
POSES A FINANCIAL HARD. PLEASE
SUPPORT BILL. MOTIONS TO PASS A
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS WE ARE HI HI.
ISLA LACKEY I BLOOM HI LUME
BURNER BOERNER HORVATH I.
LOOSE THREE OF US ROBERT READ
US ROBERT RIVAS I'D VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING. THE BILLS
OUT SIX ZERO I BELIEVE HERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR GLACIER
FOR THE PRESENTATION OR MOVE
ONTO YOUR NEXT BILL S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. THANK YOU
MADAM HERE I'D LIKE TO INVITE
UP MY PARTNER AND- FROM MY
DISTRICT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON WHO'S PARTNERED WITH ME
ON THIS BILL THIS. THIS IS A
LOCAL BILL FOR CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY- IT'S SIMILAR TO A BILL
THAT THAT HAS BEEN APPROVED BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR THAT IS AFFECTED
OTHER. COUNTIES BUT THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW THE COUNTY. TO PUT
BEFORE THEIR VOTERS. I TAX
MEASURE THAT WOULD GO ABOVE THE
CURRENT CEILING THAT EXISTS IN
THE COUNTY. AS YOU KNOW WE'RE
IN AT PANDEMIC WITH ENORMOUS
IMPACT- IN OUR COMMUNITIES THE
SOCIAL. SAFETYNET OUR FIRE
PROTECTION ACTIVITIES
EVERYTHING IS AT RISK BECAUSE
OF THE REVENUE SHORTFALLS THAT
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE ARE FACING
AND YET IT COMES AT A TIME WHEN
THE DEMAND ON PUBLIC SERVICES
HAVE NEVER BEEN. GREATER THERE
ARE LIMITATIONS TO AS TO WHAT I
JURISDICTION CAN DO. AND
CERTAINLY THE CAP ON TAXES HAS
CREATED A LIMITATION NOT. THAT
THAT SIMPLY DOESN'T ALLOW THE
VOTERS TO WEIGH IN ON THE ISSUE
ITSELF AND SO THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW FOR CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
THE ABILITY TO- PLACE MEASURES
ON THE BALLOT ABOVE THE
EXISTING CAP. AND GIVE THEIR
VOTERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH
IN ON THIS LOCAL CHOICE WHETHER
THEY CAN BRING YOU REVENUES TO
HELP THE MOST VULNERABLE AT A
TIME AS CRITICAL AS THIS ONE.
WITH THAT. WE HAVE OUR CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY SUPERVISOR JOHN
GIOIA AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY AS
WELL AS CHRISTY BALMA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION AND I
ONCE AGAIN THANK MY PARTNER- IN
THE ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON FOR HIS HELP ON THIS
BILL AS WELL THANK YOU SIR
GLAZER AND I WELCOME WITH
WITNESSES. MODERATE IS OPEN THE
PHONE. WE SHOULD SUPPORT. IT
LIKE. LOOK. HELLO MADAM CHAIR.
YES THIS IS CHRISTINA- I GUESS
I'LL JUMP AHEAD CENTER SILENCE
ON THE LINE. YOU KNOW THAT. I'M
SORRY I WOULD IT DID YOU CALL
ON JOHN GIOIA YES AND I'M GONNA
GO AHEAD LIKE PROCEED SHE WAS A
KIND OF. AND JOHN GO RIGHT
AFTER THING YOU THANK FOR
PATIENTS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
DID YOU KNOW FIREFIGHTERS UNDER
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES DEPEND ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO INVEST IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND WHILE
THE MAINTENANCE OF COUNTY
STREET HIGHWAYS PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AND OUR SAFETY
NET SERVICES ARE CRITICAL FOR
OVER A PUBLIC SAFETY THIS
COUNTY AFTER CUSTOMERS HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY. TO EXERCISE AFFECT
THE AUTHORITY IN ORDER THE
ADEQUATELY FUNDED FIRE
DEPARTMENT AND EMS SERVICES. AS
A SENATOR SO ADEQUATELY SO
ELOQUENTLY I THINK THEY'RE VERY
EXPRESSED-DEMAND ON THESE
SERVICES HAS GONE EXPONENTIAL
IN THIS PANDEMIC AND A
FIREFIGHTER WHO DEDICATE THEIR
LIVES TO SERVING THE PUBLIC OF
THE RESULTING REVENUES WILL BE
SO HELPFUL FOR THEM TO DELIVER
THEIR MISSION AND THEIR UNITY
SO WE'RE JUST. TODAY. THANK YOU
MUCH AND THEN WILL HAVE A ONE
BELIEVES. GLORIA JONES. YEAH
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIRED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I WAS
ACTUALLY PARTICIPATING IN THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS MEETING
TRYING TO MULTI TASK THOUGH-
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
CHANCE TO ACT A FEW WORDS I AM
A MEMBER OF THE CONTRA COSTA
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND I JUST
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS
BILL. WILLALLOW US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PLATE BEFORE
VOTERS A CHANCE TO CREATE A
SUSTAINABLE LOCAL FUNDING FOR.
A VITAL SERVICES. LET ME
STREPTOCOCCI COUNTY DID NOT
HAVE CURRENTLY EIGHT LOCAL
SALES TAX WOOD COUNTY
GOVERNMENT. UNLIKE MANY OTHER
COUNTIES IN THE BAY AREA ITH
APPS BUT THE LOCAL DEDICATED
PACK- I DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU
THAT ALLOCATED THAT WERE FAKING
IT AT THE COUNTY LEVEL. OUR
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AT THE END
OUR COUNTY SANTA NEARLY A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS BOND
OKAY- WE HAVE A HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICE DEPARTMENT. AND
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
COOPERATIVELY WITH OUR COUNTY
LABOR UNIONS AND COMMUNITY AND
HAVE IT QUICKLY. MAJOR MEMBER
BALLOT IN THE BOND AFTER IT
OBVIOUSLY. THAT WOULD ALLOW US
TO RAY. BADLY NEEDED FUNDS. FOR
AWP THAT THE MORE WHEN IT ARE
FIRST RESPONDERS. SO SERVICE.
FRONT LINE WHERE. AND IT BILL
WILL BE THEY'RE OPPORTUNITY.
VOTER THAN CONTRA COBB THAT CAN
MAKE THAT CHOICE. AND WE
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIP WE
HAD WITH THE EVEN THE COUNTY.
THERE ARE MANY. PARKER IT WHICH-
NO MORE I GET ON THE BALLOT AND
WE HOPE THAT THAT ARE
COOPERATIVE EFFORT UNION TECH
WILL HAVE A PERHAPS WITH KNOW
THAT OKAY YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOU
CONSIDERATION AND THANK YOU TO
SENATOR GLAZERS REPAIRING THE
BILL ON OUR BEHALF. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WILL MOVIE TO THERE
ANYWAY HERE. TWO OR TWO THAT
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WILL MOVE OVER TO
THE MODERATOR FOR THE OF THOSE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL- PLEASE JUST YOUR NAME
YOUR POSITION AND- YOUR TITLE.
AND AS A REMINDER TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE'LL GO TO THE LINE. ONE
MOMENT HERE WE HAD ONE AND THEY
REMOVE THEMSELVES WELL ABOVE
MINIMUM TO COME BACK. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
THIS IS NICKELODEON LIQUOR ON
BEHALF OF THE MAYOR OF CONCORD
ONE OF BOYS ARE STRONG SUPPORT.
PRECIADO ALL THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE AUTHOR AND IN ADDITION THE
CITIES OF LAFAYETTE. DANVILLE
AND SAN RAMON ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO MOVE TO A
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND WE
HAVE ONE PERSON LINED UP FOR
OPPOSITION AND THAT WOULD BE.
SCOTT KAUFMAN HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
AND I BELIEVE HE'S ON THE PHONE.
SCOTT KAUFMAN. MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION. ONE MOMENT HERE I
THINK WE MIGHT HAVE THEM ON
WITH THE OPPOSING HERE RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NOW OPEN IN
LINE THREE TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD THIS IS DAVID SHOWN
BROWN WITH THE TRANSPORTATION
SOLUTIONS DEFENSE AND EDUCATION
FUND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
FUNDAMENTALLY DISHONEST WAY OF
RAISING TAXES. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE HAVE LINE THREE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CRETELLA THE
COST COST THE TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION AND I CAN BE GROUP
YES YEAH. THANK YOU BOB WE
CANNOT. SO I HAD TO WAIT MARCH
OPPOSE. FIVE THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN- WERE
VERY UNHAPPY WITH IT AND WE
THINK IT WOULD. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE THREE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS MICHAEL RATHER
REPRESENTING THE ALLIANCE OF
CONTRA COSTA TAXPAYERS. AND OUR
LETTER OF OPPOSITION WAS
SUBMITTED ORIGINALLY ON JUNE
SECOND THE SENATE THE
GOVERNMENT FINANCE COMMITTEE
BUT IT DOES NOT APPEAR IN YOUR
ASSEMBLY ANALYSIS REPORT. I'VE
RESET THE LETTER THAT WOULD BE
THE LEGISLATIVE PORTAL AND I
REQUESTED IT THEY'LL BE
INCLUDED IN YOUR ANALYSIS
REPORT. AMONG WEEKEND GOVERNING
PRINCIPLES ON WHICH SENATOR
GLAZERS CAMPAIGNED WITH A
PROMISE TO HOLD THE LINE ON
TAXES. THAT ISN'T WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS ESSENTIALLY
DECLARED ONCE AGAIN THAT THE 2%
CAP ON LOCAL IMPOSE SALES TAXES
SPECIFIED IN REVENUE TAXATION
CODE SEVEN TWO FIVE ONE POINT
ONE. DOESN'T MEAN WHAT IT SAYS.
THAT'S THE SORT OF LEGISLATIVE
SAUSAGE MAKING BECAUSE MIKE YOU
CALIFORNIA REGARD THE STATE
HOUSE AND IT'S JUST. WITH THE
REGION. SO PLEASE REJECT UNDER
HAVE BACK. THANK YOU. ONCE
AGAIN PRESS ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. I HAVE NO FURTHER
IN Q. MODERATOR WE ARE STILL
LOOKING FOR A SCOTT KAUFMAN. IS
HE IN THE QUEUE. ONE MOMENT
I'LL SEE IF HE'S ON THE CALL I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU. DO NOT
SHOW- MISTER HAPPEN ON. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU
ARE ON THE CALL. WILL MOVE ON
THEN- WHO WILL MOVE ON TO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
FOR SENATOR GLAZERS. ANY
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT IT SEEMS
LIKE YOU'RE GONNA GET AWAY SCOT
FREE HERE- DETAIN EMOTION PLAYS.
THE BILL. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
SECOND BY THREE OF US. OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I KNOW THAT
EACH OF US REPRESENTS CITIES
AND IN SOME CASES ONE OR MORE
COUNTIES I THINK IF YOU TALK TO
THEM ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW IN THE
WORLD IT'S CRASHING DOWN AROUND
THEM. IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
THEY'RE EXPECTING A SHORTFALL
OF A HUNDRED MILLION. DOLLARS
AND FOR MANY OF MY CITIES AND I
KNOW IT'S THE SAME FOR YOURS
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
SHORTFALLS AND JUST PROVIDE THE
BASIC NEEDS. AT A TIME WHEN
PEOPLE NEEDED MORE THAN EVER.
THIS MEASURE DOESN'T RAISE
TAXES PEOPLE WHO KNOW ME AND A
FEW OF THE CALLERS DO. NO MY
RELUCTANCE TO RAISE TAXES. THIS
MEASURE GIVES THE OPPORTUNITY
TO THE VOTERS OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY ONLY TO MAKE THAT
CHOICE. THE DEBATE CAN HAPPEN.
FROM ALL SIDES. AND THE VOTERS
THERE CAN MAKE THEIR BEST
JUDGMENT BUT LET'S GIVE THEM
THAT OPPORTUNITY. THIS BILL
WITHOUT THIS BILL THERE IS NO
OPPORTUNITY. THIS BILL GET THE
OPPORTUNITY AND GIVEN THE
CHOICE AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANKS GLAZERS COULDN'T
AGREE WITH YOU MORE A SOMETHING
A TOOL IN TOOLBOX TO HELP OUT
OUR COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW IS
WELL NEEDED AND AGAIN LET YOUR
COMMUNITY DECIDE IF THEY WANT
TO. MOVE FORWARDON THIS I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE WORK ON
THE BILL AND I WILL BE VOTING
AYE TODAY. MOTION IS TO PASS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I. LACKEY. LACKEY
NOW BLOOM HI. BLOOM I
BOERNER HORVATH NO.
BOERNER HORVATH NO RAMOS.
THREE OF US I THREE OF US I
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I'D
VOEPEL FULL PELL NOW. LONG CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SENATOR. OKAY LET'S SEE WHAT WE
HAVE LEFT HERE. SB NINE OH TWO
SENATOR WIENER WELCOME.
ONE
SHERMAN IBM YES YOU SURE CAN
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
KIND SIR I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR HEARING THIS BILL
TODAY AND THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
ARE PARTICULAR TIME TO REVIEW
THE BILL AND- FOR- SPEAKING
WITH ME AS WELL I APPRECIATE
IT- SB NINE OH TWO IS A- PURE
LOCAL CONTROL- BILL- I'VE HAD
SOME OTHER BILLS THAT ARE NOT
LOCAL CONTROL- BILLS OBVIOUSLY
NINE OH TWO IS A BILL- PROVIDES
GOTTA YOU GOTTA HAVE SOME
BALANCE RIGHT. GO AHEAD OF THEM
ALL I. SB NINE OH TWO PROVIDES
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA. WITH A
VOLUNTARY AND VERY POWERFUL AND
EFFECTIVE NEW TOOL THAT THOSE
CITIES CAN. USE OR NOT USE A
CITY CAN DO NOTHING. AND SB
NINE OH TWO WILL HAVE NO IMPACT
ON THAT CITY. OR A CITY CAN
OFTEN IF IT BELIEVES IT
APPROPRIATE. AND USE THIS TOOL-
THIS TOLD ME VERY HELPFUL
DESPITE THEIR COMMON
IMPRESSION- DIED. CITIES OVER
ONE WHICH HAS NEVER WON HIS OWN
FOR MORE DENSITY FOR MORE
HOUSING. BUT THAT IS NOT
ACCURATE THEIR PLENTY OF THEIR
CITIES THAT DON'T. BUT THERE
ARE CITIES THAT DO WANT TO ZONE
FOR MORE HOUSING IN PARTS OF
THEIR CITY. BUT CALIFORNIA LAW.
STATE LAW MAKES IT REALLY
REALLY HARD FOR THEM TO DO IT.
IT MAKES IT TAKE YEARS AND
YEARS AGO TAKE FIVE TO TEN
YEARS. TO DO EVEN A MODEST
REZONING. IT CAN COST AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF TAXPAYER
MONEY. TO GO THROUGH THAT YEAH
I OUR PROCESS. AND IT CAN LEAD
TO UNENDING LITIGATION AND SO
THEY ARE CITIES THAT WANT TO
ZONE FOR MORE DENSITY. IN PARTS
OF OUR CITY. BUT THEY JUST
DON'T WANT TO DEAL WITH IT
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BE SO
LENGTHY EXPENSIVE AND IS GOING
TO BE A LITIGATION. WHAT SB
NINE OH TWO DOES. IS IT ALLOWS
CITIES IF THEY CHOOSE. TO ZONE
FOR UP TO TEN UNIT BUILDINGS
ARE COULD BE THREE UNITS ARE
FIVE UNITS RESPONDING UNITS OR
TEN UNITS ARE A MIX WHATEVER
THEY WIND. UP TO TEN UNITS- IN
A STREAMLINED EXPEDITED WAY BY
ACTION OF THEIR CITY COUNCIL.
THIS ARE EXCLUDES SPRAWL THAT'S
NOT WHAT WE WANT- SO THE- THIS
TOOL IS LIMITED TO AREAS THAT
ARE NEAR. TRANSIT ORIENTED JOB
RICH AREA OR AN INFILL AREAS SO
WE DON'T WANT TO BE GIVING
CITIES. MORE TOOLS TO HAVE MORE
SPRAWL WE WANTED TO BE A
SUSTAINABLE AND SERVICE. TO
UTILIZE THIS TOOL. THE
PROMPTLY- INCREASE ERROR ZONE
HOUSING ABOUT CITY. WE HAVE AN
EFFECT TWO YEARS AGO I WAS IN
THIS COMMITTEE- BEFORE THE
CHAIR AND- I THINK THERE ARE
SOME. DIFFERENCES IN THE
COMMITTEE COMPOSITION AT THE
TIME WITH SB EIGHT TO EIGHT-
WHICH CHANGE HOW WE CALCULATE
RINA. AN INCREASE THIS CITIES
HOUSING GOALS NOT IS PLAYING
OUT NOW. IN THAT IT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE RENO WAS NOT
MEETING OUR ACTUAL HOUSING
NEEDS. IT IS NOW MUCH CLOSER TO
DOING SO IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WERE ABOUT TO GO TO THE
PROPOSITION THAT. THAT'S GOOD.
WE'RE TELLING SAID WE WANT YOU
TO BUILDING HOUSING. BUT THERE
WERE MADE HARD FOR THEM TO ZONE
IT THE ZONE TO DO SO SB NINE OH
TWO WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR
CITIES TO DO SO. I WANT TO-
JUST MAKE ONE THING VERY VERY
CLEAR SB NINE OH TWO DOES NOT
CHANGE HOW INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS
ARE APPROVED. SB NINE OH TWO IS
ABOUT THE ZONING THAT ON PAPER
AND IN THE MUNICIPAL CODE. PROT
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS WILL STILL
HAVE TO GO THROUGH WHATEVER
PROCESS EXISTS NOW WHETHER THAT
IS A SECRET DISCRETIONARY
PROCESS OR STREAMLINED PROCESS.
OR WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE
THIS DOES NOT CHANGE ON. OUR
FINALLY- I WANT TO THANK OUR
MEMBERS FOR CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THE BILL- AND SO IT'S A BASED
ON THOSE CONVERSATIONS I DO
WANT TO CAN. I TO IMPLEMENT
THAT I WILL TAKE WEEKS TO TAKEN
COMMITTEE WAS AUTHOR MEMBERS
WERE TAKEN AS AUTHOR AMENDMENTS
IN THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE- AND THOSE ARE OUR
FIRST TO PROVIDE. GLUED VERY
HIGH RISK- ZONES AND THEN
SECONDS- TO REMOVE THE LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD ALLOW I CITY
COUNCILS- TO IMPACT OF VOTER
ADOPTED- ZONING RESTRICTIONS
THAT WE CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THOSE BALLOT MEASURES AND
WHETHER THEY'RE GOOD OR NOT
GOOD YOU CAN DO IT SEPARATELY
IT DOESN'T NEED TO HAPPEN
THOUGH STILL SO WE'RE GOING TO
REMOVE THAT LANGUAGE CITY
COUNCILS WHEN IT WILL TO. JAMES
THIS OWN THAT HAS DOGGED. BY
OTHER VOTE ON THEIR
MUNICIPALITIES SO THOSE TWO
AMENDMENTS I'M COMMITTING TO
TAKE HIS AUTHOR MOMENTS WE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE I WITH ME TODAY ARE
REPRESENTATIVES OF OUR TWO CO
SPONSORS. AHA FOR ME FROM
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY AND THE
RESTAURANT TAKE FROM CALIFORNIA
YIMBY THANK YOU. THANKYOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR AND A MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD JUST PLEASE OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES. THEIR LINES
ARE OPEN GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT THE POLY FROM
ANY DAY HAD HERE TODAY I'LL BE
HAPPY TO HAVE IT HAPPEN ENTITY
CALIFORNIA WHO IS THAT COULD
BOTHER AT AT THE NINE OH TWO. I
WOULD HAVE A LITTLE BIT A FEW
AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP
DEVELOPER IN CALIFORNIA BITING
UP IT IS FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT THE-
COUNTRY STATE MARKET BACKLIT. I
HAVE ABOUT THE AMENITIES OF A
FORTY IF. THROUGHOUT THE DATA
CAN. AND WE HAVE A SERVER.
FORTY SIX HUNDRED. AND THE PATH
TEN YEARS SIXTY PERCENT. OF OUR
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND FAMILY.
5080% OF THE AREA MEDIAN
INCOME. OUR MODEL WHILE
ORIGINALLY FOCUSED ON BIG
BALLOT HOMES HAS EVOLVED IN
RECENT YEARS TO INCLUDE INFO
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING AND ALL
URBAN AS WELL AS MANY WORLD
JURISDICTION. ACCESS TO LAND
REMAINS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE OF
CONCERN FOR ALL OF OUR
AFFILIATES ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THE BILL DOES NOT
STREAMLINED OUR PROJECT FOR
EXAMPLE PROJECT CRITICAL
REVIEW. IF IT WOULD PROVIDE AN
OPTIONAL STREAMLINED TOOL FOR
PUBLIC GOVERNMENT. THANK THANK.
ONLY. YEAH PROVIDE THEM WITH A
THAT CAN BE SAID TO THE
RESTRICTED AFFORD HOMES AND IF
THEY PLACE TO CALL THERE IS NO
SILVER BULLET THE SOLVING HOW
CRISIS AND- AT THE MINUTE
ASSEMBLY ANOTHER AN EFFECTIVE
TOOL FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
HELP YOU'RE BUT IS THAT A
HISTORIC PROBLEM THROUGHOUT OUR
ENTIRE STATE THANKS THERE FOR
HIS LEADER HOWEVER. YOUR AYE
ABOUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE IN SUPPORT.
HELLO MEMBERS I'D TAKE IT
OPPORTUNITY TODAY MY NAME IS
LOUIS BRONTE I'M THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA B. WE ORGANIZE FOR
AN ADVOCATE FOR POLICIES THAT
THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL THAT
WOULD HELP CALIFORNIA WITH ALL
ITS BURKE SHORTAGE. OF HOUSING
HOUSING CRISIS AND- WE CAN
ACHIEVE IT FOR EVERYONE SB NINE
A TWO IS AN IMPORTANT TOOL IN
MEETING THAT MISSION. CENTER WE
ARE IN THIS FROM ANY THEY HAD
EVER THE BILL WELL IF I WAS TO
FOCUS ONLY ON AT THE- OUR LOCAL
YOU BE ALLIES. AROUND THE STATE
IT ACTUALLY DOESN'T. BOTHER
CALIFORNIA. HAVE BY GOOD FOR
YOU REAL ISSUE FOR SOME
PROTECTION BECAUSE THEIR
PROPERTY WHEN ROCK AND A HARD
PLACE. OF NEEDING TO COMPLY
WITH THE GOOD THING REGIONAL.
AND COUNTRY FACING A LAWSUIT
FROM THEM BECAUSE THEY
TRANSPORTATION. THANK YOU FOR
UP FOR BY. A OPTION. AFTER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PURSUE. IN
PLACES WHERE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS IS NOT TO BE AT THE
CORNER EMPATHIZE WITH BETTER
WINNER NOTED THAT THE BILL
STREAMLINED THE PLANNING NOT
THE ACTUAL CONSTRUCTION OF THE
PROJECT. THIS RELIEF IS NEEDED
NOW WE'RE GOING TO RUN CITY
COUNCIL ALREADY STRUGGLING WITH
THEIR BUDGET. PREVENTING THEM
FROM NEEDING TO PAY FOR PUBLIC
WALK THROUGH. THE MORE WE CAN
RESEARCH FROM THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF HOME BUILDERS
FIND THAT BUILDING A THOUSAND
POUND. INCREASE TWO THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED FULL TIME JOBS AND
GENERATE ALMOST ELEVEN HUNDRED
TO A HUNDRED ELEVEN MILLION.
IMPACTING ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT FOR THE FIRE PRIVATE
SCHOOLS. HAVE BEEN ADDED TO
HELP THE PATIENT OKAY. WELL.
WE'RE HAPPY TO BE HERE SUPPORT
THE- VERY MUCH. WITNESS HAULING
MANY SHERRI SHEPHERD HAVE
DEVISED A TREATISE FOR A
SIMILAR PAINTED OKAY GET UP
MONTEREY CAN YOU OPEN THE LINE
FOR THEM THOSE IN SUPPORT AND
PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF JUST NAME
XIN AN ORGANIZATION THANK YOU.
OKAY AND AS A REMINDER IT IS
ONE ONE ZERO THIS IS FOR
SUPPORT. FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS NOT QUALIFY
THEM WITH A MORE VENTURA COUNTY
CALLING IN SUPPORT. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE THREE HUNDRED FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MRS ROSS
TOLD ON BEHALF OF SANTA CRUZ
GAMBIAN. THANK YOU NOT. NEXT
WOULD ALIGN THREE FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS MOIRA
TOP ON BEHALF OF ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS COUNCIL STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE THREE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO ARE YOU
SURE OAKLAND CALLING WITH EAST
BAY FOR EVERYONE IN SUPPORT FOR
THAT THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE
THREE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE NEW
MADAM CHAIR ADAMANTLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WERE IN COURT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT IS ONE THREE FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS DENNIS BOYCE ON CALLING
FROM VAN NUYS ON BEHALF OF US
TO BE IN B. AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT IS LINE THREE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE STORE IS ON BEHALF OF
UP FOR GROWTH ACTION CALIFORNIA
SPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE
THREE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MANY
THREE CAME UP I LIVE IN THE OF
WINNETKA AND WITHOUT THAT IN
BEING I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU SUPPORT AT THE
NINETEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT IS ONE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CAN DOWNTURN ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF ASSOCIATED
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
NEXT IS LINE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS EATEN STRAW WITH THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
IN SPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT IS LINE THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IT MAY FAN ON BEHALF
OF BRIDGE HOUSING AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTER THE SHOCKING HIGHER BE
HAPPY SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
IS ONE THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS S BOB NAYLOR
REPRESENTING THE DEAL'S DEAD
AND COMPANY AND ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ABOUT ENSURING
MEMBERS AREN'T ABLE AND CAN'T
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION IMPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE THIS GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
WHAT. DO YOU MEAN SUPPORTING
ACTING ON A TIP. HANK YOU.
NEXT IS LINE THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THIS YOU MIGHT IF YOU CAN
ADEQUATE THEY BURY COUNCIL AND
STRONG SUPPORT AND AT THE NINE
OH TWO. NEXT IN LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS NOT AN ANIMAL ON ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF HISPANIC REAL
ESTATE PROFESSIONALS AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS
IS GREAT- ON BEHALF OF
SCHNEIDER ELECTRIC NORTH
AMERICAN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT DEADLINE TUESDAY
NEXT OF MINE TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD YOR
LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON MEMBERS
DOESN'T MATTER THAT WHAT HAD
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF. THAT COALITION WHICH
INCLUDES CANDY PARTNER.
CONTAMINATION SB AT HOME. AND
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
PLANNING AND URBAN. RESEARCH
INSTITUTION. OLOGY WHAT ABOUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT IS
LINE THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS JORDAN GRIMES I'M CALLING
FROM SAN MATEO CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF AN INSULT FOR
EVERYONE IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
THE MAGNITUDE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT WE GO TO LINE THREE
HUNDRED FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
STILL THE FERRARI ON BEHALF OF
FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIVE AT THE
COFFEE BEAN- HELLO ALSO-
REPRESENTING PLAN FOR EVERYONE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT IS ONE THREE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS VICTORIA
HERE SIGN EXECUTIVE LET YOU
THINK FOR EVERYONE HERE IN
OVERWHELMING SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MAX'S LINE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWENTY EIGHT SORRY I DIDN'T
HEAR CORRECT WE HEAR YOU THANK
YOU- HELLO THIS IS ME OF THE IS
YOUR FROM THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT NEXT HEADLINE THREE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS MY LOW TRAVELS
SAN FRANCISCO CALLING ON BEHALF
OF PROGRESS NO LEGALITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
BAXTER'S LINE THREE HUNDRED
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN
THE REYNOLDS CALIFORNIA
ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF THE LOW
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANKS IS LINE THREE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE CARD FOR NEIGHBORHOOD
CENTERS CALLING INSTRUCTIONS
FOR. THANK YOU ACCESS LINE.
THREE THREE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS LIZ CRAIG OF
QUINCE SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA
MEMBER OF SOUTH BAY EMB CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE ZERO TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT IS
LINE THREE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MICHELLE RANT WHAT THE **** ON
THE BALLOT COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
AND SUPPORT THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS KATHY CARE
CHEN CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE TO EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
HENRY HOOKER CALLING ON BEHALF
OF SANTA CRUZ SENIORS FOR
HOUSING. STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
NINE OH TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT IS LINE THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DUNCAN MCFETRIDGE
REPRESENTING THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT IS LINE. ONE NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL MOVE ON
THE BUDGET WHICH IS LINE THREE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
NORMA'S MIND IN SILENCE OBISPO
CALLING ON BEHALF OF LOCAL
UNITY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
DONE ONLY A CROW AND I'M
CALLING TODAY- DEPENDED
CALIFORNIA WITH ABUNDANT
HOUSING LOS ANGELES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE THREE HUNDRED
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON AMANDA CRUISE
WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT ARE PART
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE OF
THREE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
CAN'T SHARE NUMBERS JASON
BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DOWNTOWN ASSOCIATION
WE ARE SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT IN LINE SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ALFRED I
LIVE IN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND
I SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT IS
LINE THREE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'LL
BE MORE SHAUNA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SANTA MONICA EMB AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANKS. THANK
YOU. NEXT IS LINE THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I THE
TEACHER A QUICK CAL- WILL HAVE
YOU THINK BUT LONG BEACH EVERY
INSTRUCTED PORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND ON
BEHALF OF SALE FOR THE PART
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT IS
LINE THREE FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS JAMIE FIRST PETE
CALLING FROM OCEANSIDE
CALIFORNIA THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF HISPANIC REAL
ESTATE PROFESSIONALS CALLING IN
THE STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DIDN'T
DEREK ACORN FROM OAKLAND
CALLING FROM- EFFECT FOR
EVERYONE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE
LINE FOUR ZERO TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
FOUR HUNDRED TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU LIKE DAVID CALLING
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA. I
OPPOSE. NEXTER GOING TO LINE
FOUR HUNDRED AND THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS AMPLE
UNDER CALLING FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA WITH HEALTH
SACRAMENTO LOCAL GIVE ME GROUP
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND OUR FINAL IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME IS LINE FOR
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS ALEXANDRA CALIFORNIA
YIMBY CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK.
LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE ONE MORE
THAT'S QUEUED UP WHILE WE WERE
WAITING. COMES FROM LINE THREE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS DONNA CHISHOLM I OPPOSE- SB
NINE OH TWO. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT IT'S
ONE ZERO. OKAY IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE. WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE THAT ARE QUEUING UP HERE
THE NEXT COMES IN THE LINE OF
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD YES MY NAME IS TERRY
TECHNIQUE AND I'M ON THE BOARD
OF THE WESTWOOD HILLS PROPERTY
OWNERS ASSOCIATION AND LOS
ANGELES REPRESENTING MORE THAN
SIX HUNDRED FAMILIES AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
ONCE THE PRESS ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. IF YOU ARE IN QUEUE
RIGHT NOW FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE
WAIT AND PRESS ONE ZERO TO
REMOVE YOURSELF. WE'LL GO TO
THE LINETO EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WE'LL WE'LL MOVE ON
THEY REMOVE THEMSELVES LINE
THREE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUSINESS PROPOSITION. SUPPORT
NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT TO GO
TO LINE ONE AT NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NONE OF THE
PROBLEMS REPRESENTING OUR UP
AND WOOD WHAT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR GOING ONLINE THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS OPPOSITION NOW I DON'T
KNOW STILL SUPPORT MOMENT. NEXT
DEADLINE THREE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL MOVE TO
THE LAST ONE IN Q. WHICH IS
LINE FOUR ZERO TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE LINE.
LINE FOUR HUNDRED TWO YOU ARE
ALIVE. THIS OPPOSITION NO
SUPPORT. PLEASE GET BACK TO ALL
WE HAVE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MODERATOR I'M NOT
QUITE OPEN TO THE ROAD THOSE IN
AROUND. FORTY TWO OH TWO IF
THEY WOULD BUT AFTER IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ERIN LEHANE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS. IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL OF
AMENDED. TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE SCALE OF THE BILL BUT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING.
WITH THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
AND MOVE IT FORWARD THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MANAGER MEMBERS
RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION-
WE'VE SUPPORT THE BILL IF
AMENDED WE'VE ASKED THE AUTHOR
TO CONSIDER RESTORING LANGUAGE
HE HAD AN EARLIER VERSION OF
THE BILL. THAT HAD TO DO WITH
THE ROBUST. ROBUST LANGUAGE
RELATIVE RELATIVE TO SOUND
RENTAL HOUSING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THIRTY ONE ELSE IN FORTY
TWO OH TWO. SEEING NONE OKAY SO
WE'LL NOW TAKE OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AND OUR SPEAKER
WILL BE MAYOR BILL BRAND OF THE
CITY OF REDONDO BEACH WELCOME
MAYOR. HERE AGAIN ARE CURRY-
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON THE ELECTED MAYOR OF
REDONDO BEACH FOR THE LAST
THREE YEARS AND WHAT THE
COUNCIL MEMBER FOR THE PREVIOUS
EIGHT YEARS. AT OVER ELEVEN
THOUSAND RESIDENTS PER SQUARE
MIE REDONDO BEACH IS VERY
DENSELY POPULATED COMMUNITY OUR
SCHOOLS ARE FULL TRAFFIC IS
GRIDLOCKED AND WE HAVE
DEVELOPED OUR WAY INTO A
STRUCTURAL BUDGET DEFICITS
BECAUSE THEY'RE DENSE
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT COST
THE CITY MORE IN SERVICE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. THEN IT RETURNS
IN PROPERTY CAT NEEDS SO YEAH
WE HAVE MOST PRINTERS IN
REDONDO BEACH AND THOSE RUNNERS
OCCUPIED A WIDE VARIETY OF
HOUSING FROM SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES THE HIGH DENSITY
APARTMENT BUILDINGS. WE EVEN
HAVE A SECTION EIGHT PROGRAM
THAT DISTRIBUTES OVER FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND
RENTAL ASSISTANCE WE DO NOT
HAVE A HOUSING SHORTAGE HERE WE
HAVE AN AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
AND LIKE MANY OF THE HOUSING
BILLS UNDER CONSIDERATION THIS
SESSION. SB NINE OH TWO
DEMOCRATS WILLING NOTHING WHEN
CREE SUPPORTABLE HOUSING STOCK.
MUCH OF SB NINE OH TO SIMPLY
RESTATES WHAT CITY COUNCIL CAN
ALREADY DO WE DON'T POP ABOUT
TEN UNITS OR EVEN MORE THIS
BILL WITHOUT WOULD ALLOW US TO
CIRCUMVENT SEQUEL. BY ALLOW
BACK ANALYZING IMPACTS IN
DEFINING MITIGATIONS ALLOWS FOR
GROWTH WITHOUT. DESTROYING OUR
QUALITY OF LIFE. CLEVELEYS
CIRCUMVENTING C. IS RECKLESS
NEIGHBORS. K. INSULT TO IN S.
NINE OKAY VITAL OUR FOR SO ONE
OF THE- CON. WE READ QUOTE THE
LEGISLATIVE POWER OF THE STATE
IS VESTED IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE BUT THE PEOPLE
RESERVE TO THEMSELVES THE
POWERS OF INITIATIVE AND
REFERENDUM ONE QUOTE.
LEGISLATING ELATION EMPOWERING
CITY COUNCIL TO OVERRIDE THAT
RESEARCH POWER OF THE PEOPLE IS
CLEARLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL FORMER
GOVERNOR HIRAM JOHNSON MUST BE
ROLLING IN HIS GRAVE. YOUR OWN
ASSEMBLY BUILDING HOUSES OF
THIS BILL QUOTE THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE AT THE CALLED INTO
QUESTION THE ETHICAL
IMPLICATIONS QUOTE IS IT
APPROPRIATE TO ALLOW A LOCAL
GOVERNING BODY TO OVERRIDE THE
WISHES OF ITS CONSTITUENTS. IF
YOU BELIEVE IN THEIR OWN
DEMOCRACY THE ANSWER IS NOW. BY
THE WAY REDONDO BEACH IS
ALREADY UPDATING OUR GENERAL
PLAN TO MEET OUR NEW READ A
NUMBER WHICH IS RECENTLY
DOUBLED INNER CITY COUNCIL
RECENTLY WERE REQUIRED 20%
AFFORDABLE UNITS AS PART OF A
LARGE PROJECT REPURPOSE OUR
MALL. AND WE WERE SPECIFIC THAT
IT HAD TO BE LOW OR VERY LOW
INCOME AFFORDABLE. OUR STATE IS
ALREADY ACCOMPLISHING WHAT THIS
AND OTHER STATE BILLS DO NOT.
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY IT THE
ANSWER. RECKLESS CENTER WIDE
LAND USE PLANNING COMMITMENT
SACRAMENTO IS NOT THE ANSWER.
CENTER PARTY DID NOT WORK IN
RUSSIA AND IT WILL NOT WORK
HERE. STOP I'M ASKING FOR YOUR
NOTEBOOK ON THIS BILL SB NINE
OH TWO. IT DOES NOTHING TO
CREATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY. SB NINE OH TO
VIOLATE THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION AND TOWARDS THE
EXPRESSED WILL OF THE VOTERS
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE. PLEASE
VOTE NOW IN SB NINE OH TWO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MAYOR BRAND WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO OTHER ANYONE ON
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE FORTY
TWO OH TWO. SEEING NONE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD OPEN UP
THE LINES AGAIN HENNIG ONCE
AGAIN LET'S REMIND EVERYBODY
NAME. PHYSICIAN AN ORGANIZATION
ONLY THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER IT IS ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. OUR FIRST WILL COME
FROM THE LINE THIRTY ONE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I LIVE HELLO. YES YES WE
HEAR YOU OKAY THANK YOU HI MY
NAME IS RACHEL WAS LUCKY ON THE
PRESIDENT RAMPARTS VILLAGE NYC
COUNCIL A CERTIFIED
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL CHARTER
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
REPRESENTING TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND STAKEHOLDERS. THE
RAMPART VILLAGE NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL HAVE SUBMITTED OUR
RESOLUTION THROUGH OUR PORTAL
WE STANFORD OPPOSITION SB NINE
OH TO ASK YOUR NO VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NET NEXT OF MINE
FORTY FOUR ONE ONE FOUR ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS RAY
ONE OF THE VICE CHAIR AND
FORMER CHAIR OF THE CUPERTINO
CITY PLANNING COMMISSION I'M
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF I'M CALLING
JUST POST SB NINE OH TWO- ON
CONSTITUTIONAL AS WELL AS
PORTABILITY GROUNDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE FOUR
HUNDRED FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON THIS IS MIKE WEST
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES WE
CAN WITH THE BUILDING TRADES IN
A SUPPORT IMPLEMENTED POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ACCESS
LINE FOR TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARY ELIZA
PROGRAM BUT IT'S JUST- AND
STRONG OPPOSITION I'M SPEAKING
WITH LEVEL CALIFORNIA AN EXTRA
NINE STRONG OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MATT
KREMIN HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA THAT ACCOMPLISH OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS WE ARE
SUPPORT IT AMENDED TO READ AS
LAID OUT BY THE BUILDING
TRADES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT IS LINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS ONE THAT I
MCELROY I REPRESENT LITTLE
CALIFORNIA KATIE WITH A
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF LOCAL
ELECTED AND ELECTED AND
GRAYBURN AVENUE BLOCK CLUB IN
SOUTH CENTRAL LOS ANGELES WE
UPHOLD NINE OH TWO WE AFFIRM
THE OSITION OF MAYOR BRAND
THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE FOUR
HUNDRED TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE
WILL BE. THE ONE WE USUALLY
HAVE A HARD DRIVE THAT ONCE
AGAIN LINE FOR OR TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FINALLY CLEAR WATR OF
CALIFORNIA REALLY GROUP HOME. I
AM IN THE OFFICE I DIDN'T FIND
EVIDENCE OF THE- WORLD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NET LINE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JILL STUART I LIVE IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY- I
BELONG TO TWO GROUPS ANGELENOS
FOR TREES A LITTLE CALIFORNIA-
WE HAVE READ THE BILL CLOSELY
WAS GLAD YOU GOT RID OF THE
OVERRIDING OF THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE TEN UNIT LUXURY
APARTMENTS ARE NOT GOING TO
HELP ANYONE WERE OLDER BUILT ON
LUXURY AND THERE'S NO YOUR
DOUBLE REQUIRED WHATSOEVER.
NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS NOW AMERICA
SOME OF COMMUNITIES NINETY.
SEVEN AND I VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE.
SENATE DEMOCRATIC. THANK YOU.
NEXT IS LINE THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DONNA
CHISHOLM I'M A MEMBER OF CURB
FEENEY CITIZENS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUILDING WE OPPOSE
SB NINE OH TWO THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT IS LINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS BRENDA
LAPORTE'S HERE TO CALIFORNIA WE
ARE SUPPOSED CURRENTLY BUT WE
WILL BE REVIEWING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE FOUR
HUNDRED TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KAPLAN CITIZENS OVER PRESERVING
BENNETT PLEASE EXEMPTS THE
COASTAL COMMUNITIES OF VENICE
AND OTHERS AND THEREFORE I WILL
OPPOSE THIS THANK YOU. NEXT IS
LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAILING
STEPHENS SPEAKING FOR MYSELF
AND MY SUNNYVALE NEIGHBORS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE
THREE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS GLENDA
MANIA AND- FROM LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA BY GREATLY OPPOSED
SB NINE OO TO. THANK YOU. NEXT
IS LINE FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MIKE REALLY WHAT DOES
YOUR CAPTAINCY CAMPAIGNERS
OUTRAGE FOR SENATE BILL
INTRODUCED SUPPORT IF AMENDED.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS RATE
LOWER BURKE FROM NEXT IN
ORGANIZATION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB NINE OH TWO. Q. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
JASON BACKERS OF LAFAYETTE PART
OF THE NICK THE NINE CAMPAIGN
DEFENSIVE CORPS AND I OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE FOR
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS
IS AMY MCCORD CALLING ON BEHALF
OF AND SAY THAT'S RESIDENTS FOR
RESPONSIBLE DEVELOPMENT AND WE
AT THE GROUPS STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB NINE OH TWO. THANK YOU
IN LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ANY JUST FACT A MEMBER
OF RIVIERA HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION THE SOUTH BAY AND
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS FOR LOCAL
CONTROL THERE'S NO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND DEVELOPERS ARE
ALREADY IN FRENZIED SPECULATION
BIDDING ON PROPERTIES PROTECT.
WILL MOVE UNDER THE LINE OF
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL I
REMEMBER THE LOS ANGELES-
WELCH'S CENTER ON NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL AND WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY
FUNDING URBAN DEVELOPMENT
INITIATIVE IF I HAVE A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME- COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. STEPPING UP THE TREES
AND- NO NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO THE
LINE OF EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IT. NINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO WE CAN HEAR
YOU. IT. GENDRE MOSTLY WITH THE
BILL HIKES BLOCKS BOB I'M THE
PRESIDENT AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE- SENATE BILL NINE OH
TWO. THANK YOU. NEXT IS LINE
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THE FIRST
CHAIR OF THE NEXT THE NINE
CAMPAIGN REPRESENTING THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO OPPOSED
SENATE BILL NINE OH TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT TO MINE
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE FOUR HUNDRED FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RODRIGUEZ I'M
A HOMEOWNER OF THIRTY YEARS IN
SOUTH LOS ANGELES. PEOPLE
WORKING IN THE DOORWAY HOW
COULD ANYONE SUPPORT TO BUILD
NINE OH TWO I'D DO ANYTHING
NOTHING BUT MARKET RATE HOUSING
Q. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO THE WIND
OF ONE HUNDRED AND FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE ONE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT
DEADLINE. THIRTY TO NINE THIRTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WILL MOVE AGAIN TO LINE.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN LINE ONE EIGHT
SEVEN YOUR LINES OPEN. HELLO.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE ON AGAIN
THE LINE FORTY FOUR LINE FORTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MARY
JACKAL PRESERVING VANECK PLACES
THAT THE COASTAL GUN IN SPECIAL
COMMUNITIES LIKE VANECK. POSES
WRITTEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. IN HELLO
HI YES E HEAR YOU. ALL HELLO
MY VERY MOST PEOPLE START THEIR
YOU KNOW AND WE OPPOSED BY NO
TO. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE WIND ONE NINETY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE ONE NINETY TWO. AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE FOUR ZERO ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
DAVID FERGUSON I'M A NATIVE SAN
FRANCISCAN LIFELONG RESIDENT
HELD REPRESENTING MYSELF AND
ALSO- SUNSET. WEBSITE ACTIVE
RESIDENTS F WITH THIS BILL
NINE OH TWO DOES NOTHING TO- TO
HELP- HOUSING DENSITY IN FACT-
SCOTT WIENER IS FROM NEW JERSEY
AND DOES NOT UNDERSTAND SAN
FRANCISCO THANK YOU. YEAH WE'LL
GO TO LINE FOUR ZERO FIVE FOUR
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR FIVE
ARE YOU NEEDED. PART ARE MOVING
ON OVER ONE THREE NINETY TWO
THREE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CAROL FORD
I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA PILOTS ASSOCIATION
AND WE OPPOSE. THE BILL NINE
ZERO TWO. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE DID THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE FOR TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. JANE
KENNEDY LOVABLE RIVERSIDE AND
MORENO VALLEY WE OPPOSE. YEAH.
AND NEXUS LINE THREE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
TWENTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN HI
THANK YOU AND I ADMIT I'M
VALERIE HOOD FOUNDER OF STOP
GOT LEANER NOW REPRESENTING SIX
HUNDRED PEOPLE AND GROWING
DAILY THANK YOU AND IN PART OF
THE VISION OF MAYOR BRAND WE
HAVE STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
AND LINE THREE THIRTY NINE
EUROPE. BY THREE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RESPONSIBLE
ONE FOUR HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CAROL
AUSTIN'S WOULD PROTECTING THE
FOOTHILL COMMUNITY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS ALONG WITH THE
MAYORS IT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO TO ONE
THREE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO LINE FOR THIRTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. HI I'M
GETTING MORE I AM A CURRENT
CHAIR OF THE CUPERTINO PLANNING
COMMISSION REPRESENTING MYSELF
I LIVE IN AN R. ONE EASTBOUND
ARCHITECTURALLY SIGNIFICANT
EICHLER NEIGHBORHOOD AND AYE
OPPOSED SB NINE OH TWO. THANK
YOU. MY FOUR OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WINE WICKS WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHAT YOUR LINE IS ALL
WELL. WELL WE WANT WE'LL GO TO
LINE THREE NINETY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LISA MORRISON I'M
INVOLVED WITH SEVERAL COMMUNITY
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AND THE
FOOT HILLS AREA ABVE GLENDALE.
AND MAYOR BRAND OF REDONDO
BEACH THAT IT BACK ALL MY WORDS
SO I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED ON
BEHALF OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS. ONE THREE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS ERIC PARKINSON I
REPRESENT THE GOVERNOR'S A
NEIGHBORHOOD IMPROVEMENT
ASSOCIATION IN LOS ANGELES AS
WELL AS THE SAN PASQUALE ARROYO
SECO WILDLIFE HABITAT
PRESERVATION AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BILL. NEXT IN
LINE THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE
THREE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE EIGHTY THREE ARE YOU MODE
MUTED. WELL IN A LONG FOR
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HELLO FROM. ARE YOU CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YEAH WE HEAR YOU I'M
GONNA JUST OKAY THANK YOU- THIS
IS STEPHEN ALSO FROM SAVORING
WOULD COMMUNITY OF SIX THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN WORK ON INCORPORATED
MARIN COUNTY WE STAND WITH- THE
NEXT THE NINE CAMPAIGN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA PRINT AND IN FIVE
MINUTES. WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
EXPLAIN THE TIME ON YOUR
CONFERENCE. YES SIR OKAY THANK
YOU ONE MOMENT. WAIT A MINUTE
HELLO IT'S NOT MY CREDIT CARD.
WHAT HOW MUCH TIME WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO TRY TO EXTEND
ANOTHER HOUR THIS IS. I
HONESTLY THOUGHT I DON'T KNOW
I'M TRYING TO GET THROUGH. I'M
JUST WONDERING YOUR CALL GONNA
END HERE PRETTY QUICK I JUST
WANT TO SEE HOW LONG YOU WOULD
LIKE ME TO EXTEND THIS CALL
YOUR PASTOR HI I WISH I I'M
CONFUSED I WAS TALKING TO YOU
ASSEMBLY USER. BUT I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON OKAY THIRTY
MINUTES. FORTY FIVE MINUTES
HELLO. EXTENDED FOR FORTY FIVE
MINUTES PLEASE THANK YOU
SOMEONE WHOSE CREDIT CARDS
ASSIGNED. I'M IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE SENDING MY- MY GODSEND AND
I WAS CUT OFF I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED. I'M YOUR NAME- YOUR
POSITION IN YOUR TITLE PLEASE.
EVEN NOW SO SAY BERMAN WOULD-
PART OF THE NIXON NINE CAMPAIGN
AND LIVABLE CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT- BUSINESS STATEMENTS OF
MAYOR BRANT OPPOSING NINE OH
TWO. THANK YOU. I NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE FOR TWENTY I'M A STEP
AWAY IT'S NOT LETTING ME
EXTEND- I DON'T KNOW BUT
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH SPACE ON THE
BRIDGE LAPTOP I'LL BE RIGHT
BACK THANK YOU IT'S NOT WHAT
YOU DON'T WITH THAT. I
APOLOGIZE A WHITE FOR TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE YOU
SPEAKING TO MAY I WOULD FOR
TWENTY NINE. I HAD OKAY. OKAY
MOVING ON OVER LINE. R. FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT. YES THIS
IS STEPHEN NESTLE- PARTED-
SAVERIN WOULD NX- THE NINE
CAMPAIGN AND LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
WE SO STRONGLY OPPOSE AND
SUPPORT THE STATEMENT SAID- MAY
OUR BRANCH OF REDONDO BEACH.
THANK YOU. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHY ONE TWELVE YOU ARE
OPEN. YES HELLO. OKAY HI I'M
SORRY ABOUT THAT BUT THEN THE
SECOND ISSUE I CALLED BEGIN ON
AND I WOULD NOT FIND A NUMBER
EITHER TRYING TO GET IN MY MIND
GOING BY TURNING I APOLOGIZE MY
NAME IS MARK GOTTEN FROM
COMMUNITIES UNITED EIGHTY SEVEN
FIVE ALL OF I ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ATTACK. ON
SEQUEL THANK YOU. AND IT'S
SUPER LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
YEAH THIS IS MICHAEL SIGNER ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTWOOD
HIGHLANDS NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND WE OPPOSE SENATE BILL NINE
OH TWO. THANK YOU. THANKS WE
WILL ALIGN THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHTY ASIAN AND
LOS ANGELES. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES HELLO. YEAH AND-
REPRESENTING MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED FAMILIES WE FILED PALM
FORMAL OPPOSITION THROUGH THE
PORTAL BUT WE WANT TO REITERATE
OUR STRONG OPERATION YOUR
CONFERENCE WILL END IN ONE
MINUTE. OUR STRONG OPPOSITION
TO NINE OH TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE WHAT
WE CAN RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO TAKE A PAUSE SO THEY
CAN RESET IT SO I'M SORRY FOR
THE INCONVENIENCE FOR EVERYONE
SO LET'S. CONTINUE MODERATOR
ANOTHER CALL UNTIL WE DIE. OKAY
WE WILL I'M SORRY FOR FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DON'T
KNOW I THINK A LOT. FORTY NINE
YOUR OPEN. YES HI. HELLO THIS
IS JILL OF THE COUNCILMEMBER
JULISSA. REPRESENTING CALLIE
CALIFORNIA LINE LOCAL ELECTIVE
WE STAND FOR SEQUEL TO THE BILL
WITH NO REQUIREMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE OPPOSE SB
NINE OH TWO. THANK YOU- LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN I WOULD LIKE TO
APOLOGISE WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO HAVE EIGHTEEN T. RESET OF
THE PHONE IN CALLS- THOSE OF
YOU IN THE QUEUE IF YOU CAN BE
PATIENT I BELIEVE YOU MAY HAVE
TO RECALL IN- I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'LL BE ANY NEW NUMBER CAN
YOU VERIFY THAT STAFF. OKAY
WELL YEAH WE'RE NOT SO I
APOLOGIZE PLEASE- PLEASE LOOK
OUT OF THE SCREEN IF THERE'S A
RESTORING YOUR CONFERENCE IS
ENDING NOW PLEASE HANG UP.
THERE'S A.
YEAH.
SINCE WE HAVE
A BREAK HERE- WE ARE GOING TO
DECIDE TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
I HAVE A MOTION MOVED. A
MOTION. AND A SECOND BY MISTER
RIVAS. CONSENT CALENDAR DO PASS
AND RE REFER BOOKS USE ME SORRY.
DO YOU HAVE TO CONSENT CALENDAR
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE BLOOM
ROOM AYE BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS RAMOS.
ROBERT RIVAS HI VOEPEL. OKAY
AND THEN. CONSENT IS AT SEVEN
ZERO. THANK YOU.
UHHUH.
IF
ANYBODY NEEDS A QUICK- BREAK
IT'S GOING TO BE FIVE TEN
MINUTES AT THE MOST BEFORE BACK
ONLINE I APOLOGIZE. AND THOSE
THAT MIGHT BE ON PHONE LINES
ARE WONDERING WHAT WE'RE DOING
WE'RE WAITING FOR TO RE.
CONNECT WITH OUR PHONE LINES
THANK YOU.
JUSTIN I HAVE THE
WEBEX LINE CONNECTED. GREAT
LAURIE THANK YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD- MANAGER. I'M IN MY
ASSURED THAT IT'S A THE SAME
TELEPHONE NUMBER AND CALL THE
OTHERS HAVE BEEN YOU. THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY. ALL RIGHT I WANT
TO THANK OF YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE DURING THIS THIS IS
REALLY NOT GENERALLYHAPPENING
BUT IT DID TODAY. WE ARE GOING
TO GO BACK TO THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. YES SEVERAL. I
WOULD THIS IS OPPOSITE AND YEAH
I NEED YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
AGAIN WE ARE MODERATOR I'M
LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION ONLY
THANK YOU. I'M I AM A
CONNECTING SOME JUST ONE MOMENT
PLEASE THANK YOU.
I HAVE A
HEADACHE. THE NEW. MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE- ANYONE OPPOSITION
LINING UP. I'M TRYING TO CHECK
JUST ONE MOMENT THANK YOU. YEAH
THERE WAS QUITE A FEW SOON TO.
I'M HERE REALLY FAST TYPIST.
THE OPERATOR I APOLOGIZE I
DIDN'T HAVE MY LAN AND MUTE.
TO
THE PHONE OPERATOR IF YOU CAN
STILL IF YOU CAN STAND BY FOR
ME. PLEASE.
IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT WE'RE BRINGING EVERYONE
INTO THE MAIN CONFERENCE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR
STANDING BY THIS IS THE
EIGHTEEN P. CONFERENCE
OPERATOR- WILL TRY TO CHECK
WITH THOSE THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS STAR
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY
PAD AGAIN THAT IS STAR THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD.
AND IF YOU ARE UING YOUR-
SPEAKER PHONE YOU MAY NEED TO
PICK UPTHE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS. AGAIN OF
FOUR OUT IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS STAR
THEN ZERO ON THE PHONE KEYPAD.
MOMENT PLEASE AS WE GET OF
SOMEONE QUEUED UP THANK YOU.
HE
WE HAVE MY NUMBER ONE THREE
FOUR I'M GOING TO OPEN YOUR
LINE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE ONE
THREE FOR THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD MY NAME IS.
ROCCO I LIVE IN STUDIO CITY AND
I'M WITH LEVEL CALIFORNIA LOS
ANGELES CONSERVANCY I BELIEVE
SB NINE OH TWO DISENFRANCHISES
CALIFORNIA VOTERS IN FAVOR BIG
BUSINESSES AND UNCHECKED
DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU
PRECIPITATOR TRAFFIC. MACINNES
THAT'S JUST THE NAME POSITION
AN ORGANIZATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THOUGH. SAMANTHA LAROCCO
GSA OPPOSE THANK YOU. HE WILL
MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER ONE THREE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE THREE SIX. IN THE
CORALLINE FIREBOX AND I OPPOSE.
NINE OH TWO BECAUSE THIS IS
THANK YOU VERY COMPLEX. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE ONE FOUR TWO THE LINE
IS OPEN ONE FOUR TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MELISSA
MCCAFFREY ON BEHALF OF THE
AIRCRAFT OWNERS AND PILOTS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND AVIATORS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SENATE BILL
NINE THERE TO. THANK YOU. NEXT
TO LINE ONE FOUR THREE THE LINE
IS OPEN ONE FOUR THREE.
BUT
NINE ONE FOUR THREE WE HAVE A
LINE OPEN FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
HELLO. I HAD MY ONE ONE THREE
YES YOU ARE MY ONCE I GET ALL
RIGHT OKAY I GIVE YOUR AYE
DIDN'T I HAVEN'T OKAY I'M WITH
THE BILL I LIVE IN SOUTHERN IN
LOS ANGELES THE AREA AND I
STRONGLY AT THE NINE OO TO
THANK YOU. NO A GOOD THANK YOU.
WHY NUMBER ONE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD LAW. ONE FOUR. AND ONE
FOUR FOUR WE HAVE A LOT FOR YOU.
AGAIN NINE ONE FOUR FOUR IF YOU
WANT TO CHECK YOUR MUTE FEATURE.
THERE'S NO RESPONSE ONLINE ONE
FOR ME TO CLOSE THAT LINE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FOUR SIX
THE LINE IS OPEN ONE FOUR SIX.
WHAT WHAT. NINE ONE FOUR SIX
LINE IS IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK.
THAT THE WOMAN. WE HAVE NO
RESPONSE ONLINE FORCE SEVEN A
CO THAT. YEAH MY NUMBER ONE FOR
EACH THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR A WARRANT
NEXT THE NINE WITH A BOOK CAL.
COURT AGREED FILLED.
PORTABILITY MATTERS OF OUR
FAITH AND DOUBT WELL FAR ENOUGH.
THANK YOU I NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO NUMBER ONE ONE PLEASE GO.
ONE FIVE ONE. IN ONE FIVE ONE
WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK ONE FIVE ONE CAN
YOU HEAR ME. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. YOU CAN HEAR ME YEAH I
WOULD NEVER GET NUMBER OKAY YOU
CAN HEAR ME OKAY. MY NAME IS
NANCY COLLEGE TO STAY ëA BALL
WHAT VALLEY AND WE AT HONOLULU
I KNOW TO THANK YOU. HELLO YOU.
THANK YOU WILL NEED THAT LINE
ONE MOMENT. NUMBER OF. FIND ONE
FIVE TWO ONE PLEASE CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES GO AHEAD THANK YOU
MANY PEOPLE JOHN AND JUST ABOUT
A LOT FIRE WE HAD SEVEN FIRED
ON I'M JUST BACKING IT OUT OF
WHY THIS IS SEVEN FIVE A LOT
THREE WEEK IN LINE POLICE AMONG
AND. THE FEELING ALLOWING MORE
HOW TO GET. THINGS YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NO. THANK YOU
WERE GOING TO MEET THAT LINE
WHEN. A POST THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT I'M TRYING TO MEET THE
LINE.
NINE ONE FIVE SEVEN-
WE'RE GONNA OPEN A LINE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE ONE FOUR ONE FIVE
SEVEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR HAD
ONE FIVE SEVEN YES. OKAY MY
NAME IS THOUGHT YOU GONZALEZ I
REPRESENT WE WESTFELDT HELP
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION OVER TWO
HUNDRED HOMES I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND I WANT TO SAY
IT'S RACIST IN NATURE. SORRY
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. THE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE HAVE ONE ONE
SIXTY ONE ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THE LINE IS OPEN ONE SIXTY ONE.
ONE SIXTY ONE WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK.
ONE SIXTY ONE A PLEASE CHECK
YOUR MUTE FEATURE. I AM NOT
GETTING A RESPONSE AND A
CLOTHES LINE ONE SIXTY ONE.
ONE
MOMENT PLEASE FOR NEXT- PERSON
IN THE QUEUE WE HAVE LINE ONE
SIX NINE THE LINE IS OPEN ONE
SIX NINE. YES MY NAME IS CONNIE
CARE REPRESENTS SAN PASQUALE
OVER OIL CYCLE WILDLIFE HABITAT
PRESERVATION IN THE GARB BONTA
NEIGHBORHOOD IMPROVEMENT
ASSOCIATION IN HIGHLAND PARK.
AND I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
ANYTHING THAT CIRCUMVENT SYKORA
THANK YOU THANK YOU. IN BETTER.
HE DID FINE. IT'S FINE. ONE
MOMENT FOR NEXT CALL ONE MOM.
YEAH. I KNOW BUT FOR ONCE. ONE
HELLO MY NAME IS KATHY TAYLOR
AND THE PRESS PRO OF THE WEST
TO BE LIKE RED WHO AND LOS.
RUBBER OVER FIVE HUNDRED
HOUSEHOLDS AND REACHING SEVERAL
THOUSAND MORE WITH OUR
COMMUNITY NEWSLETTER I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE AMENDMENTS TO
THIS BILL- PLEASE DO NOT ALLOW
CIRCUMVENTION OF C. CORE THE
RENO ALLOCATIONS ARE INFLATED
WE NEED MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
NOT BUCKLEY HOUSING I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. SHE WAS PAID
THANK YOU. INTERESTING WE HAVE
THAT LINE YOU ONE MY FOR NOW
PERSON IN THE QUEUE. YES MY-
LEGAL BOTH. YEAH OKAY. ARE WE
pEIGHTY LINE. ONE EIGHT. MY
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE OPEN IF
YOU WISH TO. IN ONE EIGHTY NINE
IF YOU TO CHECK MUTE THREE WE
DO A LINE. FOR I AM NOT GETTING
A RESPONSE IN THE- THAT ONE.
RIGHT. HE LINE ONE NINETY FIVE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. MODERATE
COULD YOU PUT REPLY THAT THE
MUTE PHONES. YES WHEN THEY'RE
NOT ON. YES GO AHEAD PLEASE ONE
NINE FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS TOM NOW I LIVE IN
WHAT AND I NEEDED PM. HOW MUCH
TAXPAYER. AND I ESPECIALLY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE FIVE WILL MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT PERSON ONE MOMENT. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO ZERO ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD TWO ZERO ONE. HI AND
GAGHAN'S FRANKLIN COURT THE
COALITION IN HOLLYWOOD WE ARE
TOTALLY AGAINST THIS WE NEED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING YOU ARE
GOING TO GET AND STUFF ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU. PLEASE ME YOUR PHONE
IF YOU'RE- I HEAR CONVERSATIONS
THE FINAL MEETING HERE. MY
NUMBER TWO ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD TWO ZERO FOUR. WE HAVE A
CRABTREE I'M A RESIDENT OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND A
SUPPORTER OF THE NIXON NINE
CAMPAIGN I STRONGLY OPPOSE
KAREN IS THEM INCLUDING SENATE
BILL NINE OH TWO THANK YOU. I
HAVE ONE TWO ZERO SEVEN ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. HELLO HI PLEASE
GO AHEAD TWO ZERO SEVEN THANK
YOU MY NAME'S JENNIFER HEY GIVE
THEM A MEMBER OF THREE FIFTY
SAN FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA AND A
SUPPORTER OF MY SAN FRANCISCO
BLUE COLOR NEIGHBORS USED SMALL
TRUCKS TO SERVICE CLIENTS. I
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT CALLER.
NINE TWO ZERO EIGHT ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. TWO ZERO EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE RATIO PETROCELLI
WITH UNITED TO SAVE MISSION AND
THE MISSION IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT FOR NEXT PERSON IN Q. MY
NUMBER TO TAMERLAN TWO ONE ZERO
WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN. HELLO
I'M PAMELA GIVE REMAIN A MEMBER
OF THE PANORAMA CITY
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL CAN UNIT
LUXURY APARTMENT DO NOT LEAVE
THEN YOU'RE A LOW INCOME HOW.
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
ONE MOMENT FOR NEXT PERSON IN
THE QUEUE. THIS. MY NUMBER TWO
ONE FOUR ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WE'LL HAVE YOUR LINE AND MUTED
GO HEADLINE TWO ONE FOUR. MADAM
CHAIR NUMBERS KATE ON THE HIT
AROUND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL CLIPPERS WE WERE
OPPOSED BUT HAD MOVED TO
SUPPORT IF IT MEANT IT POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. MY NUMBER TWO
ONE SEVEN THAT PLANE TO
SEVENTEEN THE LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
RETURN ALL YOUR A LITTLE MONEY
BAIL OUT NO RELIEF TO LITTLE
CAL. BASED OUR NAME SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF B. NINE OKAY
ADD. WHY NUMBER TWO ONE NINE
THAT'S LINE TWO ONE NINE. WE
HAVE THAT LINE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH HEARING AND BALANCE
CALIFORNIA CALL TO IMPOSE-
SECOND CAN BUILD THE ROLE FOR.
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT FOR NEXT
PERSON IN. AND WHY NUMBER TWO
THREE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
TWO THREE FIVE WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN. HI THIS IS DEBBIE CAN
COUNT ON THE BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF HIDDEN HELD WE APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT I VOTER
INITIATIVE BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE LANGUAGE EXTENDED THE HIKE
AND MODERATE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ONE MOMENT FOR NEXT PERSON.
MY NUMBER TWO THREE EIGHT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO THREE
EIGHT THE LINE IS OPEN HI THIS
IS JOKE TO WORK WITH WELL
CALIFORNIA. OKAY THAT SPIDERS
COMMITTEE NAME. HAD COME UP WE
WILL TO CHANGE TO A FOR HOUSING
PLEASE NO MORE HAD WE DON'T IT
THANK YOU THINK YOU. ONE MORE
FOR IN A PERSON THE QUEUE.
ME
CHECK OUT MY NUMBER TWO FOUR
NINE TWO FOUR NINE ONE MOMENT.
I TWO FOUR NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU ROBIN
REDEVELOPMENT CITIZENS
PROTECTING SAN PEDRO IN LOS
ANGELES AND OUR ORGANIZATION
REQUEST THAT YOU AMEND THE BILL
TO EXEMPT THE COASTAL ZONE OF
SPECIAL BECAUSE THE COMMUNITIES
OF BENEFITS SAN PEDRO WHICH
HAVE BEEN PROTECTED IN THE
COASTAL ACT FOR ALL OVER THE
BALLOT MIGHT FOR OVER FOUR
YEARS OTHERWISE WE OPPOSE SB
NINE OH TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NO. THIS MAKES ME NERVOUS.
THE REQUESTED. HI FOUR FOUR
THREE REST. YEAH BECAUSE OF
AMBULANCE. OKAY. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER COLORS. I DON'T SEE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE KEY RIGHT
NOW OKAY WELL THEN WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE. YES
I'M A REAL QUICKLY YES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. YEAH I WANT TO THANK
THE SENATOR FOR. ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENT TO REMOVE THE
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD HAVE
PREVENTED A CITY COUNCIL TO
OVERTURN. VOTER APPROVED.
ORDINANCES I FOUND THAT- THAT
PARTICULAR LANGUAGE TO BE A
THREAT TO THE VALUES OF OUR
DEMOCRACY. AND EVEN IF YOU ARE.
A FORMER NEW JERSEY RESIDENT
I'M STILL GOING TO VOTE FOR THE
BILL. FOR THE RECORD FEMINISM
RIGHT TO LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO
FOR TWENTY THREE YEARS VERSUS
SEVENTEEN YEARS GROWING UP IN
NEW JERSEY SO. I THINK I HAVE-
FINALLY- COMES OVER THE DRUG.
CHARGE CLARIFICATION YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER. OR YES. I
REMEMBER BOLOGNA SOLVE WELL
PURSE SAYS PHIL THE FAMILY WAS
ACTUALLY LIVE IN A LIVING IN
CAMPS AT HI SO THAT THE CORRECT
QUALIFY AS- CLOSE TO A NATIVE I
GREW UP FIFTEEN OKAY. THEY ARE
LITTLE WE KNOW I WANTED I THANK
YOU FOR TAKING THE TO THAT YOU
REFER TO ON RELATING TO VOTER
IN AND VERY HIGH FIRE THAT'S-
BOTH OF THESE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO ADD TO
CONSTITUENTS- AND IN MY
DISTRICT BUT ALSO WHEN IT COMES
TO HI FIRES ON TECHNICA. ENOUGH
MANY OF OUR DISTRICTS AND-
CERTAINLY AROUND THE STATE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
AND THE OF THE VOTING ON THE
BILL. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YEAH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIX THANK YOU
CHAIR AND CENTER YOU FO BRING
THIS. BILL FOR. I KNOW MUCH AND
YOURSELF AMID TALK ABOUT ISSUE
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT- TO ME%
AND OTHER SOME ON THE STATUS OF
THAT DEALS WITH. CULTURAL
PRESERVATION AND- IN A VERY
JUST. OF NATIVE AMERICAN
REMAINS. AND I KNOW WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THE PRIOR BILL S.
B. THIRTY FIVE. YOU KNOW HOW
THERE'S ONGOING DIALOGUE TO
HOPEFULLY FIX SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE FIXED. AND SO MY
QUESTION ON THIS BILL- AND I
SEE IT. IN HERE- AS FAR AS
EXEMPTING- SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS FROM SEEK WHAT. SO
WOOD SB THIRTY FIVE. AND THIS
BILL ARE THEY KINDA LIKE CO
MINGLED. TOGETHER OR THEY
SEPARATE. WELL TO BE CLEAR I
THANK YOU AT SOME THEM FOR THE.
THE CHAIRS BILL AB ONE SIX
EIGHT. I TO CREATE A NEW. SB
THIRTY FIVE TRIBAL RE WE PASS
OUT PASS THAT OUR OF. THE
SENATE COMMITTEE WOULD CHARGE
WITH MY SERVE AND BECAUSE OF MY
SAID IT PASSED OUT YOU KNOW WE
DID WITHIN AGREEMENT WITH THE
CHAIR THAT WE WERE GOING TO.
CONTINUE TO WORK FINALIZE. THE
VERY SMALL NUMBER OF REMAINING
ISSUES I I'M VERY UP. NUMBER TO
PASS UP THE AND WE WILL HAVE TO
PROTECT THE- ARE FRANKLY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN INCLUDE AS FAR AS THE-
BY EVERYONE MESSED. INCLUDING
ALL COMMITTEES. SB THIRTY FIVE
ONE TWO INCLUDING THIS ONE
INCLUDING MANY TRIBAL LOBBYIST
WHO ARE. VERY CA TO BUILDING NO
CAUGHT IT AND SO BETTER LATE
THAN NEVER OWNED SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO PASSING THAT
LEGISLATION TO HAVE AN
EXEMPTION SB. THIRTY FIVE I'M
COMMITTED TO THAT WORK- IN
TERMS OF THIS BILL THIS BILL AS
I MENTIONED THE BEGINNING THIS
BILL DOES NOT. APPROVE SPECIFIC
PROJECTS. ALL RIGHT. SORRY IN
SAID THIS BILL THOSE ARE AND SO
THIS BILL DOES NOT STREAMLINE
PARTICULAR ARE PROJECTS SOMEONE
COULD A THIRTY. ON ANY PROJECT
THAT TO THE CITY THAT QUALIFY
AS FLOW THROUGH MINING- BUT
THIS BILL IN AND OF ITSELF.
DOES NOT. APPROVED PROJECTS
EITHER VIA SEEK WHAT SB THIRTY
FIVE OR ANY OTHER MECHANISM.
THANK YOU CENTER THANK YOU FOR
THAT HISTORY ON ON- HOW WE'VE
GOTTEN TO TODAY HOWEVER WE'RE
SITTING HERE TODAY AND IT'S A
VERY TRUE ISSUE THAT I BRING IT
UP AS FAR AS TRYING TO FIX
WHAT. WE WHAT WE DIDN'T HAVE IN
SB THIRTY FIVE AND TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS- BUT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT
DUPLICATING THAT- THAT ISSUE
AGAIN BECAUSE IN THIS BILL- IT
TALKS ABOUT DOES THIS BILL.
DOES YOUR BILL NINE OH TWO
DOESN'T EXAM SEQUEL. FIVE SIX
IF ALL RIGHT WELL. THE DOES NOT
EXEMPT SPECIFIC APPROVALS FROM
SIX WORK THE SAYS YOU DON'T
HAVE TO PLUS WHAT FOR THE RE.
THAT IS DONE ON P. IN THE
CITY'S CODE I THAT DOES NOT
APPROVE SPECIFIC PROJECTS EACH
PROJECT WILL STILL HAVE TO GO
THROUGH WHATEVER APPROVAL
PROCESS- WE'RE CURRENTLY EXIST
OUR FOR THAT KIND OF PROJECT-
AND THIS- DOES NOT CHANGE THAT
THANK YOU YEAH. FOR THE MIDDLE
AND IF I'M AND ONE OTHER THING
I MENTIONED THE- THE BINDING OR
THE WHEN YOU'RE DOING A PROJECT
LIKE AN EXCAVATION FINDING
REMAINS OR POTENTIAL ARTIFACTS-
TO BE CLEAR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT. WHEN YOU ARE DO BUILDING
A PROJECT THIS IS THAT WHICH IS
OF COURSE AFTER THE PROJECT'S
GONNA PROVE WHETHER IT'S VIA
STREAMLINE PROCESS SB THIRTY
FIVE C. QUOTE IF YOU ARE
EXCAVATING AND BUILDING- AND
YOU FIND SOMETHING THAT MAYBE.
REMAINS OR ARTIFACTS YOU HAVE
TO STOP AND GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW
THAT PROJECT GOT APPROVED. THE
RESPONSIBILITY UNDER LAW TO DO
THAT WHETHER IT'S SB THIRTY
FIVE OR SEQUEL AND THAT'S OF
COURSE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND
THAT IS IMPORTANT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT TOPIC UP BECAUSE
OF IF SPEAK WITHOUT EGGS THE IN
YOUR FACE IN THAT PROCESS BUT
HERE IN THE BILL AND PAGE TWO.
THIS IS THE WAS. IN ADOPTED
UNDER THESE PROVISIONS NOT A
PROJECT FOR PURPOSES OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT. SO I THINK THERE.
I'M STILL NOT. WHETHER IT DOES
OR DOESN'T SEE BUT I WOULD AND
I THE DIAL THAT'S ON WITH AB
ONE SIXTY A AND TRYING TO BRING
TYPE OF RESOLVE TO THAT
DISAGREEMENT THAT'S THERE- SO
HOW. WOULD WE END UP GOING BACK
TO THIS BILL NINE OH TWO ONCE
THAT DISCUSSIONS DONE HOPEFULLY
IT'S ONCE AND FOR ALL FAVORABLY
TOWARDS THE TRIBAL- ASPECT TO
IT. HOW DO WE THEN TAKE THAT
AND PUT IT INTO THIS BILL IF
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD TODAY
WAS A FIFTY TO BE CLEAR- AND
UNDERLYING REFERRED TO YEAH I'M
THAT YOU AYE. THAT IS CORRECT
WHEN THE CITY COUNCIL. A ZONING
THE KIND OF ZONING ORDINANCE
THOUGHTS OF IT TO SEE WHAT. BUT
AS OR DOES NOT APPROVE ANY
PROJECTS AND- AND SO SB ONE OR
AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT YEAH DOES
NOT APPLY TO A REZONING IF IT
PASSES WITH I. HOPE IT WILL AND
I BELIEVE A WELL THOUGHT OUT
REZONING A SPECIFIC PROJECT SO.
THIS BILL DOES NOT APPROVE
SPECIFIC PROJECTS WHICH IS ONE
EITHER AB FIFTY TWO PROJECTS UP
PROCESS WILL KICK IN OR IN AB
ONE SIXTY EIGHT. OUR PROCESS
ONCE I BILL- IT'S PAST INTO LAW.
NOW FOR A SPECIFIC APPROVAL
THIS IS ABOUT A REZONING THAT
DOES NOT APPROVE SPECIFIC
PROJECTS. SO IF ONE IF AB SO IF
EIGHTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT PASSES
ONCE THAT HAPPENS. THERE WILL
BE NO NEED TO MAKE ANY CHANGES.
TO AB ONE NOT MATTER TWO
BECAUSE ONE SIXTY EIGHT WILL
FLY. TO ANY SB THIRTY FIVE
PROJECT. REGARDLESS OF. WHAT
NINE OH TWO SAYS TO WOULD NOT
INTERACT. THANK YOU. BURKE
EGGNOG THAT THAT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING NOW CULTURAL RESOURCE
IN IN REMAINS THAT ARE THERE
THAT OMEHOW GOT THROUGH ALL
THE DIFFERENT CA OF THE LAW BUT
YOU'RE WILLING TO ADDRESS AND
TO COME TO SEE TYPE OF FOR IT
MY QUESTION IS STILL AS WHY
WOULD WHY WOULD WE MOVE
FORWARD- WHAT NINE OH TWO ONE
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON FIXING
THAT PART OF IT IN AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT AND THEN COULD BE. PART
OF EVERYTHING MOVING FORWARD
AND WE HEARD SOME OTHER BILLS
TODAY TO THAT DOUBT ALONG THIS
AREA SO WELL THROUGH THE CHAIR
SORRY FOR YEAH I MEAN I
OFTENTIMES CHECK YOU'RE FINE
THROUGH GOVERNMENT OBVIOUSLY AS
WE GO AND THIS WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE BILLS IN VARIOUS HOUSING
BILLS UP IN BOTH HOUSES AND THE
AND THE BODY RESPECT BODIES
WILL. CONSIDER THEM WE. YEAH WE
HAVE OPEN TRIED. LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS EVERYTHING. MOVES
FORWARD DOESN'T MOVE FORWARD AT
THE SAME TIME AND AGAI. AB
NINE OH TWO THERE'S NOT
APPROVED SPECIFIC PROJECTS
WHICH IS ONE. EIGHT SB NINE TO
THE APPROVED SERVER PROJECT. I
THOUGHT THE PRICE APPROVAL.
THAT EITHER A FIFTY TWO OR THE
FUTURE AB ONE SIXTY. WHAT KICK
AT. NOT BECAUSE OF OTHER. IT'S
ABOUT THIS. PROJECT OF. AND
THAT'S WHY IF IT ONE EIGHT WERE
TO BE AN ACT INTO LAW WHICH I
HOPE BE. THERE WOULD BE NO NEED-TO MAKE A- MODEL. OR CONFORM
AND AB AND ASKING I KNOW TO.
THANK YOU ANTI YOU CENTER I
KNOW WE'VE TALKED A LOT ON THIS
IS AND THERE'S OTHER ISSUES ARE
OUT THERE THAT. YOU KNOW IF WE
COULD END UP. FINDING AN AREA
RESOLVE- AROUND SB THIRTY FIVE
AND THEN COMING TO SOME TERMS
WITH THEM. AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT
IT WOULD MAKE IT A LOT EASIER.
TO UNDERSTAND- THIS BILL MOVING
FORWARD AND TAKING THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION HOWEVER. YOU KNOW
THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE YEARS OF
NEGLECT SO MANY YEARS OF
NEGLECT THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
HEARING IN THIS ROOM HERE
WITHIN THE HOUR. THE DEALS WITH
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
NATIVE AMERICAN REMAINS STILL
IN THE UC SYSTEM. AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THAT AND YOU STILL LOOK
AT THE DEVELOPMENT NOW IT'S NOT
TO HAND DEVELOPMENT. BUT WE
HAVE TO BE CLEAR CLEAR ON WHAT
IT IS. THAT WERE DOING MOVING
FALL. THANK AGAIN FOR KNOWLEDGE
BUT IN THE PAST THE THERE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT WERE CLEAR BUT
WE'RE AT THE ROAD. AT IS FOR ME
I STILL A LOT CONCERN THAT
MOVING FORWARD HERE WE'RE NOT
ADDRESSING THAT. RIGHT AND TO
NOW HAVE HEARING OF OVER
HUNDRED THOUSAND AMERICAN
REMAINS I WANT TO BE CLEAR FOR
SELF. MOVE VOTE THAT ACTUALLY
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION. VOICE
OF THE CAP AND YOU WILL NOT.
SIT HERE IN FRONT OF YOU. WHAT
THE VOICE OF THE CAL THE PEOPLE
THAT. LAY WITH. US IN THE STATE
OF. THANK YOU. RIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ANY OTHER I CAN. RETAIN
A MOTION. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION IN THE SAN LET'S SEE
CLOSE STAY. SENATE WIENER HI I
READ ASK FOR AYE VOTE THANK SIR
WE I APPRECIATE THE IN OF THIS
BILL TOOK ENCOURAGE BECAUSE
MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING AND
EASES UP ZONING PROCESS FOR
COUNTIES AND CITIES. CALIFORNIA
HAS SEVERE HOUSING SHORTAGE
MOST MOST COUNTIES AND CITIES
ARE CONTENDING WITH SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASES IN THE ARENA
REQUIREMENTS. OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE ALSO SUFFERING
FROM THE FINANCIAL STRAINS OF
COVERT NINETEEN HAS CREATED
WHICH PLACES PRESSURE ON THEIR
PLANNING DEPARTMENTS. I SUPPORT
EFFORTS TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OVERCOME THESE
CHALLENGES. WELL THIS BILL IS
PERMISSIVE WHAT IT DOES ALLOWED
LOCAL ELECTED BODIES TO DO
REMAINS PROBLEMATIC FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS. ALLOWING THE
ADOPTION OF AN ORDINANCE
WITHOUT SEQUEL REVIEW THAT
COULD ALLOW HOUSING ON A SITE
THAT HAS NOT BEEN EVALUATED FOR
RESIDENTIAL USE INCLUDING THE
POSSIBILITY OF REZONING
COMMERCIAL SITES TO RESIDENTIAL
USES. IT CONCERNS ME. SKIPPING
WORK IN THE ZONING PROCESS
WOULD SEE WHAT COULD ALSO BE
BYPASS WITH THE EVENTUAL
HOUSING PROJECT ON THE SAME
PARCEL CONCERNS ME. ESPECIALLY
WHEN THE PROJECT LEVEL
STREAMLINING HAS NOT ADEQUATELY
PROTECTIVE ALL SENSITIVE AND
VALUABLE RESOURCES. I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU FOR TAKING THE
ADOPTED THE AMENDMENT FOR
ALLOWING INDUCTION OF THE
ORDINANCE A COMPLEX WITH THE-
WISHES THE VOTERS. ALSO ZONING
I APPRECIATE THAT. TODAY
THOUGH- I CANNOT SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY I WILL LEAVE IT TO
EACH OF MY COLLEAGUES TO DECIDE
FOR THEMSELVES OF THIS BILL
PROVIDES ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS.
FOR THEIR INCOME FOR THEIR
CONCERT CONSTITUENTS. MOTION TO
IS TO DO PASS AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
INCLUDING NOT VOTING
AGUIAR-CURRY NOT VOTING LACKEY.
LACKEY I'D BLOOM. LOOM II
BURNER. NO BOERNER HORVATH NOW
RAMOS. LUCE RAMOS NOT VOTING
THREE OF US THREE OF US I'D
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL VOEPEL HI.
TELL US NOT FIVE TWO TAKE YOUR
CALL ONE THANK YOU. AND SORRY
FOR ALL THE- OKAY- I BELIEVE.
YEAH LET ME JUST CAN ONE THING
BEFORE WE MOVE ON- I WAS TOLD I
NEEDED TO SEND SOME PEOPLE DONE
APPROPRIATIONS FOR A QUICK
QUOTE AND THEN WE CAN START
BACK UP I HATE TO DO THAT TO
EVERYBODY BUT I THINK WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE PROCREATION.
THOUSAND VOTES SO THOSE OF YOU
THAT THE WAITING I THINK IT'S
MR VOEPEL MR BLOOM AND- MYSTERY
OF US YOU TOO. IF YOU CAN MAKE
A QUICK AND THEN WE'LL DO A
FINAL BILL. YEAH YEAH RIGHT
OKAY WHY OF THE PLAN ON
ATTENDING RECESS RIGHT NOW AND
AGAIN I HAVE TO EVERYONE BUT
THEY HAVE TO HAVE OUR. FREESHIP
HI YOU'RE GONNA PROJECT YEAH
YEAH YOU CAN HEAR THIS ONE
SHOULDN'T TAKE TOO MUCH. YEAH A-
MORTON'S. OKAY NICE.WE'RE OKAY.
REYES WHAT.
YEAH MICHAEL GRAB
THAT REAL QUICK I'LL BE RIGHT
BACK UP. YEAH YEAH YEAH I HEARD
I SPOKE ABOUT. THE SERVER I
DIDN'T. HI MY. RIGHT.
YES THEY.
YEAH I ALWAYS VERY VERY MUCH.
NUMBER. YEAH I'VE GOT TO GIVE
EVERYTHING YOU HAVE DONE.
OKAY
WE'RE GONNA RECONVENE- I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS FOR DOING SB ONE FORTY
SIX ON BEHALF OF SENATOR BILL
AND- IF YOU'D LIKE TO START
WHEN IT'S CONVENIENT YEP THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR BELL. LET
ME START BY ACCEPTING ALL OF
THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND PER THE- FOR
THE- FOR THE SENATOR HE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THE
WORK ON THIS BILL. AND AS WE
ALL KNOW THE PANDEMIC HAS HAD A
VERY DRAMATIC IMPACT ON OUR
STATE AND THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT THIS PANDEMIC IS IMPACTED
THE WAY TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES. THE WAY THAT THEY DO
THEIR BUSINESS. AND SO WHILE
OUR RESIDENTS ARE BEING ASKED
TO STAY HOME AND ONLY TRAVEL TO
CARRY OUT ESSENTIAL BUSINESS.
TRANSPORTATION AND TRANSIT
AGENCIES ARE STILL REQUIRED TO
ENSURE TRANSIT REMAINS IN
OPERATION. THAT OUR STREETS AND
HIGHWAYS ARE SUITABLE FOR
TRAVEL AND THAT VARIOUS OTHER
REQUIREMENTS ARE STILL MATT.
THIS LEGISLATION SENATE BILL
ONE FOUR SIX. WOULD PROVIDE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES WITH A
DEEP POOL. YES PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT PRACTICE IS. IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR
SUSTAINABLE- THE COMMUNITY
STRATEGY. WITH COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THIS LEGISLATION
SIMPLY INSURERS. AND PROVIDES
THE NECESSARY CLARIFICATION
THAT TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES
HAVE THE OPTION. TO HOLD
INFORMAL NOT BERMAN ACT
MEETINGS ELECTRONICALLY WITH
OPTION WHEN THEY ARE. DID HELP
IN BOOKING STRATEGIES. REALLY
ONE OF THE MANY ON A ISSUES OR
FALLOUT FROM OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS IS MAINTAINING AN
EFFICIENT FLOW OF LOCAL AND
STATE. OUR GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS WHY AS SHE THAT
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO ENCOURAGE PUBLIC.
PARTICIPATION SO ACCORDING TO
SENATOR BELL OPERATING IN OUR
CURRENT ENVIRONMENT NO HOLDING
MEETINGS AND HEARINGS VIRTUALLY
OVER THE INTERNET HAVE ACTUALLY
INCREASED THE PARTICIPATION OF
OUR PUBLIC. ALL THINGS.
CONSIDERED THIS MEASURE CLEARLY
MOVES US IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
AND BRIGGS EXISTING LAW AND
ALIGNMENT WITH THE TECHNOLOGY
WE HAVE AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW- AT
THIS TIME. SO A WITNESS FOR
THIS BILL THAT IS WITH US BY
PHONE HIS REBEKAH LONG FROM THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. AND THE ASSOCIATION
OF BAY AREA. GOD BECOME
GOVERNMENT SORRY A BAG REBECCA
IS ALSO AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE WITH
THAT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RETURNS- WE'LL MOVE ON
TO OVER A WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
HE RAN FOR US. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT WHILE WE
GET THERE LIKE GIVE THEM THEIR
LINE NUMBER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL BE JUST ONE MORE
MOMENT ONE MOMENT THANKS. MY
NUMBER IS THREE HUNDRED AND
FOUR NINE THREE ZERO FOUR YOU
MAY GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES SIR I AM CALLING TO OPPOSE
THE BILL. I FIGURE THAT'S NOT
REALLY AN- EXTRA ALERTS FOR THE
MUSIC EXCUSE ME GROUP CURRENTLY
WORK TAKING- PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF YOU'D
LIKE TO STAY IN THE QUEUE THEN
YOU CAN DO THAT WHEN WE DO
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL BE JUST ANOTHER MOMENT
AS A REMINDER IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. THEN ZERO AGAIN IF
YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. SO
MY NUMBER'S THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE LINE THREE THREE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT WOULD
BE JUST ONE MORE MOMENT. ALL
THERE CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN YES WE CAN WONDERFUL ALL
RICHARD NO LONGER SPEAKING
SOLELY ON MY OWN BEHALF I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL IT
IS WELL DOCUMENTED THAT PUBLIC
COMMENT DRAWS A RICHER WHITER
OLDER MAILER AND MORE
CONSERVATIVE AUDIENCE THE OPRAH
MAKES PUBLIC COMMENT MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO EVERYONE. THANK
YOU PASSED THIS BILL. ONCE
AGAIN I IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY
PAD. HI THERE MY NAME'S REBECCA
LONG AND- I WAS FIFTY ONE OF
BELIEVE WITNESSES THAT. LEFT
MOMENTARILY DURING THE RECESS-
I'M THE MANAGER OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
THE ASSOCIATION OF VERY
GOVERNMENT'S COMMONLY KNOWN AS
AND KEEP THE IN A BAG. AGENCIES
ARE JOINTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
ADOPTING THE BAY AREA
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
STRATEGY ON THE NEXT VERSION OF
WHICH IS CALLED PLAN BAY AREA
TWENTY FIFTY. WILL BE ADOPTED
AND FALL OF NEXT YEAR WE
SUPPORT SB ONE FORTY SIX THAT
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT THE
DIGITAL ENGAGEMENT EFFORTS WE
ARE CONDUCTING PLAN AREA WILL
SATISFY STATE REQUIRED. EVEN
FOR SHELTER IN PLACE ORDER BUT
DID WHICH HOPE WILL HAPPEN NEXT
FALL. IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
HE'S HE WAS AN EARLY SUPPORTER
SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE. THAT
LANDMARK LINKING LONG RANGE
TRANSPORT PLAN TO THE STATE'S
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
EFFORT. TWELVE YEARS AND ALMOST
THREE SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
STRATEGIES LATER WE'VE LEARNED
A LOT INCLUDING THAT WHILE WELL
INTENDED SOME OF THE- PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT PROVISIONS NEED
UPDATING AS THEY'RE OUT OF SYNC
WITH BEST. PRACTICES FOR
SEEKING PUBLIC INPUT ESPECIALLY
DURING A PANDEMIC. LAST FALL WE
BEGIN OUR PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT ON
PLAN VERY TWENTY FIFTY WITH
OVER THREE DOZEN IN PERSON POP
UP OUTREACH EVENTS ACROSS ALL
NINE COUNTIES. AT VARIOUS
LOCATIONS SUCH AS FARMERS
MARKETS LIBRARIES AND JOB FAIRS
TRYING TO MEET PEOPLE WHERE
THEY'RE AT. THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THESE EVENTS WERE LOCATED IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
CONCERN AND WE RECEIVED OVER
THREE THOUSAND COMMENTS THAT
INFORM THE NEXT STAGE OF THE
PLANNING PROCESS. DESPITE THIS
GREAT RESPONSE FROM THERE AND
RESIDENTS MANY OF WHOM WOULD
NOT HAVE KNOWN WHAT ANYTHING
ABOUT PLAN BAY AREA HAD WE NOT
ATTENDED THESE EVENTS. NONE OF
THAT INPUT COUNT TOWARDS LAWS
PLEINEMENT. THAT WE CAN. TWENTY
ALL PUBLIC WHAT JOB. OF COURSE
WE CAN'T HOLD IN. PULLED
WORKSHOP AND IT'S TANDEM SO
IT'S GOING. WELL WITHIN A-
INCREASE IN ATTENDANCE COMPARED
FOR IN PERSON MEETINGS PLUS
GREATER PARTICIPATION BY
YOUNGER RESIDENTS. FROM VIRTUAL
WORKSHOPS TO TELEPHONE
TELEPHONE TOWN HALLS HELD IN
SPANISH CANTONESE AND MANDARIN
AS WELL AS ENGLISH. WE ARE
ENHANCING ACCESS AND REACHING A
WIDER AND MORE DIVERSE SET OF
RESIDENTS THAN EVER. AND WHILE
WE ALL EAGERLY AWAIT THE DAY
WHEN WE IN PERSON MEETINGS CAN
RESUME SAFELY. THERE ARE SOME
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS TO VIRTUAL
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT AS A MEANS TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO MORE
STAKEHOLDERS THAN TYPICALLY
ATTEND IN PERSON MEETINGS. IN
CLOSING I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB ONE FORTY
SIX WHICH WILL ENABLE US TO
CONTINUE THE EXTENSIVE EFFORTS
WE ARE UNDERTAKING. TO HEAR
FROM AREA RESIDENTS DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND RECEIVE CREDIT FOR
SUCH EFFORTS THIS PLANNING
CYCLE. THANK CENTER BELL FOR
AUTHORING THE BILL MADAM CHAIR
AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
LONG KNOWN OTHER ANY OTHER OF.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. MODERATOR
YOU CAN OPEN YOUR- IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE FOUR
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
YOU HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU ARE
WE GOING TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE TO IN
OPPOSITION SHE DOES IT I IS A-
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND AMY
HARTMAN FROM CLIMATE PLAN.
WELCOME. HELLO THANK YOU FOR
BEING IN THE LEADERSHIP COUNSEL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE ARE GOING THANK LEADERSHIP
IN COMMUNITIES ACROSS AND WORLD
AND THE SAN JOAQUIN EASTERN
COACHELLA VALLEY'S WE HAVE
SUPPORTED THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
PROPHECIES AND EACH OF THE
COUNTIES THAT WEWORK AND
RELIED ON ALL REQUIREMENTS FOR
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE COMMENTS MADE
ALREADY TO ENSURE A BROADER
PARTICIPATION IN A MORE
MEANINGFUL PARTICIPATION
HOWEVER WITH THE BEST INTEREST
THE PARTY PROCESS AND THE
COMMUNITIES IT SERVES AND MINE
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. AS IT STANDS AND CRACKED.
THE PUBLIC TO BE ONE FORTY SIX
WHAT ARE AWARE RECOMMENDED
PRESENT IN THE IN OUR- AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT MOVING AND
RIGHT TO. WE DO STILL HAVE
TROUBLE OR MANY CONCERNS IN THE
BILL IN PRINT HOWEVER. ONE OF
OUR MAIN CONCERN TO DEVELOP
THAT CURRENT LAW ALREADY ALLOWS
FOR NOT MEETING THE NEXT TIME.
AND HE WOULD ALREADY HAVE
FLEXIBILITY WITHIN THE SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION ACQUIREMENT TO
TAKE MEETINGS ABOUT- AND WE
BELIEVE THAT- ADJUSTING OKAY
STRATEGY HAS ACTUALLY ALREADY
BEEN- APPROVED AND DESKTOP
COAST REGION VIRTUALLY- AT THIS
TIME. SO MEETING CAN AND MUST
HAVE COME UP REMOTE
PARTICIPATION OPTIONS AT MANY
AGENCIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA HAVE
PROVIDED A CONSIDERABLE
EXPERIENCE WITH AT THAT POINT.
FURTHERMORE WE GIVE STORE
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE BILL R. F.
THANK THAT ORDER. BACK BEFORE
THE TO YOUR OF SB ONE FORTY
SIX. ADDITIONALLY THE NUMBER
MEETINGS IN HERE AND ORIGINAL
DR FOR PUBLIC REVIEW. ARE WE
APPRECIATE THAT OF THE STORE IN
THE IN THE- AND I WORK THREE D.
ON WHICH ARE TRYING TO PLANNING
WE HAVE RELIED ON ALL EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS ASSEMBLY FUTURE
CRIME AND SHOULD ONLY BE
STRENGTH IN THE TIME.
REGARDLESS OF THE MEETING BEING
DEFINED AS A WORKSHOP OR
GATHERING EVERY PUBLIC MEETING
MUST BE REQUIRED MULTIPLE
PARTICIPATION OPTIONS INCLUDING
VIDEO CONFERENCE CALL AND. AND
SAFE IN PERSON PARTICIPATION.
WHAT WE KNOW PROJECT. ARE AT
GREAT. RIGHT NOW IS NOT THE
TIME BE RELAXING THE STANDARD
FOR COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
BEYOND THE ESSENTIAL
FLEXIBILITY FOR MOUNT MEETING
FORMATS WHICH CURRENT LAW
ALREADY ALLOWS. YOU KNOW THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC HAS MADE
IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
COMMITTEES WITHOUT ACCESS TO
BROADBAND. FOR COMPUTING
DEVICES TO ENGAGE IN PUBLIC
PROCESS HE IS. THAT CREATIVE
AND VARIOUS MEETING FORMATS
MUST BE EMPLOYED TO REACH THE
COMMITTEES ESSENTIAL PROP THAT.
INSTEAD OF DECREASING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION OAK REQUIREMENTS
IN SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE. IN A
CONDENSED LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
NPOS AND LEGISLATORS SHOULD BE
DIRECTING EFFORTS TOWARDS
ENSURING COMMITTEES ACCESS
REMOTE MEETING. THE MANY
WORKING ON A COMMITTEE STRUCK.
WALKING AROUND AND EVEN ON A TO
ATTEND THAT HEARING. THEY'RE
MORE OR URGENT NEED A CROWN
WHICH RIGHT NOW HE BELIEVES
THAT THIS. IS NOT AN
APPROPRIATE TIME TO BE LOOKING
AT THIS CHANGE TO PARTICIPATION
APARTMENTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. IN HER NAME FROM CLIMATE
PLAN. I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
DOCTORS OFFICE PLANNED TO TAKE
A WOULD BE AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED BY THE COMMITTEE
AND IF THIS IS A QUICKLY WITH
LIKELY FACILITATE A
CONVERSATION WITH OUR PARTNERS
TO UNDERSTAND IF WE SHOULD
MAINTAIN OUR CURRENT APPROACH
ADMISSION- WE WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT PUBLIC PARTICIPATION AND
ENGAGEMENT ARE AN ONGOING
CHALLENGE ESPECIALLY FOR MORE
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. LIKE
THAT HAVE BEEN SILENT FOR
YEARS. THAT MAKE ISSUES SO IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ME OR PUBLIC
DEBATE MEANT TO COMMUNITIES ARE
SHAPING THEIR OWN NEIGHBORHOOD
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
PHYSICAL DIFFERENCE IN
REQUIREMENT FROM CO THE
NINETEEN. WE WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
OFFICE OFFICE AND OTHERS TO
ENSURE THAT WE DEVELOP
SOLUTIONS TO MAXIMIZE PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT AND A CO CREATED
WITH A TWO AT THE MOST.
IMPACTED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY. OR
THE OTHER I WOULD AND-
MODERATOR CAN YOU. IF YOU ARE
YES IT IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
OF SB ONE FOUR SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. ONE
FOUR SIX. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IS THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU KNOW TEN
EMOTION HELLO YOUR MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LUCKY. A SECOND
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REVIEWS THANK
YOU FOR STANDING IN FOR CENTER
BILL APPRECIATE THE NEED FOR
FLEXIBILITY DURING THESE TRYING
TIMES AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE RESIDENTS ARE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS IMPORTANT
PLANNING PROCESS MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED. ACT HI A
LACKEY. LACKEY I'D BLOOM. BLOOM
I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I'D RAMOS.
RAMOS HI THREE OF US
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL. VOEPEL
HI. FIFTY EIGHT ZERO BILL IS
THEM OKAY- WE ARE GOING TO DO
SOME HOUSEKEEPING HERE BEFORE I
MOVE ON I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
OF MY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE AFOR ALL THE HARD
WORK OF THIS IS BEEN AS YOU ALL
KNOWS TRYING TIMES TRYING TO
MAKE SURE WE DOT THE I'S AND
CROSS THE TEASE THANK YOU TO
INITIAL MATCHUP JAMIE MACDONALD
HANK BRADY DIXIE PETTY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY IS- SHANNON FLORES
SHE IS OUR YOUNG FELLOW AND I'M
YOU KNOW THE FELLOWS OF HAD A
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE THIS YEAR.
AND DESPITE EVERYTHING THE SHOW
LADY HAS BEEN FOCUSED AND DONE
AN INCREDIBLE JOB IN TRYING TO
BE VERY MINDFUL OF THE
SITUATION WE'RE IN SO I WANT TO
THE PROJECT A SHOUT OUT TO
SHANNON FLORES SAID. TODAY HEY
SHANNON. OKAY SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL FOR THOSE ABSENT OR
NOT VOTING FOR BILLS ON CALL
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE ADD ONS
PLEASE. SB ELEVEN TWENTY ATKINS
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR TO ONE.
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH VOEPEL.
FORTY ONE. REPORTER BILLS SEEK
THAT WAS ELEVEN TWENTY. DID HE
RECEIVED A VOTE OR NOT- VOEPEL
DID TO EXCUSE ME PRETTY GOOD SO
SORRY I'M SO SORRY I DIDN'T I
DID NOT HEAR YOU YEAH RIGHT
HERE VOEPEL AYE. OKAY OKAY WE
ALL OF HER HEART JUST DROPPED.
OKAY VOEPEL I. BILL IS FIVE TO
ONE A BILL IS ABOUT. HAVE THANK
YOU. I'M SURE THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT LIKE A FAINT SOMETHING THAT
HAVE BEEN OF THE SENATE. SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE COLYANDRO
AND- RUBIO ADDED MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND RE REFER TO COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT
VOTE IS THREE TO BLOOM.
BOERNER HORVATH THREE OF US.
THREE TWO TWO BILL FAILS. SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE GLAZER THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS FRONT VOTE
IS FOUR TWO THREE. RAMOS RAMOS
I. THREE BILLS UP FIVE TO THREE.
THREE HAVE A COUPLE OF ADAMS.
AT SB. TEN FORTY NINE. THE
MOTION IS A TEN POINT NINE A
SENATOR GLAZER MOTION IS TO
PASS RAMOS. ALMOST I. IT'S AN
ADD ON THE BILL HAS ALREADY OUT
BECAUSE THIS UP OKAY YEAH. AND
THE CONSENT CALENDAR- DO PASS-
VOEPEL. RIGHT VOEPEL HI THAT
THOSE ARE YEAH OKAY. I THINK
THAT'S EVERYTHING. CORRECT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO
SORRY WE'RE NOT MEETING IN.